THOSE OF YOU WHO.
ARE WONDERING WE WILL GO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND IN ORDER ON THE
AGENDA WE WILL START WITH ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ISSUE NUMBER ONE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
EACH OF THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY IS EITHER A HOLD OPEN ITEM
OR AN INFORMATIONAL ITEMS WILL
BE WE WILL BE TAKING NO VOTES
TODAY.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE WAITING
[inaudible]
FOR SOMEONE.
SO MAKE YOURSELF COMFORTABLE SIR
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE
[inaudible]
FACILITIES [inaudible]
OR I SEE.
WE'RE NOT USUALLY THIS ORGANIZED
BUT PART OF THE PROBLEM IS WE
HAD A CAUCUS AFTER SESSION AND
SO NOBODY KNEW HOW LONG THE ****
IS EXAM LAST SO WE COULDN'T SAYS.
THE CIVICS ARE TIMES OR HAVE
BEEPING PEOPLE WHO ARE -- NOT
ELECTED IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHEN TO SHOW UP DOWN HERE AND
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT WE MADE
THEIR JOB ABOUT AS DIFFICULT AS
WE POSSIBLY COULD UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES SO.
WE'RE GOING TO SHIFT GEARS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
FACILITIES FIRST.
AND TALK ABOUT THAT AND THEN
FIGURE OUT WHO'S AROUND.
TO DEAL WITH THE OTHER ISSUES
AND PERHAPS WE'LL START BACK IN
ORDER ON THE AGENDA SO ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR AT FACILITIES.
GENTLEMAN IF YOU'D IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD
STARTING TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT.
AT THE CONTROL OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RALPH THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
READY CATS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IT JUST GETS CHRISTIAN US MANY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START THIS.
ONE THANK YOU SENATOR ROSS --
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
MILLION IN GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND A FORTY FOUR FIFTEEN
CONTINUING AND FIFTEEN NEW
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROJECTS
STATEWIDE. FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSALS BE APPROVED SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION OF
THE TWO BILLION IMPROV FIFTY ONE
FUNDS PROVIDED FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD BE OBLIGATED.
CONSISTENT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CRITERIA FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING FOR A
STATEWIDE THE PROJECT
RECOMMENDED FOR FUNDING ADDRESS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FIRE
LIFE SAFETY ISSUES.
WELL FIRE LIFE SAFETY ISSUES
AREN'T NECESSARILY THE SOLE
REASON FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROJECT TO BE CONSIDERED FOR
FUNDING IT SHOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT DRIVER.
WHEN DETERMINING WHICH PROJECTS
TO BE FUNDED THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERS WHETHER A REQUESTING
DISTRICT CAN PROVIDE SOME LEVEL
OF FUNDING MATCH OR IF THERE ARE
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
PREVENTED DISTRICT FROM
CONTRIBUTING?
AN EXAMPLE OF THE LATTER WOULD
INCLUDE REDWOOD COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT A SMALL
DISTRICT WAS SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS RESULTING
FROM RECENT SEISMIC ANALYSES --
WE NOTE THAT CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
APPROACH AND THAT IT WOULD
CREATE -- I BELIEVE THAT --
CREATE A DISINCENTIVE FOR
DISTRICTS TO MAINTAIN THE
FACILITY -- HOWEVER WE DISAGREE
THAT -- COLLEGES WOULD PURPOSELY
ALLOW THEIR BUILDINGS TO FALL
INTO DISREPAIR IN ORDER TO
ACCESS THE REMAINING ONE POINT
THREE BILLION AND ON OBLIGATED
PROP FIFTY ONE FONT -- WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT -- FOR PART OF
THE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALREADY KNOW
IT'S A SIXTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLAR.
NEED IN STATE FUNDS ARE SO AS
WELL IN EXCESS OF WHAT REMAINS.
WELL I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS BUT I
THINK I'LL WAIT TO EVERYBODY
ELSE THE PRESENTS -- ROLE WITH
THE LA -- SO WE HAVE TO TO
GENERAL -- COMMENTS ON UNRELATED
TO COMMIT CALLED FACILITIES.
FIRST IT'S MORE OF A HIGH LEVEL --
SHOULD TERMS OF THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PROJECTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS BUDGET.
I'M AS WE NOTED IN OUR ANALYSIS
THERE -- THIS ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROOF SUBSTANTIALLY MORE
PROJECTS THAN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION HAD INCLUDED.
WE THINK THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK WE HAVE --
CONCERNS IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
THAT -- THERE WERE NOT VERY MANY
PROJECTS APPROVED IN THE BUDGET
AND THAT THAT MEANS WE WOULD BE
A VERY SLOW PACE TO EXHAUST THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FROM PROP.
FIFTY ONE I'M EVEN NOW WITH
THESE ADDITIONAL -- PROJECTS
APPROVED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WERE STOLEN PACE FOR
ABOUT EIGHT OR NINE YEARS UNTIL --
PROP FIFTY ONE FUNDING WOULD BE
COMPLETELY EXHAUSTED.
AND WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER --
APPROVING EVEN MORE PROJECTS IN
THE IN THE BUDGET CONSIDERING
THAT THE THE REASON WHY --
PROPERTY ONE FUNDS HAVE BEEN SO
SLOW IN GETTING ROLLED OUT IS
NOT BECAUSE OF THE MAN FROM THE
COLLEGES AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
YOUR AGENDA.
ON PAGE TWENTY SEVEN IS A AN
ENTIRE PAGE OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THAT WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET.
I'M SO WE DO THINK THAT YOU ARE
YOU MIGHT ANT TO CONSIDER
ADDING ADDITIONAL -- OFF OF THE
ONE BOND SPENDING TO TO FIND
MORE PROJECTS.
AND THE THE SECOND ISSUE IS --
MR GOVERNMENTS IN LITTLE BIT AS
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
THE WAY THAT FINANCE IS LOOKING
AT THESE -- LEASING LACKED THE
LIFE SAFETY CRITERIA AS A FILTER
FOR DECIDING WHICH PROJECTS TO
INCLUDE -- WE ARE CONCERNED THAT --
THE THE FIFTH MEANS THAT THERE
ARE SOME PROJECTS -- THAT ARE
THAT IT THAT IT YOU KNOW YOU'RE
APPROVING A PROJECT IN SOME
DISTRICTS WHERE THEY DONE A POOR
JOB OF MAINTAINING THE BUILDINGS --
BUT THE THE CHANCES OF IT HAS A
LONG ESTABLISHED APPROACH -- TO
PROVING PROJECT AND THEY HAVE A
LIFE FIFTY CATEGORY SPECIFICALLY
TO HAVE SOME SPECIFIC RULES.
AND THEN THEY HAVE SEVERAL OTHER
CATEGORIES THAT ARE NOT ABOUT
LIFE EITHER ABOUT INCREASING
INSTRUCTIONAL CAPACITY AND
MODERNIZING FACILITIES -- WE
DON'T THINK THAT WITH THOSE
THOSE CATEGORIES THERE NEEDS TO
BE THERE ADDITIONAL LIFE FIFTY
LINES AND THE WAY THAT THE THE
THIS APPROACH PLAYS OUT IS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE. FOR EXAMPLE --
TO TO DISTRICTS WHERE
APPLICATIONS TO HAVE A THIRTY
YEAR OLD BUILDINGS MODERNIZED.
AND EVERYONE DISTRICT HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB OF MAINTAINING THEIR
BUILDING SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY LIKE SAFETY ISSUES.
THEY ARE WOULD BE WOULD GET LEFT
PRIOR EVEN A DISTRICT WHO'S
THIRTY YEAR OLD BUILDING IS IN
PAIN -- DISREPAIR I'M SO WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT SENDING THE WRONG
SIGNALS TOOK TO COMPLETE COLLEGE
OF AND SO WE WE WOULD RECOMMEND --
THAT WE RECOMMEND DIRECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE CHANCES
OFFICE TO DEVELOP ONE SET OF
CRITERIA -- FOR IDENTIFYING --
UP FRONT -- FOR DECIDING HOW TO
ADDRESS LIKE FIFTY PROJECTS.
WE WE WE KNOW ALSO IN ADDITION
TO US HAVING CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
WE ALSO HAVE HEARD FROM
DISTRICTS THAT THEY'RE JUST VERY
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY THE
PROCESS IF AND WHAT WHAT IS THE
WHAT IS THE RATIONALE FOR
WHETHER PROJECTS ARE BEING
REJECTED -- IF IF THERE CAN'T BE
AN AGREEMENT IF THE LEDGES THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S CAN COME TO AN
AGREEMENT THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THE LET'S SAY YOU
COULD CODIFY SOMETHING IN
STATUTE.
THAT MADE THAT -- HAS AN
APPROACH THAT DOES -- HAVE A
PROCESS OF THE DISTRICTS CAN GET
FUNDING FOR LIFE SAFETY ISSUES
WHILE STILL ENSURING THAT THERE
IS A STRONG FISCAL INCENTIVE TO
MAINTAIN YOUR BUILDINGS.
RIGHT ARM.
YOUR AGENDA DUKE BY A GREAT JOB
OF HIGHLIGHTING OF WHAT WE DO IN
TERMS OF PRIVATIZATION BECAUSE I
WOULD SAY I THINK THE ISSUE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE -- IS
DIFFERENCES IN PRIVATIZATION
BETWEEN -- WITH THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DOES WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO -- I AM
WORKING OFF OF THIS HAND OUT OF
IT AND I AM STARTING TO
FACILITIES -- MATERIAL STARTS ON
PAGE.
FOURTEEN YOU ALL THE GOVERNOR
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT US EVERY
YEAR TO PRODUCE A FIVE YEAR PLAN.
OUR MOST RECENT FIVE YEAR PLAN
ESTIMATES THE NEED OF THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS FOR CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
ABOUT ELEVEN BILLION OF THAT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. TWENTY BILLION
ASSOCIATED WITH MODERNIZATION OF
EXISTING FACILITIES TO MEET OUR
CURRENT PROGRAM TO MEET.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT.
MOST CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING IN THE
SYSTEM IS LOCAL FUNDING SO WE
ARE BUILDING ON LOCAL FUNDING --
WITH THE STATE BOND PROGRAM
THROUGH PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
DISTRICTS ALSO GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FROM OTHER
SORTS OF SOURCES FOR THEIR
FACILITIES.
AND SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
[inaudible]
FIFTEEN WE CERTAINLY.
CAN'T MEET THAT THIRTY BILLION
DOLLAR DEMAND TODAY AND SO WE GO
THROUGH A PROCESS OF THE SYSTEM
TO PRIOR TO PRIORITIZE PROJECTS --
THAT ARE SUBMITTED FOR STATE
FUNDS IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHART
ON THE RIGHT FROM THE TOP SLIDE.
YOU'LL SEE WHAT MR BRAWL HAS
NOTED THE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED --
PROJECTS THAT MEET A VERY STRICT
FIRE LIFE SAFETY DEFINITION ARE
INCLUDED IN OUR REQUEST --
PROJECTS THAT DO NOT MEET THAT
STRICT DEFINITION THOUGH MAY
STILL HAVE FIRE LIFE SAFETY
COMPONENTS IS THE PART OF
FINANCE NOTES.
ARE PRIORITIZED BASED ON THOSE
CATEGORIES THE FIVE ADDITIONAL
CATEGORIES INCLUDED THERE.
INCREASING INCREASING
INSTRUCTIONAL CAPACITY
MODERNIZING SPACE I COMPLETING A
CAMPUS TO BECOME A COMPREHENSIVE
CAMPUS INCREASING OUR SUPPORT
FACILITIES AND MODERNIZING
SUPPORT FACILITIES WE TRY TO
BALANCE OUR PRIMARY GOAL -- IN
THIS -- PROCESS IS BALANCING
ACROSS -- MODERNIZATION AND
GROWTH AND BALANCING ACROSS
INSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT SPACES.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF
PART OF THAT SLIDE A YOU'LL SEE
WITHIN EACH OF THOSE CATEGORIES
THEN.
WE APPLY ADDITIONAL
PRIVATIZATION -- FACTORS FOR
PROJECTS THAT ARE IN THE GROWTH
CATEGORY WE CONSIDER HOW MUCH
GROWTH OF THE COLLEGES
PROJECTING WHAT THE EXISTING
CAPACITY IS.
WHAT THE NEEDED TYPES OF SPACE
ARE AND WHAT THE LOCAL
CONTRIBUTION AS? FOR
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS WE
CONSIDER THE AGE OF THE BUILDING
THE CURRENT USE OF SPACE THE
LOCAL CONTRIBUTION.
AMOUNT FOR THOSE IN OUR COMPLETE
CAMPUS CATEGORY WE CONSIDER AGE
PROGRAM CHANGES PROGRAM DECIDED
LOCAL CONTRIBUTION.
MOVING ON THEN TO ART OF THE
NEXT PAGE PAGE SIXTEEN ARE CLEAR
REQUEST FROM THE COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR -- IS TO APPROVE THE
PROJECTS -- SUBMITTED BY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS TO THE
GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE REQUESTING
NINETEEN CONTINUING PROJECTS FOR
A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED THREE
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THIRTY NINE NEW PROJECTS FOR
A TOTAL OF FORTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE NEW PROJECTS
THE COSTS ARE FOR THE
PRELIMINARY PLANS FOR THE
WORKING DRAWINGS FACES.
AGAIN AS OF BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS HAVE NOTED --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FUNDS
FIFTEEN OF THE CONTINUING
PROJECTS AND FIFTEEN NEW
PROJECTS.
ALL CLOSE BY JUST TALKING ABOUT
FUTURE ACTIONS RELATED TO
CAPITAL OUTLAY -- THEY WERE
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA -- WE ARE
WORKING TO SEE HOW OR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS I CAN
FURTHER THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
IN THERE TO REALLY -- ISSUES
THAT WE ARE MOST INTERESTED IN
THINKING ABOUT HOW
INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT BE BETTER
INTEGRATED TO SUPPORT
COMPREHENSIVE GUIDED PATHWAYS --
WHETHER THIS DISTINCTION BETWEEN
INSTRUCTIONAL SPACE AND SUPPORT
SPACE CONTINUES TO MAKE SENSE.
AND THEN WHETHER IN OUR
PRIORITIZATION OF PROJECTS WE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING THE EQUITY
GAPS THAT WE SEE ACROSS REGIONS
ACROSS GROUPS OF STUDENTS.
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS
IDENTIFIES REGIONS -- OF
PARTICULARLY LOW PERFORMANCE THE
EMINEM HIGHER THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THE FAR NORTH AND WE ARE LOOKING
AT WAYS IN WHICH WE MIGHT THINK
ABOUT HOW THOSE GAPS.
ARE AFFECTED BY THE ACCESS TO
QUALITY FACILITIES THESE
DISCUSSIONS ARE VERY PRELIMINARY
AND WE WILL SEE -- WE WILL BE
SEEKING CONSULTATION TO OUR
FORMAL INTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS
CONSTANT CONSULTATION PROCESS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
WELL LET ME START BY ASKING THIS
QUESTION WHY DON'T WE BEFORE I
GET INTO HOW THIS FACILITY
ALLOCATION.
FUND MONEY ALLOCATION PROCESS
WORKS WORKS WHICH I COULD
CONFESSES CONFUSING TO ME.
WHY DON'T WE JUST ISSUE THE REST
OF THE BONDS?
SO THE REST OF THE BONDS AND
HAVE A PRIORITY LIST IN.
APPROPRIATE PRIORITY LIST WILL
GET TO THAT AND START AT THE TOP.
AND THEN FIX WHAT WE CAN AND
THEN.
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE NEXT STEP IS
GOING TO BE.
AND I'M NOT BEING CRITICAL -- I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
FLOWING THROUGH THE PIPELINE TO
GET SOME OF THESE BUILDINGS AND
PROJECTS.
BUILDING FIXED IN PROJECTS --
GOING SO BUT I AM CURIOUS AS TO
IT'S A RELATIVELY.
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY GIVEN THE
MONEY WE DEAL WITH HERE.
YEAH -- I'LL BE HAPPY TO TAKE A
OR AT LEAST TAKE THE FIRST STEP --
ANSWERING THIS AND CAN GUIDE ME
IF I'M GOING A BIT OFF COURSE
YOU KNOW YOU HAD ME [inaudible]
BUT THE BOND IT MEASURE ITSELF
REQUIRES THAT THERE BE A
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION AND
SOUNDS LIKE YOUR QUESTION IS WHY
NOT JUST ONE LET JUST LET ONE
APPROPRIATION. TWO BILLION OR
STAY THE REMAINING ONE POINT SIX
BILLION.
COMMITTEE COLLEGE PROJECTS.
AND I THINK -- PART OF THE
CONCERN FROM THE MINISTRATIONS
SIDE WOULD BE JUST KIND OF THE
LEVEL OF REVIEW TO MAKE SURE
IT'S THE HIGHEST QUALIFYING
PROJECTS BUT THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
RESTATING SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT CONCERNS THAT WE'VE HAD
OVER TIME.
ON THE OTHER ONE IS A BIT MORE --
MAYBE A BIT MORE INTO THE WEEDS
BUT IT'S THE NATURE OF HOW WE
SELL THE BONDS THAT IS THE
TYPICAL PRACTICE IN CAPITAL
OUTLAY WEATHER'S BOND FUNDED OR
OR CAST FUNDED.
THAT YOU ONLY PROVIDE THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE PHASES THAT
ARE NEEDED SO FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S THERE'S FIVE CONTINUING
PROJECTS THAT ARE NOT FUNDED.
FOR FOUR OF THEM IT'S JUST
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT READY THEY'RE NOT
EXPECTED TO ADVANCE TO THE POINT.
WHERE THEY WOULD NEED TO
CONSTRUCTION I SEE SO YOU NEED
TO RETAIN ENOUGH FUNDS?
BUTTER AVAILABLE FUNDS IN THE
FUTURE TO COMPLETE PROJECTS THAT
YOU'VE ALREADY STARTED.
IF YOU SPEND IT ALL YOUR BOND
FUNDS.
ON THE PRELIMINARY WORK IN THE
PARTIAL WORK ON THE PROJECT AND
YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF UNFINISHED
STUFF LAYING AROUND THE STATE IS
THAT.
THAT'S FINE WAY MCEACHERN'S
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING OKAY I
GET THAT.
SO THEN LET ME TALK ABOUT.
LET ME TALK ABOUT THIS RATHER OF
CONFUSING TO ME PROCESS WHEREBY
THE CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ANSWERS OFFICE
ORDERS PRIORITY IN TERMS OF OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND OTHER
PROJECTS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED.
AND THEN THE LIST GOES.
TO THE FIRST FLOOR [inaudible]
AND THEN.
A NEW LIST POPS OUT AT LEAST
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
SOMETIMES THE PROJECTS ARE
REORDERED SOMETIMES THERE
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS THERE OF NEW
PROJECTS ARE ADDED IN ALL
PROJECTS REMOVED [inaudible]
I THINK -- IN TERMS OF WHAT WHAT
IS PROPOSED TO BE FUNDED FELL.
I WOULD SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LIST IS WOULD
BE A SUBSET OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THAT MISSION.
OKAY SO.
THEY GIVE YOU ONE THROUGH TWENTY
AND YOU WHAT COMES AT THE END OF
YOUR PIPE IS ONE THROUGH.
TEN BUT IT MIGHT NOT BE THE
FIRST TEN YOU SKIP AROUND IN THE
LIST AND IT MIGHT BE THE NUBER
ONE AND NUMBER THREE AND NUMBER
SIX IN.
NUMBER NINE AND NUMBER TEN
WHATEVER THE NUMBERS ARE TO GET
THE TEN PROJECTS IS THAT ABOUT
RIGHT -- WE WOULD HAVE A WE
WOULD HAVE A DIRECT.
IT WOULDN'T BE QUITE AS SIMPLE
AS A SAYING.
OKAY COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'RE
JUST GOING TO IMPROVE THOSE THAT
ARE PRIME NUMBERS -- AND AND
SAID WE'LL LOOK AT EACH ONE
INDIVIDUALLY BASED ON OUR
CRITERIA.
AND SO IN THIS CASE OTHER.
THIRTY NINE NEW REQUEST ABOUT
FIFTEEN MET THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CRITERIA ORDERS MIKE HERE'S MY
CONCERN -- K. THROUGH TWELVE
IZZY EQUALLY -- BOGGLING TO MIND
BOGGLING TO ME BUT THIS IS
PARTICULARLY SO BECAUSE I CAN'T
FIGURE OUT WHEN.
DISTRICTS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS COME TO ME.
NOT IN THIS CAPACITY BUT IN THE
PAST.
DISTRICTS THAT AREN'T EVEN IN MY
SENATE DISTRICT.
AND ASK ME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
SELECTION CRITERIA AND HOW ONE
DISTRICT MADE A LIST AND HOW THE
OTHER DIDN'T AND HOW.
THEY RUN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ONE DISTRICT IS ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LIST BUT IT DOESN'T.
MANAGE TO MAKE ITS WAY TO THE
FINAL DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LIST.
AND I DON'T HAVE AN EXPLANATION
FOR THEM.
BECAUSE I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
THE THE SELECTIONS ARE MADE AND
TO BE FRANK -- I'VE NEVER REALLY
HAD A EXPLANATION.
WHEN I ASK QUESTIONS THAT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
AND THEN IN TURN ARTICULATE BACK
TO THE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
APPROACHED ME?
AS TO WHY THEY DIDN'T GET PICKED
BECAUSE THIS IT WILL LOOK AT THE
HEALTH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROJECT.
AND IT MAY BE A MATH AND SCIENCE
BUILDING.
BUT THEN I SAID WELL LOOK THIS
DISTRICT OVER HERE ON THE COAST
THAT DISTRICT GOT A MAT MATH AND
SCIENCE BUILDING THAT HAD A
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
ISSUE IS THE SAME PRIORITY ONE
TWO THREE FOUR WHATEVER YOU
CLASSIFY THEM AS OUR FINANCE
WHOEVER HAS A CLASSIFICATION.
AND I SAY I DON'T KNOW.
AND I'M I GUESS I'M.
I'M I I OWN A LECTURE I GUESS
WHAT I'M ASKING IS THAT WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO. TO
DESIGN A PROCESS.
THAT IS MORE TRANSPARENT WE'RE
GOING IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE
STANDARDS ARE.
THAT THEY HAVE TO MEET
RECOGNIZING WILL NEVER HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY.
THAT HAS A PRIORITIZATION SYSTEM
ATTACHED TO IT SO THEY CAN SORT
OF FIGURE OUT WHETHER THEY'RE IN
THE TOP 25% OF THE BOTTOM 25%.
AND THEY KNOW WHAT THE CHANCES
ARE SO AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHEN THEY'RE DISAPPOINTED.
AS OBVIOUSLY SOME OF THEM ARE
GOING TO BE THEY UNDERSTAND.
WHY THE DIS DISAPPOINTMENT IS
FLOWING THEIR WAY I'LL GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE NOT THIS IS NOT IN
THE SENATE DISTRICT?
SO IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH ME
PERSONALLY -- DISTRICT CAME TO
ME THEY SAID WE HAVE A WE HAD A
VERY WE HAD A HIGH PRIORITY
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUE HAVING
TO DO WITH THE SCIENCE BUILDING --
GROSS ANATOMY LABS AND ALL THIS
OTHER STUFF THAT APPARENTLY THEM
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER WAS H. FEES
VENTILATION ISSUE OR WHAT.
THEY HAD TO MOVE ALL THOSE
THINGS OUT AND THEY SET HIM UP
IN PORTABLES.
WHAT THEY TOLD ME I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER IT'S?
ACCURATE.
I'M JUST REPORTING.
IS IT BECAUSE THEY RELOCATED
THEIR LABS IN PORTABLE
FACILITIES ON THE CAMPUS AT CUT
THEM OUT OF THE PROCESS.
FOR OBTAINING A HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
OF A PROJECT APPROVAL IN THIS
SYSTEM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW
AGAIN I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THAT'S ACCURATE OR NOT.
BUT IF IT IS OR EVEN PART OF IT
IS ACCURATE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO LOOK AT SO
YOU HAVE A IF YOU HAVE A
DISTRICT IS ATTEMPTING TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE.
EVEN ON A TEMPORARY BASIS AND
THEN DOESN'T QUALIFY -- FOR
CONSIDERATION OR APPROVAL ON ONE
OF THESE PROJECTS LIST -- MAYBE
THERE WERE HIGHER PRIORITY
PROJECTS -- MAYBE THERE WAS A
REASON.
BUT THE DIFFICULTY IS THE
REASONS NOT CLEARLY COMMUNICATED
TO THE DISTRICT SO THEY DON'T
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
AND THEN THEY COME TO PEOPLE IF
SOMEBODY LIKE ME AND I CAN'T
EXPLAIN IT EITHER SO.
I GUESS WHAT I'M ASKING IS THAT
WE FIGURE OUT -- A BETTER WAY.
TO DISCONNECT WHEN IT COMES.
TO IDENTIFYING THESE PROJECTS
GRADING THEM SCORING THEM
LISTING THEM.
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S ALMOST LIKE I
DON'T KNOW THE SELECTION OF THE
POPE.
IN A PUFF OF SMOKE COMES OUT OF
THE TOP OF THE CAPITAL AND WE
GET A LIST AND NOBODY REALLY
KNOWS.
WHO VOTED FOR WATER HOW YOU MADE
IT TO THE LIST AND?
AND IF IT'S NOT YOUR LIST YEAH
THEN YOU CAN EXPLAIN IT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
AND I DON'T KNOW -- WHAT HAPPENS
ON THE FIRST FLOOR I RESPECT
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE FIRST FLOOR
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE [inaudible]
TRY MAYBE.
BEFORE WE GO ON IF YOU DON'T
MIND.
SO.
HE'S ALWAYS HEAR PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT BREAKING DOWN SILOS AND I
USED TO REALLY NOT UNDERSTAND
THAT AND THOUGHT IT MADE NO
SENSE UNTIL I GOT THIS JOB.
AND IT IS SHOCKING HOW PEOPLE
WORK IN SILOS AND TO THE CHAIR'S
POINT WE WE DON'T COMMUNICATE
WITH EACH OTHER THEN WE GET LEFT
WONDERING WHAT'S HAPPENING -- I
DON'T EVEN KNOW IF ALL OF YOU
ALWAYS KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING BUT TO RICHARD'S POINT
OF EXCUSE ME CENTER RAS POINT.
ABOUT THEM IF COMMUTING COLLEGES
COMING TO US AND WONDERING YOU
KNOW HOW MUCH HOW DO I GET ON
THE LIST WHY AM I NOT ON THE
LIST.
THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE IT IS
INCREDIBLE I MEAN WE JUST I
THINK I WOULD JUST SAY
COMMUNICATE COMMUNICATE
COMMUNICATE EVERYONE EVEN IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE SOMEBODY
BAD NEWS.
AS LONG AS YOU TELL THEM WHAT'S
GOING ON AND THEY UNDERSTAND
IT'S BETTER THAN NO NEWS OR THE
WRONG NEWS SO JUST LET'S LET'S
BREAK DOWN THOSE SILOS AND TALK
TO EACH OTHER.
THANK YOU SIR LIVES SO IF IF UP
A PROJECT IS IS.
IS NOT COMES OUT OF YOUR ON YOUR
LIST FINANCE YOU APPLY YOUR
CRITERIA AND THE PROJECT DOESN'T
MAKE THE LIST FOR A PARTICULAR
YEAR.
WHEN WE TURN TO THE NEXT ROUND
OF BOND FINANCING AND PROJECTS
THE NEXT YEAR? TO THOSE PROJECTS
STAY ON THE LIST AND ARE THEY
RECONSIDERED AND AND DO THEY
BUMP UP ON THE ON THE ON THE
LISTER DO WE START WITH A CLEAN
SLATE AND EVERYBODY GOES BACK TO
THE DRAWING BOARDS AND YOU MAY
OR MAY NOT MAKE IT.
WE'VE BEEN RE SUBMITTING
PROJECTS POPS OF PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN ON OUR APPROVED LISTS
THAT WERE INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OUR PRACTICES
BEEN -- TO TO RESUBMIT PROJECTS
ARE THEIR CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH
THOSE PROJECTS MIGHT DROP OFF
THE LIST AND IN IN IN.
IN WHAT WOULD THOSE CONDITIONS
BE IT SO TO THE EXTENT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEED NO LONGER
EXISTS BUT IF IF THAT IS A VERY
LIMITED -- SET OF PROJECTS SO IT
IS OUR PRACTICE IN GENERAL WOULD
BE TO RESUBMIT. TEN MAYBE I'M
JUST I THINK THAT YOUR POINT --
TO BOTH OF THE POINTS -- I THINK
THERE ARE SOME CRITICAL
QUESTIONS THAT THERE IS INSURED
AGREEMENT ACROSS THE PARTIES
HERE -- ABOUT.
HOW WE APPROACH THIS YEAR TO
YEAR I THINK THE CORE ONE ONE
CORE ONE IS HOW MUCH MONEY?
ARE WE GOING TO SPEND IN A GIVEN
YEAR -- SEARCH YOUR POINT ARE WE
SPENDING ALL TWO BILLION AND
PROP -- PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
FUNDS ARE WE SPOT APPORTIONING
IT OUT OVER SOME PERIOD OF YEARS
I THINK THERE IS WE'VE HAD WE
HAD SOME PLANS INITIALLY.
THE SUSPENDED OVER A FORTY FIVE
YEAR PERIOD THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
DIFFERENT ON THE GOVERNOR'S
EIGHT TO NINE YEARS AND SO.
I THINK THAT'S A KEY QUESTION
THAT AFFECTS HOW WE WHAT WE TELL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I THINK THAT
THE OTHER QUESTION IS.
ONCE YOU DECIDE ON THAT POT HOW
MUCH HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE
PROJECTS WITHIN THAT POT.
BUT I WILL SAY YOU KNOW I THINK
WE SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE IS RAISED THAT A FIRE
LIFE SAFETY -- CRITERIA CREATES --
CONCERNING INCENTIVESWHEN MOST
OF THE MONEY IS LOCAL SO WHAT
ARE YOU SPENDING YOUR LOCAL
MONEY ON ND AND WHAT INCENTIVES
THAT IS A CREATE -- TO TO MAKE
SURE YOUR FACILITY IS --
SUFFICIENTLY -- CONCERNING -- TO
TO RECEIVE STATE FUNDS HOW TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT KIND OF JUST
THIS QUESTION OF WHAT WE TELLING
COLLEGES SO. TO GROSSLY
OVERSIMPLIFY THIS PROCESS -- YOU
KNOW WE MAY SEND TWO PROJECTS TO
THE GOVERNOR ON TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT THEY WERE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS SOME
ROLLING.
OUT BOTH COLLEGES HAVE
SIGNIFICANT ENROLLMENT GROWTH
LET'S SAY EQUAL ENROLLMENT
GROWTH BOTH NEEDED NEW CLASSROOM
FACILITIES -- I THINK IN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT AND
SHOULD KIND OF WAY AND BUT YOU
KNOW THAT WHEN THEY GET TO
FINANCE THE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
PLANS GOES AWAY.
AND MEDIA OUT LIFE FIRE LIFE
SAFETY ONCE THAT BEGINS TO GET
APPLIED.
AND SO THIS PROJECT THAT WE SENT
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT IT WAS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
ACTUALLY MIGHT DROP OFF THE LIST
BECAUSE ENROLLMENT GROWTH WASN'T
THE LANDS AND THE OTHER PROJECT
MIGHT GO FORWARD BECAUSE THAT'S
THE DIFFERENT LINES FINANCE
SUPPLIES.
I WILL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING YOU
KNOW I THINK WE ARE THE WE HAVE
THE LEAST AUTHORITY IN THERE
ACROSS THE PLAYERS IN THE ROOM
SO.
YOU KNOW I THINK IF THE
DIRECTION WAS WE WANT ONLY
PROJECTS THAT ADDRESS FIRE LIFE
SAFETY I THINK THAT'S A
CONVERSATION WEEK WE WOULD HAVE
THE SYSTEM OF YOU KNOW MAYBE WE
SHOULD BEGIN TO PRIORITIZE ONLY
ON FIRE LIFE SAFETY.
AGAIN THOUGH I THINK THOSE -- I
THINK WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INCENTIVES AND WOULD WANT TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE OLD --
BEFORE WE DID THAT WELL IT SEEMS
TO ME THERE A COUPLE WAYS TO DO
IT THE NEXT TIME THERE'S A BOND
ISSUE WE COULD.
DO WHAT WE'VE DONE IN OTHER BOND
ISSUES WHICH IS I THINK WHICH IS
SPECIFIED THAT CERTAIN PORTIONS
OF THE BOND WE USE BOND FUNDS
WILL BE USED FOR THIS AND
CERTAIN PORTIONS BE USED.
FOR SOMETHING ELSE KNOW THAT.
THAT SORT OF ELIMINATES
FLEXIBILITY.
IN THE PROCESS AND I'M ONE FOR
FLEXIBILITY JUST AS I'M ONE
GENERAL OF ONE FOR LOCAL CONTROL
WE CAN DO IT SO.
I'D BE A LITTLE RELUCTANT TO DO
THAT BUT YOU SEE I WOULD SEEM
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE OUGHT TO
COME TO SOME AGREEMENT.
AS TO WHAT PORTION OF THE MONEY.
OUGHT TO BE GENERAL USE FOR LIFE
SAFETY ISSUES AND WHAT PORTION
CAN BE USED FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH WITHOUT LOCKING ANYBODY
INTO A PARTICULAR FORMULA.
AND THEN SORT OF MARCH DOWN THE
ROAD WITH THAT IN MIND.
OUT OF THE NIGHT OF THE TWENTY
FOOT.
TWENTY BILLION RIGHT. TWENTY TWO
BLOOD TWO BILLION BUT THE NEEDS
ARE.
OKAY WELL OUT OF THE THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS HOW MUCH IS LIFE
SAFETY.
DO WE KNOW.
WE DO YOU KNOW LET ME FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON THAT.
UNDER OUR DEFINITION YEAH YEAH.
ONE OKAY WELL I DON'T WANT TO
BELABOR THIS MIND MY COLLEAGUES
PROBABLY ONE OF MOVE ON TO OTHER
THINGS INCLUDING THEIR DISTRICTS
BUT YES I HAVE A QUESTION ON THE
SPOT ABOUT MY DISTRICT IF I MAY.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU.
SO DECEMBER AND YOU KNOW VALLEY
COLLEGE THE CREW TECHNICAL
EDUCATION BUILDING -- IT IT'S
SLATED TO RECEIVE THE MONEY TO
IMPROVE IT DO THEY HAVE ANYTHING
TO WORRY ABOUT THAT THAT MONEY
MIGHT GO AWAY.
AND IF NOT WHEN WILL THEY GET
THE MONEY.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER LATER
THANK YOU -- SO THE STANDARD YOU
KNOW -- THE END AND YOU CAN
RELATE THIS TO THE MEMBERS THAT
THAT PROPOSAL THAT WAS SUBMITTED.
IT IS ALMOST THE ARCHETYPE OF
WHAT WE AT FINANCE WOULD BE
WANTING TO SEE IT VERY.
WELL IT WAS HARD WONDERFULLY I
WAS SCARED YOU'RE GONNA SAY WE
DID A REALLY BAD JOB WHILE WHILE
IT IS HOME.
WELL IT WAS NOT IN THE IN THE
FIRE LIFE SAFETY CATEGORY -- I
BELIEVE OF THE MODERNIZATION IS
THE CATEGORY WAS AND IT DID IT
AND THE THE THE PROPOSAL DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF THE OF THE
SCRIBING THE THE CRITICAL FIRE
LIFE SAFETY NEEDS IN THE END
THAT FACILITATES GUESS IF YOU
VISITED IT YOU WOULD KNOW THAT
THERE'S FIRE.
FORTUNATELY THEY'RE SO MANY IT --
BUT IT IT WAS -- SO THAT BEING
THE CASE THE THE NEXT STEP WOULD
BE APPROVAL OF THE LEGISLATURE --
BUT BY THE LEGISLATURE AND AND
STANDING BY TO GO FROM THERE
ONCE THAT IS DONE SO JULY -- ONE
WE GO INTO THE BASICALLY THE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD FACE THE
CHANCES OFFICE WILL WILL THE
MINUTE -- FUNDING IT GETS
ENCUMBERED AND IT'S OFF AND
RUNNING.
AWESOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT
I ALSO JUST WHILE I HAVE IT ON
WANTED TO SAY THAT CHRISTIAN IS
PRETTY ACCURATE IN IN THAT AND
ROMAN CATHOLIC POPULATION
EXAMPLE -- THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMUNICATION THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE CHANCES OFFICE DURING OUR
VALUATIONS.
BUT THAT SAID THE ADMINISTRATION
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THE
ENROLLMENT ISSUE SHOULD BE DEALT
WITH LOCALLY THAT SINCE WE HAVE
A FIXED PART OF STATE FUNDS WE
SHOULD BE AT AND THAT STATE
FUNDS JUST A FRACTION OF THE THE
OVERALL NEED EVEN WHEN.
TAKING LIKE MODERNIZATION THING --
THIS FIRE LIFE SAFETY IN THERE
THAT WE FEEL THAT THE STATE
FUNDS SHOULD BE ENSURING THAT
THE THE STAFF STUDENTS AND
FACULTY THAT ATTEND THESE
COLLEGES OR SAY.
I DON'T NECESSARILY DISAGREE
WITH THAT I GUESS OR SOME
EXCEPTIONS DEPENDING ON THE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND WHAT
COMMUNITIES WERE TALKING ABOUT
SUMMER.
MORE ABLE THAN OTHERS TO BEAR
THE LOAD OF OF LOCAL MEASURES
BUT BUT I I MICHAEL.
MY COLLEAGUE'S QUESTION.
RAISES A POINT AND THAT IS HOW
DO WE COMMUNICATE TO TWO
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE.
WHAT GOOD PROPOSALS ARE?
WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FOR IN
TERMS OF?
THE PROPOSED THE KIND OF
PROPOSALS THAT FLOAT TO THE TOP
AND AND RECEIVE APPROVAL -- AM I
MAKING SENSE DO WE DO YOU
COMMUNICATE BECAUSE YOU HAVE
DISTRICTS OF VARYING SIZES AND
I'M SURE SOME HAVE FLEETS OF
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND.
HOW THIS PROCESS WORKS AND SOME
PROBABLY DON'T?
AND EVERYBODY SHOULD YOU KNOW
COME TO THE TABLE WITH AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY SO.
YET IF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THE SYSTEM OFFICE DOESN'T.
DOESN'T REALLY HAVE A GRASP OF
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THEN YOU'RE GOING TO
BE UNABLE.
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES WITH THE
COMMUNITY THE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN OF THEM THAT WE HAVE
AROUND. FIFTEEN SKEWS ME ONLINE
RIGHT -- HOPEFULLY THEY DON'T
HAVE ANY.
LIFE SAFETY AND MAINTENANCE
NEEDS JUST YET.
I DON'T THINK SO WE'LL HERE SOON --
I I WOULD JUST SAY YOU KNOW I
THINK -- YOU KNOW OUR EMPHASIS
WE HAVE A STAFF OF THAT WORKS ON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FINANCING
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUEST AFTER WE
RUN THROUGH OUR PROCESS AGAIN
WHICH WE THINK -- YOU KNOW TRIES
TO AS OBJECTIVELY USING STATED
CRITERIA -- DETERMINE THE
HIGHEST PRIORITIES YOU KNOW WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
THOSE PROJECTS AND HOPEFULLY --
WRITING SUFFICIENTLY COMPELLING --
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS TO GET
THOSE PROJECTS FUNDED.
AND SO WE ARE -- WE PLAY A ROLE
WITH THE DISTRICT AND PREPARING
THE REQUEST FOR FINANCE.
SO FOR THOSE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
CONTACTED ME AND THINK THEY WERE
DROPPED FROM THE LIST AND WERE
RESUBMITTED AND ALL THE REST
I'LL -- HAVE THEM WORK WITH YOU
ALL TO FIGURE OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
YES.
PERFECT ONE FINAL QUESTION ON
THIS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ISSUE AND THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE FUTURE ACTION PEAS.
AND YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THE
ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT -- VISION
FOR SUCCESS LOW INCOME ENGLISH
ESL STUDENTS THE CARD SERVICES
SERVICE CENTER -- OBVIOUSLY.
A VERY VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THERE ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THE STATE THAT ARE LOCATED IN
AREAS THAT ARE NOT QUITE OF DEMO
GOOD DEMOGRAPHICALLY CHALLENGED.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT THEY WILL BE
THAT THOSE DISTRICTS WILL BE
DISADVANTAGED WHEN IT COMES.
TO THIS -- BOND FINANCE THE
MAINTENANCE IMPROVEMENT.
PEACE SO I WOULD JUST I WOULD.
OPEN BY SAYING WE ARE -- EARLY
IN OUR PROCESS WE CERTAINLY NEED
TO SEEK MORE CONSULTATION FROM
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH A WORKER PRIMARILY
OF CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICIALS.
AND FACILITIES DIRECTORS ON
ALTERNATIVES -- I THINK IT FITS
INTO THIS CONVERSATION BY SAYING
OF THE THIRTY BILLION WE EXPECT.
MUCH OF IT MOST OF IT WILL BE
FUNDED LOCALLY.
WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
STATE FUNDS ARE GOING TO BE
LIMITED AND SO HOW DO WE BEST
PRIORITIZE -- THE PROJECTS THAT --
THAT CAN BE FUNDED WITH STATE
FUNDS TO YOUR EARLIER POINT
COMMUNITIES HAVE DIFFERENT
ABILITY TO RAISE LOCAL FUNDS AND
SO WE THINK ABOUT IT -- THAT IT
WOULD BE REASONABLE TO CONSIDER
THAT COMMUNITIES -- THE PROPERTY
TAX BASE IS A WAY OF THINKING
ABOUT WHAT CAN BE GENERATED
LOCALLY.
AND WE THINK THE CASE HAS LONG
BEEN MADE WE'VE MADE THE CASE
THAT FACILITIES ARE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF IMPROVING STUDENT
SUCCESS SO THAT WE SHOULD THINK
OF IT AS A KEY LEVER.
AS WE THINK ABOUT OUR GOAL TO
BUY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE CLOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS ACROSS REGIONS
ACROSS -- PARTICULARLY --
HISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS SO I THOUGHT YOU KNOW
WHAT WE HAVE OF SCENTED AS AN
ALTERNATIVE AS ONE IDEA FOR THE
SYSTEM.
IS BEGINNING TO INCORPORATE
MEASURES OF NEED -- AND THEN
ALSO BEGINNING TO THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE RE FRAME OUR CATEGORY
SO THAT DISTRICTS ARE FORCED TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN -- WHETHER A
FACILITY IS -- COMPETES AS AN
INSTRUCTIONAL FACILITY OR AS A
SUPPORT FACILITY TODAY UNDER
GOTTA PATHWAYS MORE AND MORE OF
OUR FACILITIES HAVE INTEGRATED
PURPOSES AND WE THINK THAT MAKES
SENSE -- TO FURTHER -- THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS SO -- I THINK
THESE WILL BUILD ON THESE WILL
BE INCREMENTAL CHANGES TO THE
EXISTING WAY IN WHICH WE
ALLOCATE FACILITIES DOLLARS
PRIOR TEST FACILITIES DOLLARS
BUT CERTAINLY -- YOU KNOW IF YOU
ALL WERE THE GOVERNOR GONNA USE
DIFFERENT CRITERIA THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE TO HAVE
THAT.
CONVERSATION WITH YOU SO WE ARE
PERPETUATING -- THIS
INCONSISTENCY BETWEEN WHAT WE
PROPOSE AND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
INCLUDED THE BUDGET WELL I THINK
I'LL BE LOOKING TO YOU.
THE FOLKS AT THIS TABLE TO
PROVIDE SOME SUGGESTIONS IN THAT
REGARD I MEAN.
YOU ARE CERTAINLY THE EXPERTS
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CERTAINLY HAS A VARIETY OF
THINGS ON THE PLATE THAT OF
FINANCE HAS TO BALANCE INCLUDING
DEBT SERVICE AND ALL THE REST
BUT YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE ON THIS
NEW TIS FUTURE ACTION BUSINESS
I MEAN.
PERHAPS HARDSHIP PERHAPS FAILURE
TO PASS INABILITY TO PASS LOCAL
BOND MEASURES.
ARE OUR CRITERIA THAT DID YOU
MAY WANT TO LOOK AT AND AND THE
REASONS THAT BOND MEASURES
DIDN'T PASS -- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE STILL
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO EDUCATE.
TO BOTH THE YOUNG AND THE NOT SO
YOUNG AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
OFTEN THE PLACE TO DO IT.
OKAY YOU FOR THE QUESTION ALSO --
THERE'S NOTHING FURTHER THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH ON ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR ISSUE NUMBER ONE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING.
MORNING I THINK IT'S STILL
MORNING.
IF YOU -- LADIES WOULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES DURING MY LEFT YOU'RE
RIGHT MA'AM.
SEAN KNEW AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHEN
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
RIGHT SO IT WOULD BE SO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START STUDENT
CENTER FUNDING.
START YES MA'AM.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CONTINUES
TO IMPLEMENT THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA WHICH
WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET I IN
ADDITION TO ALLOCATING FUNDS
BASED ON ENROLLMENT THE FORMULA
ALLOCATES GENERAL PURPOSE
APPORTIONMENT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BASED ON ADDITIONAL
FACTORS SUCH AS THE NUMBER OF
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENROLLED.
AND SPECIFIED STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS SUCH AS THE COMPLETION
OF A DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN APPROXIMATELY 70% OF
THE FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED ON
TOTAL ENROLLMENT. 20% ON
ENROLLMENT OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
AND 10% FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
METRICS.
THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES SOME
REVISIONS TO THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE FORMULA SPECIFICALLY. ONE
MAINTAINING TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN RATES FOR THE
FORMULA INTO THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY FISCAL YEAR. TWO
CAPPING YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH
FOR THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION AT 10%.
AND THREE CLARIFYING THAT THE
DEFINITION OF TRANSFERS SHOULD
REFLECT AN UNDUE BLOCKADED COUNT.
THESE REVISIONS WERE PROPOSED TO
ADDRESS ISSUES REGARDING
ANOMALIES IN THE DATA FOR THE
STUDENT SUCCESS AND SUPPLEMENTAL
ALLOCATIONS.
THIS PROPOSAL IS ALSO INTENDED
TO GIVE SUFFICIENT TIME TO
ADDRESS THE FORMULAS LONG TERM
FISCAL STABILITY.
AND IMPROVE THE ACCURACY OF DATA
REPORTED BY DISTRICTS.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROVIDES
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
ABORTION MINTS INCLUDING.
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF POINT
55%.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND FOR A THREE POINT
46% COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
HELLO.
BOTH THE AWAY -- AND HAD A HAND
ALL PUFFED UP IT'LL USE WITH
KIND OF A SUBSET OF SOME OF
INFORMATION WITHIN YOUR AGENDA --
USE -- AS THE BASIS FOR MY
PRESENTATION BUT ACTUALLY I'LL
SKIP OVER TO PAGE THREE ON OUR
HAND OUT TO DISCUSS -- I'M LIKE
TO DISCUSS TWO ISSUES HERE -- WE
DON'T HAVE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE COMPONENTS THE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING IN THE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE'LL
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
WANT TO TALK ABOUT -- TWO THINGS
ONE IS -- ON AN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN APPORTIONMENT SHORTFALL --
FOR THIS YEAR -- AND THEN I'LL
TALK ABOUT SOME OF OUR
ASSESSMENT AND RECOMMENDATIONS
REGARDING SOME MODIFICATIONS TO
THE FUNDING FORMULA.
ON THE FIRST ARM IN ARM UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ON THEIR
RESPECTIVE SHORTFALL -- FOR
PERFORMANCE IN -- IN THE CURRENT
YEAR OF ESTIMATE IS SIXTY NINE
MILLION SO THERE'S THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH GENERAL FUND -- TO COVER
THE FULL COST OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA.
AND THIS IS DRIVEN BY -- AND
HIGHER THAN ANTICIPATED -- COSTS
REGARDING THE STUDENTS ACROSS
ALL OCCASION WHICH IS THE
PORTION OF THE FORMULA BASED ON
STUDENT OUTCOMES -- AND AND THIS
THIS -- INCREASE I THINK IT'S
PARTLY WHAT'S DRIVEN AND MANY OF
THE PROPOSALS TO TRY T CAP --
FUNDING AND TO LOOK AT THE DATA
AND RELIABILITY OF THAT OF THAT
DATA.
THAT THE CHANCES OFFICE HAS AN
AN ESTIMATE OF THE SHORTFALL
THAT'S EVEN HIGHER THAT'S BASED
ON THERE A PRELIMINARY WITH
I'M LOOKING AT DATA AS OF THE
END OF FEBRUARY -- THEIR FORMULA
FUNDING FROM THE COSTS ARE EVEN
HIGHER IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE MILLION ABOVE WITH
THOSE IN THE BUDGET.
AND THEN THEY ALSO PROJECT --
LOWER THAN ANTICIPATED PROPERTY
TAX REVENUES.
I'M I THINK WE WE WE WERE JUST
POINT OUT ONE I THINK IN TERMS
OF THE LOCAL PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE WE WOULD SAY THAT -- THE
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECT THAT HE
WANTED THIS PART OF THE YEAR IS
CONSISTENTLY UNDER REPORTED
DISTRICTS -- BOTH SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT ND
TO UNDER REPORT FROM SPECIFIC
REVENUES -- REDEVELOPMENT
REVENUES AT YOU RIGHT FROM THE
NEWS AND SO WE WOULD EXPECT THAT
THAT'S NOT AS MUCH OF AN ISSUE --
WHEN YOU GET TO MAIN YOU GET
UPDATED INFORMATION?
BUT THE THE HIGHER COSTS OF THE
FUNDING FORMULA THE TEXAS
OFFICES USING THEM THE THE
LATEST AVAILABLE DATA WE THINK
THAT'S AN ACCURATE REFLECTION OF
OF A SHORTFALL YOU'LL HAVE IN IN
THE CURRENT YEAR.
THAT'S THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION.
I AM WHAT WE THINK OF THE THREE
IN A MILLION ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE MILLION IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THAT IS
HIGHER COSTS OF THE FORMULA.
THAT WE THINK IS A REAL
SHORTFALL YOU HAVE WHETHER IT'S
MORE TO THREE HUNDRED MILLION WE
THINK IT DEPENDS ON WHETHER THE
PROPERTY TAX ISSUE IS REALLY --
JUST THE UNDER REPORTING OF ONE
POINT IN TIME OR WHETHER IT'S
REALLY IN A SYSTEMIC ISSUE.
WITHIN THE HUNDRED FORTY THREE
SERVE A MINIMUM THAT YOU SHOULD
EXPECT THAT THAT WILL BE USEFUL.
FOR JUST A COUPLE A COUPLE
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF YOUR
CONSIDERATION WE KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS INDICATING
THAT THEY WILL WAIT TILL MADE TO
FEEL REVENUES ARE BEFORE THEY
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY WILL BACK FILL -- THE
SHORTFALL.
I'M.
SORRY IT MIGHT BE ONE OF THE BIG
DECISIONS YOU HAVE WHEN YOU GET --
TO YOUR YOUR BUDGET BECAUSE THAT
IS WHETHER OR NOT YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
BACK FILL.
I'M COVERING THE SHORTFALL DOES
HELP SGNAL SUPPORT FOR THE NEW
FUNDING FORMULA AND THE FOCUS ON
IMPROVING STUDENT OUTCOMES IN
THE COMMITTEE CALL SYSTEM -- BUT
IF THE LEGISLATURE CHOSE NOT TO
COVER THE SHORTFALL THERE WILL
BE -- SOME ADJUSTMENT TO COMMUTE
COLLEGE AMOUNT OF OF FUNDING
FORMULA AMOUNT THAT THE RECEIVED
YEAR.
AND THAT THE CHANCES OF AS
INDICATED THEY WOULD -- TRY TO
ASSURE THAT EVERY DISTRICT GOT
AT LEAST WHAT THEY GOT LAST YEAR
PLUS COLA WHICH IS ALSO -- TIED
TO WITH A HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION THAT THAT WAS INCLUDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AS WE
TRANSITION TO THE FORMULA.
COLLEGES ARE -- DISTRICTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE RECEIVING AT THE
BARE MINIMUM A SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN PLUS COLA FOR THE FIRST
THREE YEARS OF PERIOD.
I'M READING THAT SORT OF
DIFFERENT THAT APPROACH -- FROM
A PROJECT THAT THE FEW
REASONABLE GIVEN THAT THERE ARE
SOME DISTRICTS -- MY WHOLE ARE
RECEIVING FOR EXAMPLE DOUBLE
DIGIT INCREASES UNDER THE NEW
FORMULA.
THOSE DISTRICTS MIGHT BE MORE
EASILY ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE SOME
OF THESE OPERATIONS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE YEAR BECAUSE MANY
OF THEM DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY
WERE GETTING.
FUNDING WITH HIGH BECAUSE ALL OF
THE THE THE THE LAST THE LAST
MINUTE CHANGES THERE ARE A LOT
LIKE MACHINES THE FORMULA IT IS
VERY DIFFERENT TO WHAT LOOKED
LIKE IN JANUARY.
AND SO WE DON'T THINK A LOT OF
COLLEGES REALLY EXPECTED THE M.
AND BUDGETED FOR THE THINGS THAT
MIGHT BE MORE EASY EASIER FOR
THEM TO ACCOMMODATE.
I'M.
THAT I WANT TO MOVE ON INTO THE
OURS OF MEN OF FIVE THE
PROPOSALS TO YOU -- CHANGE THE
THE ACTUAL FORMULA ITSELF IN A
MOVE TO PAGE.
FIVE SO ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
WE DID WHEN WE HEARD OF THE
PROPOSAL AND WE KNEW THAT IT WAS
COMING FROM SOME CONCERNS ABOUT --
THE ISSUES WITH THE DATA AS IT --
AND AND YOU KNOW THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET IS USING --
WE'RE USING ONE YEAR DATA IN A
REHEARSAL USING SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OUTCOMES DATA TO DECIDE
HOW MUCH EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FUNDING -- DISTRICTS WILL
RECEIVE THAT DATA CAME IN HIGHER
THAN EXPECTED AND A BATTERY SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER THE STATE
OUT THERE SOME ISSUES WITH THE
DATA.
SO WE WANTED TO LOOK BACK AND
SAY IT SO IS THIS SOMETHING NEW
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S JUST
STARTED TO HAPPEN BECAUSE OF THE
NEW FUNDING FORMULA OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT IS SORT OF A
INHERENT -- COMPONENT OF THE
DATA SO THIS CHART THAT WE HAVE
YOU ON PAGE FIVE SHOWS YOU THAT
WE WENT BACK TEN YEARS AND LOOK
THAT.
THIS IS -- SPECIFICALLY
ASSOCIATE DEGREES THOUGH WE IF
WE DID THE CHART FOR CERTIFICATE
THAT WOULD LOOK ALMOST IT WOULD
LOOK VERY SIMILAR.
JUST LOOKING AT WHAT ARE THE
YEAR TO YEAR FLUCTUATIONS IN IN
IN THESE AWARDS PER YEAR.
AS YOU CAN SEE ON WE HAVE ONE
LINE OF THE STATEWIDE LINE
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT MORE STABLE
THAN THE OTHERS BUT STILL CAN
VERY ANYWHERE FROM.
FROM 0% INCREASE 213% INCREASE
PER YEAR.
AND THEN WHEN YOU GO TO
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS WE CHOSE
THREE RANDOM DISTRICT OF A
BIGGER FOR SMALL AND MEDIUM JUST
TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA.
YOU CAN SEE PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL
FLUCTUATION FROM YEAR TO YEAR IN
TERMS OF THE THE THE OUTCOME SO.
THIS DOES RAISE ISSUES OF IF
THIS IS THE THE THE WAY WE'RE
DISTRIBUTING FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS.
DO WE WANT TO CREATE THE
UNCERTAINTY BOTH FOR THE STATE
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT COSTS ARE BUT THEN ALSO FOR
DISTRICT THEMSELVES DISTRICTS
ART -- FROM THE INTENT OF THE
NEW FUNDING FROM THE WAS TO
CREATE GREATER INSTABILITY AND
AND PREDICTABILITY IN FUNDING.
OR DO KILL WEEDS WHAT WHAT
CAUSES THIS THESE WIVES WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT WE DO SO WE DID
TALK TO A FEW -- DISTRICTS TO
GET A FENCE AND WE DON'T THINK
WE CAN POINT PINPOINT WHAT'S NOT
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE NUMBER ONE
CAUSE IN TERMS OF WEIGHT.
BUT THEY WERE KIND OF THREE
CATEGORIES OF OF REASONS WHY
THIS THIS COULD BE THE CASE ONE
IS THE DATE OF NOT ACCURATE --
BEFORE THE FUNDING FORMULA WAS
ADOPTED THIS WAS SIMPLY LOW
STAKES THE THAT'S NOT AUDITED BY
AN EXTERNAL ENTITY OR WAS IT
USED FOR ANY.
FUNDING DECISION SO IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF SCRUTINY ON SIR COULD BE
THAT THEY'RE JUST THE DATA IS
JUST NOT AN ACTOR HISTORICALLY.
IT COULD ALSO HAVE WE CHANGE
THAT NOW.
I THINK THE CHANCES OF IT ISN'T
IS IS GOING TO INCLUDE OUR THERE
WILL BE AUDIT THEIR ANNUAL
FINANCIAL AUDITS THE DISTRICTS
MUST DO I MOVING FORWARD
BEGINNING IN NINETEEN TWENTY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE WILL
BE AN AUDIT.
THAT DEBT THIS DATA WILL BE
AUDITED OF PART OF THAT SO THAT
SHOULD HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS WELL.
UNLESS THE AUDIT.
REFLECTS THAT THE DATA IS
ACCURATE AND WE HAVE THESE WIDE
SWINGS AND THEN SO MY QUESTION
MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS THAT I
GUESS IT PROBABLY SHOULDN'T GO
TO YOU BUT I'LL.
YOU FREAKING SO OUR ADDRESS YEAH.
WHAT ADDITIONAL DATA POINTS WHAT
ADDITIONAL IT'S I THINK THE
CHANCELLOR'S ALSO HIRED A
FIGMENT TO DO A REVIEW THIS
SPRING OF OF OF A RANDOM SAMPLE
OF DISTRICT AND ALL LET THEM
TALK ABOUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
LATER?
BUT YOU ARE ALSO HELPING SET UP
MY POINTS THAT I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS THE BEST YES IS
THAT IS SUCH THAT YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO THERE ARE A COUPLE OTHER
THINGS THAT WE HEARD FROM
COLLEGES ARE POSSIBLE REASONS
ONE IS JUST SOMETIMES THERE'S
LAGS INWINDOWS REPORTED SO FOR
EXAMPLE -- IT MIGHT BE THAT
TYPICALLY A DISTRICT IS
PROCESSING THEIR ASSOCIATE
DEGREES IN MAY AND JUNE OF A
FISCAL YEAR.
AND WHEN YOU'RE FOR WHATEVER
REASON THERE'S A LAG THEY DON'T
GET TO THEM UNTIL JULY AND
AUGUST.
THE MONTH OR TWO MONTH DELAY
MAYBE FOR A STUDENT DOESN'T MEAN
MUCH. FOR THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
MEAN ANYTHING BUT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE INTO THE DATA IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU DROP ONE YEAR AND
THEN YOU CAME BACK UP ANOTHER.
SO IT COULD BE THAT THERE ARE
SOME OF THESE ADMINISTRATIVE
ISSUES THAT ARE MAKING THE STATE
A LOOK THE WAY IT IS.
AND THEN THE OTHER ISSUE IS THAT
SOMETIMES ARE JUST LOCAL
DIFFERENCES IN WHAT'S GOING ON
SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU MIGHT IMAGINE.
YOU'RE IN A COLLEGE IN A IN AN
AREA THAT'S HAD IMPROVEMENTS OR
OR PROBLEMS IN THEIR RECORD AND
ECONOMICALLY AND THAT MIGHT
AFFECT THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS TO
ENTER THE SYSTEM SO YOU MIGHT
HAVE A BIGGER COHORT OF STUDENTS
WHEN YOU'RE.
IN A SMALLER COVER DISTANT THE
NEXT THAT MIGHT AFFECT HOW WHAT
YOU SEE AS AL COMES DOWN THE
ROAD.
YOU ALSO COULD IMAGINE THAT IF I
FOR EXAMPLE CS YOU MIGHT CHANGE
ITS POLICIES ON TRANSFERS MIGHT
DECIDE THAT THEY'RE GOING.
TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
TRANSFER STUDENTS THAT THEY
ADMIT.
THAT'S GOING TO THEM THAT MIGHT
RESULT IN NEIGHBORING COLLEGES
HAVING TRANSFER NUMBERS GO UP
THESE ARE ISSUES THESE ARE REAL
CHANGES AND SO IT'S IT'S
FLUCTUATING BUT IT'S BASED ON
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING OUT IN
THE IN THE IN THE WORLD.
WELL YEAH I WOULD BET THAT IF
IT'S IF IT'S BUREAUCRATIC --
UNCERTAINTY OR LACK OF SPEED THE
MONEY FLOW WILL PROBABLY TEND TO
SPEED THAT UP YEAH THAT COULD BE
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I THINK
THAT POTENTIALLY COULD BE IT
COULD BE A WAY TO ADDRESS THAT
I'M.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ON WE
HAVE TWO RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
TH SHE WON RELATED TO THIS
POSITION WE DO THINK THAT THE
THE STEPS TO THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE IS TAKING -- TOO INCLUDE
AUDIT GUIDELINES AROUND THIS
DATA AND TRAFFIC NOT TO REVIEW
AND MAKE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HOW THE PROCESS CAN IMPROVE
WILL IMPROVE THE DATA ACCURACY I
THINK IT WILL HELP US FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE AT THE DATA WE'RE
GETTING IS.
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN THE
FIELD BUT WE DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT NECESSARILY WILL DEAL WITH
THE FACT THAT DETECT THE STATE A
COMPLEX RATE AND SO WHAT WE
RECOMMEND IS THAT THE DISTANCE
OF VALIDATION BECAUSE CREATED
USING A THREE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE AS OPPOSED TO WHEN
YOU'RE OUT OF TIME.
SO THAT THAT PROVIDES A LITTLE
BIT OF A SMOOTHING EFFECT SO YOU
DON'T HAVE THESE WILD SWINGS UP
AND DOWN.
OR EVEN IF YOU DO FROM YEAR TO
YEAR THAT IT'S NOT REFLECTED IN
THE AMOUNTS THAT WERE IS
DISTURBING TO DISTRICTS.
THE THE NEXT RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE HAVE IS THAT YOU RELATED TO
THE CAP SO WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSAL TO CAP
THE THE THE STUDENTS ACROSS
ALLOCATION AT 10% GROWTH PER
YEAR.
OUR CONCERN THERE IS THAT THERE
ARE SOME DISTRICTS THAT MIGHT BE
GROWING AT THAT RATE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY MAKING GENUINE
IMPROVEMENT THAT WE DON'T WANT.
TO DISCOURAGE THAT -- SO WHAT WE
RECOMMEND IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE EXPLORE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES FOR COST
CONTAINMENT THAT THAT -- WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY REMOVE THE
STRONG INCENTIVE FOR SOME
DISTRICTS SO THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT THINGS APPROACHES
YOU COULD TAKE THEIR ONE
SPECIFIC THING THAT WE RECOMMEND
IS -- LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF
OUTCOMES BASED FUNDING THAT'S
GENERATED BY ANY INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT IN ANY PARTICULAR YEAR
TO THE HIGHEST DEGREE EARNED
SUFFER OR THE HIGHEST ORDERED SO
FOR EXAMPLE YOU EARNED. TWO
ASSOCIATES DEGREES IN A
CERTIFICATE IN A YEAR WE WOULD
JUST GIVE YOU FUNDING FOR ONE OF
THE ASSOCIATE DEGREES
I MEAN THE IDEA THERE IS THAT WE
DON'T WANT COLLEGES TO TO JUST
START SORT OF FINDING STUDENTS
WE KNOW ALREADY GONNA GET TO THE
SYSTEM AND JUST FINDING NEW
CERTIFICATE THE NEW DEGREES TO
ADD. TO IT TO INCREASE FUNDING
THAT'S NOT KIND OF THE INTENT OF
THE FORMULA WE WANT TO BE
REWARDING -- DISTRICTS THAT ARE
GETTING MORE STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE WITH WITH EITHER A
DEGREE OR CERTIFICATE SO WE
THINK THIS WOULD HELP REDUCE
BECAUSE IN A WAY THAT STILL
ENCOURAGES STUDENT ODD COLLEGES
TO INCREASED IN THREE TH -- TO
THOSE OF THE TWO RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT WE HAVE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION. TOO MANY
COLLEGES OF LIKE TO INTERESTED
IN YOUR COMMENT ON THE LA AS
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AND ALSO
WHEN WILL WE HAVE DATA.
THAT IS ACCURATE.
ON WHICH TO BASE SOME FINAL
DECISIONS ON WHAT THE FINAL
VERSION OF THIS.
STUDENT SUCCESS FUNDING PLAN
LOOKS LIKE HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE.
TO COLLECT DATA TO DETERMINE.
HOWARD WHAT WHAT'S GOING ON AND
WHO WERE GONNA HURT BY DOING
WHAT WE DO AND SO WE HAVE DATA
TODAY WE FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WE'RE USING THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OF THE STATUTE SAYS TO
YOU SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CAL'S OF
BOTH THE LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE
SUPPLEMENTAL.
ALLOCATION AND THEN THE OUTCOMES
AND THE STUDENTS XSL CATION I
THINK THE CONCERN THAT'S BEEN
RAISED IN THE BUDGET IS -- THAT
DATA.
SUBMITTED AS PART OF OUR NORMAL --
ANNUAL REPORTING PROCESS SEES
NOW HAS A NEW LEVEL OF
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT IT DIDN'T
BEFORE AND IS THAT DATA --
ACCURATE AND SO I THINK WHAT
WERE SO WE'VE SAID IS THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION THE ANSWER WE
ASKED THE FISCAL CRISIS
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANT ASSISTANCE
TEAM TO PRODUCE A REPORT TO DO A
REVIEW OF A SAMPLE OF DISTRICTS --
INTO PRODUCER REPORT FOR US AND
SO WE'LL HAVE THAT REPORT IN
EARLY MAY THAT -- HOPEFULLY CAN
INFORM OUR FINAL DELIBERATIONS --
TO THE DISTRICTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUBMIT.
TO CORRECTED DATA WE HAVE -- WE
HAVE WE GAVE DISTRICTS THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS YEAR TO SUBMIT
A CORRECTED DATA -- FOR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN MOVING
FORWARD -- PART OF THAT FAKE MAD --
CHARGES TO COME UP WITH SOME
PROTOCOLS THAT WE SHOULD PUT IN
PLACE I WOULD EXPECT THAT ISSUES --
LIKE THAT.
OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE THE THREE
YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE ISSUE AND
THEN WE HAVE THE WHAT I WILL
CALL THE LABELING ON OF
ASSOCIATE DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES AS PART OF THE
FUNDING MECHANISM.
THOUGHT SHOULD I WALK THROUGH I
CAN WALK THROUGH -- AND AND I
THINK I MAY ADDRESS SOME OF IT
THOUGH I WILL BE SAYING IT.
I ALSO THINK -- THESE SAME
THINGS OTHERS HAVE SAID IN
DIFFERENT WAYS SO I WILL DO THAT
QUICKLY BUT I'M WORKING THROUGH
THIS PACKET -- AND I'M STARTING
ON PAGE.
TWO THE PART THAT I JUST -- YES --
THE PART THAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
WE COVER IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
WHAT WHY DID WE DO THIS IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND I THINK WE AS
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAD THREE GOALS ONE TO
ENCOURAGE PROGRESS TOWARDS THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS.
ESPECIALLY CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS -- FOR THOSE GROUPS WHO
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED A SECOND TO VERY
EXPLICITLY PROVIDE DISTRICTS
SERVING HIGHER NUMBERS OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WITH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
AND THEN THIRD TO MAKE BEANS --
DISTRICTS TO MAKE FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS.
MOST USEFUL BEST ABLE TO SUPPORT
THAT -- IMPROVEMENTS TO ASTON
SUCCESS BY MAKING THEM STABLE
PREDICTABLE AND FLEXIBLE.
AND SO THE YOU KNOW THE PART OF
THIS AND I'M GOING TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE SLIDE OF PAGE.
TWO IS THAT THIS IS A RELATIVELY
IT IS A IN SOME WAYS VERY SIMPLE
FORMULA WE ARE COUNTING THE
NUMBER.
OF FACTORS A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT WE ARE COUNTING.
AND WE ARE NOW MULTIPLYING THEM
BY A RATE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PUT INTO -- THE LAW THE RATES
WERE DESIGNED SO THAT ABOUT 70%
OF THE MONEY IN THE FIRST YEAR
WOULD GO TO THE ENROLLMENT BASE
THE BASE ALLOCATION.
ABOUT A 20% WOULD GO TO THE
ALLOCATION THE SUPPLEMENTAL
ALLOCATION FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ABOUT 10% FOR THE FOR
THE STUDENTS XSL OCCASION -- I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT YOU SET THE THE RATES
OF THE STATUTE THE PROPOSAL THIS
YEAR IS TO CHANGE THOSE RATES.
I'M MOVING OUT OF PAGE THREE ONE
OF THE THINGS -- WE HAVEN'T
TALKED AS MUCH ABOUT TODAY IS
THE PROVISIONS AROUND FUNDING
STABILITY THAT WERE INCLUDED
THESE ARE OFTEN CALLED THE HOLD
HARMLESS.
SO FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WHAT WE ARE.
ACTUALLY APPORTIONING TO
DISTRICTS IS EITHER THE AMOUNT
THAT THE FORMULA CALCULATED. FOR
WHAT THEY RECEIVED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ADJUSTED BY A
CHANGE IN THE COST OF LIVING.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY WE HAD
A THIRD -- PROVISION RELATED TO
STABILITY THAT SAYS IF YOUR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDING
FORMULA CALCULATION WAS HIGHER
WE WILL GIVE YOU WHAT YOU GOT --
WOULD HAVE GOTTEN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO PROVIDE
YOUR GEAR STABILITY.
AND SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM
OF PAGE THREE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT HOW FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED
UNDER THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA.
YOU'LL SEE MOST OF THE MONEY.
VERY SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THE
MONEY CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATUTE IS GOING TO THE BASE
ALLOCATION OF MORE THAN FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
ABOUT A YOU KNOW ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IS GOING TO THE
SUPPLEMENTAL LOCATION LESS THAN
A BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
STUDENT SUCCESS.
WITH A SMALL AMOUNT IS NECESSARY
TO MAKE SURE THAT DISTRICTS ARE
BEING HELD HARMLESS.
THE OTHER PART THAT I'M MOVING
TO PAGE FOR THAT -- WE HAVEN'T
TALKED AS MUCH ABOUT IS THAT --
YOU KNOW THINKING.
WORKING WITH FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES IS COMPLICATED --
THERE IS A POTENTIAL -- FOR YOU
KNOW UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
STATUTE LAST YEAR ENACTED -- WAS
A SET OF PROVISIONS THAT WERE
INTENDED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
THE WORK DISTRICTS WERE DOING ON
THEIR BUDGET WAS ALIGNED WITH
THE GOALS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS SO THE
STATUTE REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO
ADOPT GOALS.
THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
STATE'S GOALS OF IMPROVING
OUTCOMES IN CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS.
THEN TO ALIGN THEIR LOCAL PLANS
FOR HOW THEY'RE SPENDING MONEY --
WITH THOSE GOALS AND ALIGNING
THEIR BUDGETS WITH THOSE PLANS
SO I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ARE HOPING -- YOU KNOW
HAPPENS MOVING FORWARD IN A
PLACE WHERE OUR OFFICE NEEDS TO
PLAY AS A ROLE IS SUPPORTING
DISTRICTS HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW DO YOU BEST MEET THE
THE INCENTIVES THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES THAT ARE CREATED IN
THE FUNDING FORMULA.
DOING SO IN A WAY THAT SUPPORTS
THE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
THAT THE WORD THAT YOUR STUDENTS
NEED -- TO TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
I WILL SKIP OVER -- TO PAGE FIVE
THAN I DID TALK THROUGH SO I'M
LOOKING AT THE SIDE THAT SAYS
CONSIDERATION OF US -- FUNDING
FORMULA MODIFICATIONS SCF
MODIFICATIONS.
AND SO TO YOUR POINT MR CHER YOU
KNOW WE ARE SPENDING A LOT OF
TIME WITH THE WORK GROUP -- THAT
INCLUDE SYSTEM STAKEHOLDERS TO
WORK THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND TO WORK THROUGH
THE ALLEY -- ALTERNATIVES AND
OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT HAVE
COME UP -- FROM OTHER SYSTEM
STAKEHOLDERS.
THE LIST IS IN YOUR AGENDA OF
THE FULL LIST OF QUESTIONS THAT
WE ARE -- CONSIDERING AND ON
THIS SLIDE I'VE I'VE BROKEN THEM
UP INTO TWO CATEGORIES ONE IS.
KIND OF STRUCTURAL ISSUES
GENERALLY -- WHAT TYPES OF
CONSTRAINTS SHOULD WE PUT ALL
THE FORMULA SHOULD WE PUT ON A
YEAR OVER YEAR -- CAP ON THE
STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION I
THINK WE SHARE SIMILAR CONCERNS
IN THE ALLEY -- RAISED ABOUT
THAT PARTICULAR CAP BUT I THINK
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE FOR THE
FORMULA TO BE FINANCIALLY
SUSTAINABLE THAT THERE'S LIMITS
ON HOW MUCH THE COST WOULD GROW
YEAR FOR YEAR.
UP WE AGREED WITH THE LA THOSE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FLUCTUATION
AND DATA PARTICULARLY FOR THE
STUDENT SUCCESS ALLOCATION AND
HOW MUCH THAT CHANGES YOUR FOR
YOUR WE THINK IT'S REASONABLE.
TO USE SOME TYPE OF AVERAGE OF
DATA OVER MULTIPLE YEARS IT'S
WHAT WE DID IN THE SPACE
ALLOCATION ON THE ENROLLMENT
SIDE OF THE FORMULA WHERE WE
SAID. FOR A FOR A MOMENT FOR
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS
WORKING ACCOUNT USING A THREE
YEAR CALCULATION THAT LOOKS AT
THREE YEARS OF ENROLLMENT TO
DETERMINE THE LEVEL OF FUNDING --
AND THEN ON THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ALLOCATION -- A CORE ISSUE THAT
RE RAISED -- LAST YEAR WAS THIS
KILLING OF AWARDS FIRST IS
COUNTING OF STUDENTS AND SO I
THINK IN GENERAL WE AGREE WITH --
YOU KNOW THE THE THE ALLEY OWES
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE SHOULD BE
COUNTING SOMETHING LIKE THE
HIGHEST AWARD THAT A STUDENT
EARNS IN A GIVEN YEAR -- IN
ORDER -- TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FOCUS REMAINS ON GUIDED PATHWAYS
THAT LEAD A STUDENT TO BE
TO THE
FOR BOB THERE ARE FEW OTHER --
ISSUES THE GOVERNOR OBVIOUSLY
HAS A PROPOSAL TO KILL TRANSFER
STUDENTS DIFFERENTLY TO HELP
THIS TRANSFER STUDENT ONCE.
IN THE DISTRICT WHERE THEY LIVE
ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE'VE HAD
ABOUT THAT PROPOSAL AND THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED OR STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATIONS.
IS THAT ESPECIALLY -- AND URBAN
AREAS STUDENTS ARE ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES -- SOMEWHERE
ELSE A PLACE THEY DON'T LIVE --
AGAIN THOUGH WE RECOGNIZE THE
GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN MAKING
SURE THAT THERE ARE CONSTRAINTS
ON THAT PARTICULAR MEASURE.
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF OF OF
FIGURING OUT HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE.
CONTINUING TO ENCOURAGE THE GOAL
THAT WE HAVE THAT A STUDENT
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFERS TO A FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTION WHILE
RECOGNIZING -- THE CONTRIBUTION
IN AN ADEQUATELY -- COMPENSATING
DISTRICTS FOR THE COUNTRY OCT
CONTRIBUTION THEY MAKE. TO THAT
OUTCOME COULD DO IS COULD THERE
BE SOME WEIGHING OF FOR EXAMPLE
WHERE THE STUDENT OBTAINS THE
MOST CREDITS IN A PARTICULAR
YEAR I MEAN.
THE PROBLEM IS OF COURSE IS.
SOME OF THEM ANYWAY IF NOT MANY
OF THEM ARE IMPACTED AND SO IF
YOU ARE FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN A
PART OF THE STATE WHERE YOU HAVE
FOUR FIVE OR SIX COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- YOU'RE GOING TO GO
OR YOU CAN GET THE CHORUS AND
YOU MAY BE.
YOU MAY BE A FREEWAY FLYER FOR
QUITE SOME TIME -- COLLECTING
THE CREDIT YOU NEED TO MOVE TO
THE SYSTEM BUT PERHAPS YOUR YOUR
HOME BASES WHERE YOU.
YOU KNOW YOU YOU TAKE NINE
CREDITS YOUR EIGHT CREDITS IN A
PARTICULAR QUARTER IN FOR SOME
PLACE ELSE YOU CAME UP WITH THAT
FAR FASTER THAN IT TOOK US TO
COME UP ABOUT OUR HOME SO WE I
THINK WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT A
JOB ON US THERE WERE.
NO DOUBT IT'S A IT MAKES ME
REALIZE -- MANY PEOPLE COULD --
DO THIS WORK WELL SO -- WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE THE PLACE WHERE
THE STUDENTS TOOK THE MOST UNITS
ARE THE PLACE WHERE THE STUDENT
LAST ATTENDED.
OR THOUGHT SOME THRESHOLD THAT
SAYS WILL KILL THE STUDENT AT
ANY DISTRICT WITH A STUDENT AT
ATTAINED A MINIMUM NUMBER OF
UNITS IN THE MOST RECENT YEAR.
FOR WEIGHING DIFFERENT OPTIONS
RECOGNIZING THE GOLD OF THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET
GOOD.
AND IN THE LAST -- SLIDE ON PAGE
SIX AGAIN JUST TO REITERATE --
THIS DATA REVIEW NO I THINK WE
SEE THE TWO ISSUES IN THE BUDGET
BEING YOU KNOW HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THE FUNDING FORMULAS
FINANCIALLY IS A SUSTAINABLE.
AND THEN HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT THE DATA IS VALID AND
RELIABLE -- WE PASS THE FAKE NOT
TO DO THAT REVIEW SO THE THREE
THINGS THEY'RE COMING BACK TO US
WITH.
OUR REPORT ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THE SYSTEM TODAY WHAT ARE THE
COMMON PRACTICES WHAT OUR BEST
PRACTICES THEY'VE NOTED --
HIGHLIGHTING WEAKNESSES AND
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO US
ABOUT -- PROTOCOLS THAT WE
SHOULD PUT IN PLACE POLICIES
THAT WE SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTING
IT AT A SYSTEM LEVEL TO ENSURE
CONFIDENCE AND THEN HOW WOULD WE
GO ABOUT AUDITING THESE TYPES OF
DATA.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
EARLIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WHEN YOU
REFER TO THE WORK GROUP IS THAT
THE ADVISORY GROUP.
THAT IS THE ADVISER WORKGROUP
THE LIBELED MAYBE JUST SAY THERE
ARE LOTS OF ENTITIES IN THE
SPACE RIGHT NOW SO THE STATUTE --
IN YOUR AGENDA NOTED THE STATUTE --
CREATED AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE A
TWELVE MEMBER COMMITTEE MADE UP
OF APPOINTEES OF THE GOVERNOR
THE LEGISLATURE AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS.
BOB THAT GROUP HAS A VERY
SPECIFIC CHARGE IN THE STATUTE
HAPPY TO TALK MORE SO THAT IS
NOT THE GROUP THAT'S LOOKING
INTO THIS.
THAT'S REALLY BAD MARKINGS OKAY
SO THAT WE HAVE AN ADVISORY WORK
GROUP THAT WE HAVE CHARGED WITH
REVIEWING FUNDING FORMULA ISSUES
AND THEN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA HAS CREATED
A WORK GROUP OF A CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS AND TRUSTEES
TO ALSO REVIEW THE FUNDING
FORMULA SO THERE'S THANK.
ALLAH I NEED FOR COORDINATION WE
ARE WORKING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COORDINATE ACROSS THESE ENTITIES
I I AGREE WITH YOU THAT IS MY MY
HOPE BECAUSE WHAT I'VE HEARD IS
THAT THERE IS A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION.
BETWEEN THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND IF IN THE DISTRICTS AS FAR
AS HOW THEY CHANGED THE FORMULA --
HOW BEST TO MAKE THE FORMULA
WORK -- SO DO THE THREE GROUPS
EVER TALK.
WE HAVE WORK TO HAVE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN OUR OFFICE
AND THE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUES -- GROUP -- THE
WORKGROUP OR EXCUSE ME THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE HAS HAD ONE
MEETING OUR OFFICE -- OR WAS
THERE AND SO WE'VE COMMUNICATED
WITH THEIR STAFF -- I WOULD SAY
THE THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
THOUGH VERY INTENTIONALLY IS
INDEPENDENT FROM OUR OFFICE THE
STATUTE -- DIRECTED US TO
CONTRACT WITH A THIRD PARTY TO
HAVE STAFF FOR THAT COMMITTEE SO
WE ARE NOT SUPPORTING THE END OF
THE DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS BY
COMMITTEE.
SO THE WORKING ADVISORY GROUP I
WOULD JUST -- STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO REACH
OUT TO THEM TO WORK WITH THEM --
AND THEN ADDITIONALLY I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU ARE INCLUDING
EMPLOYEES AND FACULTY AND ASKING
THEM THEIR OPINION ON HOW THIS
WORKS AND HOW TO CREATE A BETTER
FORMULA.
YES SO -- ON OUR ADVISORY WORK
GROUP WE HAVE A VARIETY IT'S
HISTORICALLY BEEN MADE UP OF
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICIALS BUT
WE'VE WORKED YOU ADD OTHERS
INCLUDING FACULTY TO THAT GROUP --
I WOULD SAY I THINK WE HAVE DONE
IT IN A VARIETY OF WAYS.
WE'VE HAD A BIT OF A ROAD SHOW
GOING TO CONFERENCES BUT I I
CERTAINLY HEAR THE FEEDBACK AND
I THINK WE CAN DO MORE AND SO --
HAPPY -- TO IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC WAYS YOU THINK IT MAKES
SENSE OR I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO TALK WITH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD JUST SAY
JUST TALK TO THEM I IN MY LIFE
BEFORE HERE -- SOMETIMES UPON
HIGH HAS IDEAS ABOUT HELPING
SHOULD WORK AND SOMETIMES ARE
GOOD IDEAS BUT NOT TALKING TO
THE FOLKS THAT ARE ACTUALLY IN
THE TRENCHES THE TEACHERS THE
EMPLOYEES THE ONES ARE ACTUALLY
DOING THE WORK AND COMMUNICATING
WITH STUDENTS AND TRYING.
TO HELP THE STUDENTS -- MOVE
AHEAD I THINK SOMETIMES WE CAN
BE A LITTLE SHORT SIGHTED SO I
WOULD SAY THE MORE YOU CAN BRING
FACULTY IN.
AND TALK TO THEM THE MORE THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAN ENGAGE
THEM I JUST DON'T SEE ANY
DOWNSIDE TO THAT SO I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK ON THAT
THERE'S ANYTHING I CAN DO TO BE
HELPFUL.
PLEASE LET ME KNOW WE'LL DO IT
AND AND I WOULD SAY ONE OF THE
OTHER STRUCTURES AND WE HAVE A
LONG.
AND FORMALIZE HISTORY OF
CONSULTATION THE SYSTEM WE HAVE
A CONSULTATION COUNCIL BUT IT
AGAIN IS MADE UP OF VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE SYSTEM WE
WILL BE PRESENTING -- AT THEIR
MEETING NEXT WEEK A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HOPE TO
MAKE TO YOU ALL INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION A LATER THIS YEAR.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
HELLO SAVING FURTHER.
LET ME THANK YOU FOR A GREAT
PRESENTATION -- LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER CONVERSATION ABOUT THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THIS IS AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEM
.
WHAT'S THE GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE IF
I COULD HAVE YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD.
GOOD MORNING HEATHER HEIL CEO OF
THE ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. TO
SEE YOU AGAIN MA'AM SIR MORNING
AT JULIA ROBERTS CFO AT THE
FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MISTER ROBERTS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START.
I THINK OUR HOPE FOR THEIR UP IF
THAT'S OKAY -- I JUST WANT TO
SAY.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE SENATORS AND I
WANT TO INTRODUCE MYSELF AND
GIVE YOU A BIT OF AN UPDATE --
AS TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN UP TO FOR
THE PAST. EIGHT WEEKS THAT I'VE
BEEN ON THE JOB -- ANTI ANSWER
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE --
I HAVE PERSONALLY I'M.
A SOCIAL ENTREPRENEUR AND A
SERIAL ENTREPRENEUR AND A
TECHNOLOGIST.
BUT IVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITYTO
DO A LOT TO HELP PEOPLE ACHIEVE
THEIR ACADEMIC GOALS AS WELL AS
THEIR PROFESSIONAL GOALS FOR THE
PAST THIRTY YEARS.
SO -- I'M A BIT OF AN EXPERT IN
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND VERY
DELIGHTED TO BE ABLE TO FACE
SUCH A LARGE CHALLENGE AND TO
SERVE SUCH IMPORTANT NEEDS -- AS
WE'VE OUTLINED -- IN THE IN THE
WAY OF YOU KNOW OVER EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE UNDEREMPLOYED
OR UNEMPLOYED.
AND NEED SKILLS UPGRADING TO GET
LIVING WAGE JOBS -- WE HAVE IN
THE WAY OF UPDATES PROBABLY THEM
THE MOST PRESSING IN HIM AND
INTERESTING.
UPDATE IS THAT WE HAVE.
STARTED ORGANIZING AND PLANNING
FOR OUR FIRST THREE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT WILL GO LIVE ON
OCTOBER FIRST OF THIS YEAR.
THE FIRST OF THE TRIP THREE
TRAINING PROGRAMS IS MEDICAL
CODING.
THE SECOND ONE IS A CYBER
SECURITY TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND A GENERAL I. T. HELP DESK
TYPE OF A POSITION THAT WILL BE
TRAINING -- FOR SO AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WE ARE WORKING WITH.
A NUMBER OF FACULTY ADVISORS
HELPING US SELECT THE RIGHT
CURRICULA AND DESIGN THE RIGHT
TRAINING PROGRAM.
WE ARE EXAMINING -- THE RIGHT
TECHNOLOGIES TO DELIVER THE
TRAINING AND BUILDING IN A LOT
OF THE PLANNING AND SUPPORTS.
FOR JOB COACHING -- ONCE PEOPLE
ARE PLACED INTO THEIR JOBS BUT
ALSO BUILDING ON NOT ONLY THE
RIGHT ONLINE TRAINING PROGRAM
FOR PEOPLE BUT ALSO APPLIED
LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
AND WE'RE ENGAGING WITH A LOT OF
EMPLOYERS TO FIND THE RIGHT
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE WILLING TO PAY
PEOPLE TO LEARN THEIR JOBS.
AND FINALLY -- I'M DOING A LOT
OF WHAT A TYPICAL START UP WOULD
DO IN THAT I'M LOOKING TO HIRE
AT LEAST THIS.
CADRE OF SENIOR LEVEL FOLKS WHO
ARE GOING TO WORK WITH US TO
BUILD OUT THESE PROGRAMS MOVING
FORWARD.
AND ENGAGING WITH OUR KEY
PARTNERS FROM THE EMPLOYER AND
UNION COMMUNITY.
COMMUNITIES -- AND AND DOING
OTHER THINGS LIKE STILL.
WE'RE GETTING VERY CLOSE TO BUT
FINDING OUR ACTUAL NAME FOR A
COLLEGE.
SO YOU KNOW THAT'S A LOT OF WHAT
HAPPENS IN A START UP IS YOU
HAVE TO DO SOME BASICS THAT YOU
MIGHT TAKE FOR GRANTED OTHERWISE.
SO I JUST WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU ALL MAY
HAVE.
LET [inaudible]
WITH EVERYONE.
LET ME -- GO AHEAD SIR LEGALLY
YOU'RE SO PATIENT.
SO CONGRATULATIONS THAT'S A BIG
JOB STARTING A NEW SCHOOL AND
FINDING THE NAME IS KEY BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW ENGAGES FOLKS.
SO I JUST WANT TO ASK ABOUT YOU
KNOW WITH ONLINE STUDIES I WORRY
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT STUDENTS JUST
BEING BEHIND THE SCREEN.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE ABLE TO SOCIALLY ENGAGE --
AND GET THAT GOOD PAYING JOB HOW
HOW DO YOU SEE YOURSELF DOING
YEAH AND THAT'LL YOU KNOW --
AFTER MY LIFE AFTER I SOLD MY
LAST COMPANY AT THE END OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN I ENDED UP
WORKING WITH THE BILL MELINDA
GATES FOUNDATION FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS -- AND I RAN A PORTFOLIO
THAT INVESTED IN DEVELOPMENTAL
EDUCATION DIGITAL LEARNING --
ADVISING -- FINANCIAL SECURITY
ETCETERA -- AND WHAT WE'VE
LEARNED THROUGH STUDY AFTER
STUDY WHICH HAVE ALREADY KNOWN
BUT BUT REALLY -- REINFORCED --
THIS INFORMATION THAT PEOPLE WHO
TYPICALLY DIDN'T DO WELL IN
TRADITIONAL EDUCATION.
DO NOT PERFORM WELL ON A PURELY
ONLINE EXPERIENCE.
SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS USE
TECHNOLOGY. FOR WHAT IT DOES
BEST WHICH IS TO DELIVER.
REAL TIME IN A FLEXIBLE WAY WHEN
PEOPLE NEED IT WHENEVER THAT IS.
THE RIGHT CONTENT THAT THEY CAN
REVIEW AND MASTER AND COMPLETE
THEIR ASSESSMENTS ONLINE FOR
EXAMPLE BUT IT MAY BE THAT
SOMEBODY -- EVEN.
THROUGH THEIR MOBILE DEVICE GETS
THE RIGHT CONTENT TO TAKE YOU
KNOW LEARN THE NEXT THING
QUICKLY AND EASILY.
BUT THAT IS NOT A SUBSTITUTE FOR
FOLKS HAVING APPLIED LEARNING
EXPERIENCES ON THE JOB WHICH IS
WHY PAID WORK EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCE OR APPRENTICESHIP IS
CRITICAL TO OUR MODEL.
AND ADDITIONALLY WHY WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SUCCESS
SUPPORTS ONCE THEY'RE EVEN
PLACED INTO THE JOB BECAUSE A
LOT OF FOLKS IF THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THEY'VE BEEN IN THIS
KIND OF WORK ENVIRONMENT NEED.
ONGOING COACHING AND OTHER
SUPPORTS.
AND AND AND SO I I WOULD
ACTUALLY CALL IT MORE ACCURATELY
A BLENDED LEARNING EXPERIENCE
WHICH MEANS ONLINE PLUS IN
PERSON THE ALSO THE FOLKS WERE
SERVING -- TYPICALLY DON'T HAVE
NETWORKS THEY GET THEM INTO
GETTING INTERVIEWED ARE
CONSIDERED FOR JOBS EVEN -- AND
LINKED IN JUST PRODUCE A STUDY
THAT SAID OVER 80% OF US
ACTUALLY WE GET OUR JOBS TO
REFER ALL FROM FRIENDS AND
FAMILY.
SO IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
NETWORK IT'S KIND OF CHICKEN AND
EGG HAD EVEN BREAK INTO THE JOBS.
SO WE'VE GOT TO HELP THEM BUILD
THEIR FIRST NETWORKS.
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU.
THE GREAT QUESTIONS -- LET. ONE
OF MY CONCERNS -- AS WE TALKED.
IS THE DEMAND SIDE OF WHAT I
CALL CAREER TECH EDUCATION.
WHICH IS SOMEWHAT WHAT YOU WERE
ENGAGED IN AT THE ONLINE
[inaudible]
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND YOUR OPERATING ON A GRAND
SCALE STATEWIDE.
THE FOLKS AT WILL FOLLOW YOU AND
SOME OF THE OTHER ISSUES MAY
HEAR THE SAME QUESTION.
HOW DO YOU COLLECT THE
INFORMATION?
ON THE DEMAND SIDE -- COMPILE IT
SORT IT TO FIGURE OUT HOW MANY
JOBS IN MEDICAL CODING FOR
EXAMPLE.
ARE THERE THAT EXIST ON FILLED.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SAME FOR THE OTHER. TWO
ISSUES OF OUR FIELD TO TURN
MENTIONED -- AND IS THERE A
SINGLE POINT OF CONTACT IN THE
IN REGIONS OR COMMUNITIES.
IS IT THE SAME CONTACT THAT YOU
GO TO IS THAT THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD REGIONALLY FOR
EXAMPLE -- I'M I'M INTERESTED
BECAUSE YOU KNOW FRANKLY I THINK
WE FACE THE SAME ISSUES.
WHEN WE START TALKING ABOUT THE
THE CONSORTIUM THAT WE HAVE
AROUND THE STATE THAT ARE
DEALING WITH -- CTP -- IT'S THE
A CRITICAL ISSUE AND AS I
LEARNED BACK WHEN I LAUNCHED SF
WORKS IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
AS A RESPONSE TO WELFARE REFORM.
AND FOCUSING ON HARD SKILLS --
THE DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING AND
DELIVERY OF HARD SKILLS TO GET
PEOPLE OFF WELFARE INTO LIVING
WAGE JOBS WHAT I LEARNED AT THAT
POINT IN TIME IN ROCKEFELLER
READY CASE STUDY ABOUT ON THIS
MODEL WHICH IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
WORK WITH EMPLOYERS AND SPECIFIC
SHOPS ON THE FRONT END.
BECAUSE EMPLOYERS DON'T HAVE
CONFIDENCE OR EVEN KNOWLEDGE OF
WHAT.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
OTHERS ARE DOING TO REALLY
PREPARE THEM FOR THEIR JOBS THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE CONFIDENCE.
IN KNOWING THAT -- PEOPLE HAVE
CERTAIN KINDS OF THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT A LETTER GRADE FROM
ONE INSTITUTION TO ANOTHER
REALLY REPRESENTS ENOUGH THE
FORM OF THIS PERSON BEING READY
FOR THEIR JOB.
SO.
THAT REALLY BE GETS -- THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE EMPLOYERS
WITH THE JOBS WHERE THEY CAN'T
FIND ENOUGH SKILLED PEOPLE AND
RETAIN THEM.
ON AND THEY NEED -- TO WORK WITH
A PLAYER LIKE US TO SUPPLY AND
FILL THE NEEDS THAT THEY CAN'T
SEEM TO FILL.
IT'S IT'S NOT EASY.
BUT IT IS I THINK N IMPERATIVE
THIS IS THE ONLY WAY THAT I KNOW
HOW TO MAKE IT WORK.
AND WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT --
MANY OF OUR COMPANIES -- IN --
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA ARE AWARE
OF THE FACT THAT THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO FIND AND RETAIN THE
RIGHT TALENT.
ALL LONG ENOUGH AND
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF THOSE
COMPANIES ALTHOUGH THEY'RE
SITTING ON BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
CASH DON'T NECESSARILY INVESTED
INTO CALIFORNIANS.
OFTENTIMES THEY OUTSOURCE THOSE
JOBS THE OTHER PLACES.
SO EVEN IN OUR FIRST TRAINING
PROGRAM IT'S A VERY INTERESTING --
CASE STUDY BECAUSE MEDICAL
CODING IS A VERY WELL PAYING JOB
TODAY.
BUT A LOT OF THOSE JOBS ARE
BEING OUTSOURCED TO INDIA AND
OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND A LOT OFTHOSE JOBS -- WILL
ALSO BECOE OBSOLETE IN THE NEXT
DECADES BECAUSE MEDICAL CODING
WHICH IS LABOR INTENSIVE NOW
WILL BE HANDLED BY A I AND A LOT
OF NEW TECHNOLOGY.
SO I NEED TO USE THAT AS AN INCH
IN ILLUSTRATION.
AND A POINT WITH OUR LAWYER
ADULT LEARNERS BUT IT IS YOUR
ENTRYWAY INTO THE HEALTH CARE
PATHWAY.
IT IS THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
CAREER PATH IT'S NOT THE FINAL
DESTINATION.
ALL WE KNOW FROM STUDIES TODAY.
THAT THE AVERAGE EMPLOYEE TODAY
WHO'S AROUND THE AGE OF YOU KNOW
EARLY TWENTIES WILL HAVE
SEVENTEEN JOBS IN FIVE DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF INDUSTRY THROUGHOUT
THEIR CAREER.
SO THAT MEANS LIKE MY MOTHER HAD
ONE JOB WORKING FOR THE IRS FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND IT WAS
LITERALLY THE SAME JOB FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I LIKE TO SAY I'VE HAD
PROBABLY THIRTY FIVE JOBS.
AND IT'S A REALLY DIFFERENT
WORLD WE LIVE IN NOW AND YOU CAN
CALL THE GIG ECONOMY CAUGHT THIS
OR THAT.
WHAT I FOUND IS A LOT OF
EMPLOYERS FEEL LIKE HAT MAY BE
A WAY OF -- TAKING A PASS ON
INVESTING IN OUR WORK FORCE AND
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS INCREASINGLY
MORE PEOPLE ARE GETTING
DISCONNECTED FROM FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT WITH BENEFITS.
IT'S LIVING WAGE SHOULD WEAR
THAT ALLOWS FOR THEM TO THRIVE
AND SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES.
AND SO WE REALLY I THINK HAVE TO
IMPRESS UPON THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY.
AND I DO HAVE A STRATEGY FOR
THAT -- THAT GETS THEM TO INVEST
IN OUR PEOPLE AND OUR ADULT
WORKERS AND AND INVESTING IN
THEM TO DO BE ABLE TO TO NEW
JOBS THAT THEY'VE JUST CREATED --
IN THE WAY THAT WE DO THAT IS I
THINK WE MAKE A BUSINESS CASE.
SO RECENTLY ACCENTURE DID A
RETURN ON INVESTMENT STUDY FOR
THE COMPANY DISCOVER WHICH IS A
FINANCIAL.
CARD CREDIT CARD.
AND THEY FOUND THAT WHEN
DISCOVER WAS WILLING TO PAY FOR
PEOPLE'S ONGOING EDUCATION.
THEY HAD BETTER RETENTION AND
LOYALTY FROM THEIR EMPLOYEES
THEY ALSO HAD EMPLOYEE
SATISFACTION IMPROVE.
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT CASES
TO BE MADE AND WE'RE RIGHT NOW
WORKING WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL AND STARTING TO PARTNER
AND TALK WITH.
ON MANY DIFFERENT -- WHO WATCH
ECONOMISTS AND PEOPLE WHO WATCH
THE DATA AND THE LABOR
STATISTICS WHICH JOBS ARE BEING?
ELIMINATED WHICH ONES ARE BEING
CREATED HOW MANY ARE THERE HOW
MANY ARE PROJECTED TO GROW --
OVER THE NEXT DECADE TO DECADE.
AND AND WE WILL PRIORITIZE OUR
JOB TRAINING FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF IS THERE A GOOD
ENTRY LEVEL POSITION FOR PEOPLE
TO GET INTO THAT SECTOR AND INTO
THAT PATHWAY.
BASED ON THE TRAINING WE CAN
PROVIDE CYBER SECURITY IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE THERE SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
UNFILLED JOBS NATIONWIDE.
THE ONLY MORE GROWING EVERY DAY
AND YOU CAN START OUT AS AN
ADDED ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT.
LEARN CYBER SECURITY PROTOCOLS
ON THAT WHEN THERE'S A BEAUTIFUL
CURRICULA WITHIN THE COMMUNICATE
SYSTEM FOR THIS EXACT IT --
TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND AND ENHANCE YOUR SALARY BY
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS SO
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
BUILD OUT OUR TRAINING PROGRAMS.
I REALIZE YOU'VE ONLY BEEN THERE
A WEEK'S.
BUT I MEAN YOU SORT OF HAVE A
CHALLENGE DON'T YOU I MEAN HOW
DO PEOPLE KNOW.
WHO ON WHO YOU ARE?
ONLINE COMMUITY COLLEGE YOU
KNOW IF YOU WERE.
LIVING IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES YOU MAY GO TO
THE FOOTBALL GAMES OF BASEBALL
GAMES OR CONCERTS ON THE CAMPUS
AND SO YOU GET TO KNOW WHERE THE
COLLEGES ARE AND WHAT THEY DO
AND AND IS A NATURAL.
DRAW THERE IF YOU'RE SO INCLINED.
BUT HOW DO OTHER PEOPLE KNOW.
ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE I MEAN
TO SOME EXTENT I GUESS YOU MADE
MAYBE YOU CAN HOOK UP WITH THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES IF
THEY'RE WILLING TO DO SO.
I WOULD GUESS THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO FIND MORE CROP OF COOPERATION
IN SOME PARTS OF THE STATE THAN
OTHERS -- IS THAT A FAIR
QUESTION THAT'S A VERY FAIR
QUESTION -- AND BECAUSE WE ARE
UNIQUE.
INSTITUTION THAT CAN PROVIDE
TRAINING THAT IS IN ESSENCE FREE
TO THE LEARNER.
AND REALLY BORNE BY THE EMPLOYER
TO PAY FOR IT.
SUCH INSTRUCTION.
ON THIS IS A NEW MODEL AND A NEW
OFFERING AND HONESTLY A LOT OF
OUR COMPETITORS.%
ARE THOSE -- PREDATORY
INSTITUTIONS SPECIALLY ONLINE
COLLEGE IS GOING AFTER PEOPLE'S
STUDENT LOAN MONEY WITHOUT
PROVIDING THEM ANY KIND OF
GUARANTEES TO GOOD EMPLOYMENT OR
ANY KIND OF GUARANTEED RETURN ON
THEIR INVESTMENT.
THAT'S OUR BIG COMPETITOR AND SO
WE'RE PARTNERING WITH OUR OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE [inaudible]
PARTNERS -- TO TO RECRUIT OUR
ADULT LEARNERS BACK INTO
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EITHER --
WORK BEST FOR THEM THROUGH A
TRADITIONAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND ENVIRONMENT OR IF THEY'RE
THEY'RE KIND OF MID CAREER.
AND AND AND NEEDING TO GO
DIRECTLY TO EMPLOYMENT AND
REALLY DON'T HAVE TIME TO DO TO
BE FULL TIME STUDENTS.
WELL -- THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THAT
ARE PROBABLY BEST TAILORED FOR
OUR OUR PROGRAM SO WE'RE REALLY
OUR FIRST.
TARGET -- A SUBSET OF THE MARKET
IF YOU WILL IS THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION FOLKS.
AGES -- AGE.
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY FOUR WHO --
WHO ARE IN NEED OF SKILLS
UPGRADING BUT THEY'RE ALREADY
WORKING -- PROBABLY MORE THAN
FULL TIME HONESTLY JUST CAN'T
MAKE ENDS MEET -- WE'VE GOT TO
BE ABLE TO DO GRASSROOTS
MESSAGING TO THEM WE'VE GOT TO
BE ABLE TO DO -- OTHER KINDS OF
OUTREACH TO GET THE MESSAGE AND
WORD OUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT WE ARE AVAILABLE.
AND SO HELP HAVING A NAME IN A
WEBSITE REALLY HELPS.
AND WHY WE'RE KIND OF CLOSE --
TO MASTERING THAT PART BUT THEN
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
PARTNERING WITH LABOR UNIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HOPEFULLY ALL OF YOU.
AND TO TO TO LET YOU KNOW TO GET
THE MESSAGE OUT THAT WERE
AVAILABLE AND WE'RE HERE WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO NEED.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT OUR CAL GRANT
PROGRAM AND DO SOME
MODIFICATIONS TO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS IN THAT
PARTICULAR AGE GROUP BECAUSE
THEY'RE PRETTY MUCH OUT OF LUCK.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT'S CORRECT THE
WAY OUR PROGRAM IS DESIGNED ONE
FINAL QUESTION YOU KNOW I'M I'M
SORT OF LOOKING. TO TO YOU IN
THE ONLINE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
OPERATION.
TO GOING BACK TO TO THE DEMAND
SIDE. TO BUILD SORT OF A STATE
WIDE INFRASTRUCTURE -- THAT
EXTENDS THE TENTACLES EXTEND
DOWN INTO LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
REGIONS -- TO IDENTIFY.
WHETHER IT'S WORK REGIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S OR
SOME OTHER [inaudible]
EXISTING GROUP. TO BE THE POINT
GROUP. FOR EMPLOYERS TO IDENTIFY
JOB AND SKILL NEEDS.
IT CAN THEN BE COLLECTED AND
COLLATED BY YOU BUT ALSO
UTILIZED BY THE REGIONAL
EDUCATIONAL CONSORTIA.
TO IDENTIFY THE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS THAT AND DESIGN THE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT THEY NEED
TO IN ORDER TO A DARK DRESS
REGIONAL NEEDS YEAH BUT BUT YOU
ARE ALMOST BEST EQUIPPED. TO DO
THAT SORT OF ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS SO WE HAVE CONSISTENCY.
YOU KNOW FROM CHICO DECEMBER TO
DENOTE TUNED.
IRVINE TO SAN DIEGO AND AN
EMPLOYER WITH ONE SITE WERE
TWENTY FIVE SITES IN THE STATE
WOULD KNOW. TO GO TO THIS
PARTICULAR GROUP AND SAY.
I CAN'T FIND AN X. Y. Z..
AND I'VE GOT TWENTY FIVE OF THAT
I NEED.
CAN YOU HELP AND THEN THAT GROUP
COULD THEN PASS IT TO YOU PASS
IT TO THE EDUCATIONAL CONSORTIA.
AND WE COULD BEGIN TO MEET JOB
NEEDS ON A MORE ORGANIZED BASIS
I THINK AT LEAST THAT'S MY
PERCEPTION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THAT DOABLE.
THAT IS DOABLE GENERAL RIGHT AND
I THINK THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL --
VISION AS WELL I THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WHAT I'VE SEEN AGAIN
THROUGH SOME OF MY RESEARCH EVEN
IN STATES WHERE -- THE LABOR
INFORMATION IS MORE READILY
AVAILABLE TO THE EDUCATIONAL
COMMUNITY -- THERE'S A HUGE LAG
BETWEEN -- WHAT EMPLOYERS ARE
DOING REAL TIME CREATING NEW
JOBS THAT HAVE NEW COMPETENCIES
ATTACHED TO THEM?
AND HOW IT GETS ACTUALLY
PUBLISHED OR ORGANIZED IN A
DATABASE WHICH IS USUALLY TWO OR
THREE YEARS OUT OF TOUCH BY THE
TIME IT'S ACTUALLY UPDATED.
AND THEN WHEN IT HOW DOES IT
MEAN WHEN DOES IT GET TRANSLATED
TO SOME KIND OF INSTRUCTION
SYSTEM.
WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE ETHER AND
SO THE SYSTEM IS UNFORTUNATELY --
UNDER DEVELOPED RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK THAT WITH TODAY'S
TECHNOLOGIES ESPECIALLY.
WELL THERE ARE LOTS OF EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES BUT WE HAVE A WAY
WHERE WE COULD ACTUALLY PUT THAT
ONLINE.
AND TAKE TAKE THE WITH THE OTHER
BENEFITS OF MEDITATED TAKE THAT
THAT INFORMATION AND MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE REAL TIME
AND I THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE A
HUGE CONTRIBUTION TO THE ENTIRE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
BECAUSE I WAS READING IT FOR YOU.
I WAS READING IT THE LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY AND AND INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT NEEDS.
TWENTY TWENTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
I'VE TRIED OTHER GOOD JOB BUT I
THOUGHT WELL WHAT IS WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN.
WHAT WHAT WHAT KIND DO YOU DO
WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT TYPES OF JOBS
WHAT JOBS SKILLS ARE REQUIRED
FOR THE?
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN IT
IT'S IT'S IT'S TWENTY THOUSAND
FOOT DATA.
BUT THAT'S NOT HOW YOU PLAN AN
EDUCATIONAL THAT'S RIGHT.
CURRICULAR TRAINING PROGRAMS
RIGHT OR TRAINING PROGRAM WE
NEED TO HAVE MORE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK YOU COULD PLAY A KEY ROLE
IN THIS. ELEVEN A FOR THE
QUESTION.
YOUR ANSWER TO ME WAS PERFECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE RESULTS OF YOUR HARD WORK I
LOOK FORWARD TO COMING BACK AND
GIVE ANY UPDATES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE IS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY.
ALMOST THE SAME GROUP MA'AM
WOULD YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD PLEASE.
THE THINKING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START OFF LEAD
OFF WITH THIS [inaudible]
ONE FINANCE.
SEAN DOING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT.
A SECOND YEAR FREE TUITION BY
EXTENDING THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE THE FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS IN THEIR SECOND
ACADEMIC YEAR.
THE PROPOSAL BUILDS ON CURRENT
LAW AS ESTABLISHED BY A. B.
NINETEEN WHICH ITSELF
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE.
AND ALLOWS COLLEGES TO WAIVE
FEES FOR THAT FIRST YEAR OF
COLLEGE FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
DOES NOT CHANGE ANY OF THE
EXISTING PROVISIONS OF THE
CURRENT LAW EXCEPT FOR EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM TO A SECOND ACADEMIC
YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO EXPAND
OUT REACH AROUND THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE BY ESTABLISHING
THE STUDENT SUCCESS AWARENESS
INITIATIVE.
AS MORE COLLEGES IMPLEMENT
PROMISE PROGRAMS THERE IS A NEED
TO ENSURE THAT COLLEGES CAN
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE TO
STUDENTS INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
PROMISE PROGRAMS.
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE IN THEIR
FINANCIAL AID OPPORTUNITIES AND
PATHWAYS TO SUCCESS.
THIS FUNDING IS INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THAT NEED.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
AND AGAIN THE EXPANSION OF
COLLEGE PROMISES WITHOUT REGARD
TO FINANCIAL NEED [inaudible]
CORRECT [inaudible]
OKAY -- THANK YOU.
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM YOUR
AGENDA STARTING ON PAGE.
FIFTEEN AS YOU KNOW THE STATE
HAS A LONG STANDING PROGRAM
CALLED THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
FEE WAIVER THAT PROVIDES
ENROLLMENT FEE WAIVERS FOR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE FINANCIAL NEED.
CURRENTLY OVER 40% OF CCC
STUDENTS RECEIVE FULL FEE
WAIVERS THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A
SHARED THE STATE DID RECENTLY
EXTENDS THIS PROGRAM RATHER
EXPEND FEE WAIVERS. TO SELECTED
STUDENTS WITHOUT FINANCIAL.
SPECIFICALLY THE STUDENTS ARE
FIRST TIME STUDENTS ENROLLING
FULL TIME.
DURING THE FIRST YEAR OF COLLEGE.
ST FIRST FUNDED THIS PROGRAM
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM.
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE FUNDS UNDER
THIS PROGRAM COLLEGES ARE
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN SIX
IN SUPPORT PRACTICES.
WHAT ARE DETAILED ON PAGE
SIXTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA?
IN THE SENSE THIS PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO SERVE AS AN
INCENTIVE FOR COLLEGES CAN PROOF
CAN SUPPORT.
FINANCE TO SHED THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING TO AUGMENT FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
IN ORDER TO FUD A SECONDARY FEE
WAIVERS FOR SKIN FLAP FINANCIAL
NEED.
OUR OFFICE DOES HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONSENSUS PROPOSAL.
WHICH ARE LISTED ON PAGE
EIGHTEEN OF YOUR CONTACT.
TOWARD THE BOTTOM.
THE FIRST OF OUR THREE CONCERNS
IS LARGELY A MATTER OF TIMING.
BECAUSE THE STATE FIRST FUNDED
THIS PROGRAM IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN IT'S TO SEND TOO SOON
TO VALIDATE THE OUTCOMES
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT IT'S HAD
ON COLLEGE ENROLLMENT
FINANCIALLY PARTICIPATION AND
SKIP OUTCOMES.
AND WITHOUT THIS INFORMATION WE
THINK IT MAY BE PREMATURE TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM AND NEARLY
DOUBLED FUNDING.
OUR SECOND CONCERN IS MRE
DISTRIBUTIONAL NATURE.
AS THE SUBCOMMITTEE KNOWS WELL
THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
UNMET FINANCIAL NEED RIGHT NOW
AMONG COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
NON TUITION COSTS WHICH ARE OF
COURSE NOT COVERED BY THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS WHO EVER.
GIVEN THAT THE GOAL HERE IS TO
INCREASE COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
WE THINK THAT IT MAY MAKE SENSE
TO START WITH ADDRESSING THE
UNMET NEED IN THE SYSTEM.
BEFORE TURNING TO EXPANDING FEE
WAIVERS FOR STUDENTS WITH OUT
NEED.
I THEIR CONCERN JUST RETURNS TO
THE POINT THAT THE COLLEGE
PROMISE PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO
INCENTIVIZE COLLEGES TO IMPROVE
SKIN SUPPORT.
HERE WE JUST NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALSO ENACTED
NUMBER OF REFORMS INCLUDING THE
SKIN CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
THAT PROVIDE LARGER INCENTIVES
FOR COLLEGES TO IMPROVE STUDENT
SUPPORT NOW COMES.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE DO
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO AUGMENT
FUNDING FOR THE COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
SHARED THERE IS ALSO A RELATED
PUZZLED PROVIDE FIVE MILLION IN
ONE TIME FUNDS.
EXPAND OUTREACH RELATED TO THE
COLLEGE PROMISE AND OTHER
STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
OUR OFFICE IS CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THIS PROPOSAL AND WILL
BE SURE TO KEEP THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF UPDATED AS WE REACH AN
ASSESSMENT.
THANK YOU WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
I'M SURE HELLO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO AS WE SEE IN THE EXAMPLE OF
TUITION ONLY ACCOUNTS 45% OF
TOTAL COST OF GOING TO A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SO MY QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT
THE ELLIE -- SEES A ROLE FOR A
TARGETED GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT ADDRESSES THE NON TUITION
COSTS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
WELL THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION
AND OUR ASSESSMENT OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL OFFICE HAS
IN THE PAST EXPLORED OPTIONS TO
EXPAND ON TUITION COVERAGE. FOR
STUDENTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND AT OTHER PUBLIC
SEGMENTS.
I HAVE A FEW YEARS AGO RELEASED
RECORD ON CUTTING IT UP FOR
COLLEGE PUZZLE THAT EXAMINES
THAT KIND OF MODEL.
AND WE DID THAT AT THE REQUEST
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE ARE ALSO A FEW EXISTING
PROGRAMS FUNDED THROUGH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
THAT ARE LISTED ON PAGE FIFTEEN
OF YOUR AGENDA.
THAT SEEK TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
NON TUITION COSTS FACED BY THE
STUDENTS.
BUT EVEN WITH THESE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE MANY STUDENTS YOU HAVE
UNMET NEEDS AS YOU KNOW.
VERY GOOD SO I DO HAVE A BILL.
SB TWO NINETY ONE THAT WOULD
HELP FIND A SOLUTION FOR NON
TUITION COSTS.
AND MY HOPE IS THAT OF COURSE
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND
HE SIGNS IT I JUST HAVE A REAL
CONCERN THAT YOU KNOW IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU -- PROVIDED ON
PAGE NINETEEN IT'S JUST SO
CLEARLY LAYS OUT THE TUITION IS
JUST SUCH A SMALL FRACTION OF
WHAT THE STUDENTS -- NEED TO
COME UP WITH AND PAY IN ORDER TO
GO TO COMMUNICATE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE THERE'S HOPE THAT WE CAN
ALL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON THAT
AND LOOK AT THE OTHER THINGS
THAT OUR STUDENTS NEED SO THAT
THEY CAN.
COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE OR THEIR
CERTIFICATE.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL LIVE. ZERO IT YOU GO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THEN I
HAVE AN OBSERVATION BUT SOUNDS
GOOD I'M GONNA GO BACK TO THE
PACKET A AHEAD OF WE HAVE
PREPARED AND START ON PAGE SEVEN
AND THEN I THINK I'LL BE TAKING
A A BROADER VIEW OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY -- THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT ON THIS PANEL YET
AND SO I WANTED TO START AND AND
SENATOR OUT THIS GOES TO TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT WHO ATTENDS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SO WE
WE'VE SHOWN YOU TWO CHARTS THERE.
I THINK -- WHAT WE SEE IN THOSE
CHARTS IS THAT WE SERVE A -- AN
OLDER POPULATION OF STUDENTS
STUDENTS WHO ARE COMING TO
HIGHER EDUCATION DIRECTLY FROM
HIGH SCHOOL.
MORE THAN 40% OF OUR STUDENTS
ROACH OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE AND IT IN ITS SKEWS
SIGNIFICANTLY OLDER GENERALLY.
WE ALSO SEE ON THE RIGHT THAT WE
SERVE A CONSIDERABLY DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATION WITH A NEARLY
HALF OF OUR STUDENTS IDENTIFY AS
LATIN ACTS.
AND SO AS WE THINK ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW A COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
IN THE STATE'S POLICIES AROUND
CULTURE FORTY ABILITY I THINK WE
YOU KNOW WE CARE A LOT ABOUT WHO --
THE EQUITY ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH -- OURS INSTITUTIONS ARE
SERVING AND HOW AFFORDABLE IT IS
BEEN.
US ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE SEVEN
AGAIN WE TALKED ABOUT -- NO THE
INFORMATION SHARED THIS
CONVERSATION HAS FOCUSED ON
TUITION -- AND WE I THINK ARE
VERY -- PROUD OF A HISTORY OF
LOW TUITION AND OF THE FACT THAT
MOST OF OUR STUDENTS -- NEARLY
HALF OF OUR STUDENTS.
DON'T PAY TUITION.
AB NINETEEN I THINK THE ONE
THING I WOULD WANT TO KNOW TODAY
MOVING TO PAGE.
DOES THAT MEAN JUST INTERRUPT
AND I APOLOGIZE BUT DOES.
DO YOU CAPTURE ALL OF THOSE WHO
HAVE FINANCIAL NEED.
WITH I GUESS WHAT YOU WE USED TO
CALL THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
WAIVER.
SO WITHOUT THAT THEN WE HAVE A
DEFINITION OF FINANCIAL NEED AS
PART OF THE PROGRAM AND WE SAY
IF YOU HAVE FINANCIAL NEED YOU
HAVE YOUR TUITION WAVED.
US STUDENTS WOULD ALSO HAVE
THEIR FEES WAIVED OB IF THEY
RECEIVED -- OTHER FORMS OF
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE OR IF THEY
FALL BELOW CERTAIN INCOME
THRESHOLDS SO WE'VE TAKEN CARE
OF THOSE WITH.
WHAT I WOULD CALL FINANCIAL NEED
WE HAVE FOCUSED CROSSES AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM CORRECT?
I MEAN THE ROUGH BUT IT'S ONE OF
THE OF COURSE.
I'M ON THE TOP OF PAGE IT I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT
ALTHOUGH A B. -- NINETEEN THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM TALKS -- IT IS IT IS
BEEN LARGELY TALKED ABOUT AS A
FREE TUITION PROGRAM IF YOU LOOK
AT THE GOALS -- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SAT IN A B. NINETEEN
THE GOALS ARE MUCH BROADER --
AND THEY ARE VERY CONSISTENT
WITH THE BOARD'S VISION TO
INCREASE COLLEGE PREPARATION FOR
STUDENTS TO IMPROVE PREPARATION
FOR IN DEMAND JOBS TO INCREASE
TRANSFER.
AND ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS ACROSS
REGIONS IN ACROSS GROUPS OF
STUDENTS.
AND SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
PROGRAM THERE'S A SET OF
PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEY PARTNER WITH LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES THAT USE THE
ABLE MAN OUR REFORMS TO
DEVELOPMENTAL EDUCATION THEY
PARTICIPATING GOTTA PATHWAYS.
AND THEY MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO THE RANGE OF
FINANCIAL AID AVAILABLE
INCLUDING FEDERAL LOANS -- WHICH
IT WE ARE I THINK OUR POSITION
THERE HAS VERY CLEARLY BEEN WE
DON'T -- WE WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE
AN ENVIRONMENT AND WE'LL TALK
LATER ABOUT -- OUR PLAN FOR HOW
YOU REDUCE -- BORROWING BUT THAT
STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO FEDERAL LOANS -- ARE OFTEN
FORCED INTO LESS DESIRABLE WAYS
OF BORROWING OR INTO WORKING
UNREASONABLE AMOUNTS OF OURS TO
MEET THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
AND SO THAT'S HOW THE STILL BE
INSTITUTIONS GET INTO THE
PROGRAM -- THEY CAN USE THE
MONEY TO WAIVE TUITION FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO ARE FIRST TIME FULL
TIME STUDENTS BUT THEY CAN USE
IT FOR OTHER PURPOSES THAT ALSO
WOULD.
ALLOW THE INSTITUTION TO MEET
THOSE GOALS.
AND SO IF YOU GO TO THE TOP OF
PAGE NINE I WOULD JUST NOTE OF
THE PROGRAM IN THE CURRENT YEAR
WAS FUNDED WITH FORTY SIX
MILLION.
WE ALLOCATED MOST OF THE DOLLARS --
THE COLLEGES BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF THOSE FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS WHO WEREN'T ALREADY
RECEIVING FEE WAIVERS BUT WE
ALSO TOOK INTO ACCOUNT -- THE
ENROLLMENT AT THE COLLEGES AND
THE NUMBER OF POCKET RECIPIENTS
OF THE COLLEGES IN NINETEEN
TWENTY UP THE LEVEL OF
PREPARATIONS OF EIGHTY MILLION
OF THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES.
WE WOULD LIKELY -- ALLOCATE
FUNDING -- OLD WE BASED ON THE
NUMBER FOR FIRST TIME FULL TIME
STUDENTS.
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE -- NINE WE
PRODUCED A CHART THAT IS VERY
SIMILAR TO THE CHART AND THE
AGENDA THE CHART ON THE AGENDA
LOOKED AT SAN DIEGO MESA COLLEGE
WE LOOK HERE AT RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE.
AND AGAIN THE SAME POINT THAT A
VERY SMALL -- FOR ALL OF
REGARDLESS OF THE STUDENTS
LIVING SITUATION LESS THAN 10%
OF THE FUNDS OF THE COST OF
ATTENDING A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
ARE THOSE COSTS OF TUITION AND
FEES.
ON PAGE TEN I JUST WANT TO GO TO
YOUR POINT SENATOR ROTH -- THERE
ARE BARRIERS IN THE CURRENT CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT MAKE IT VERY
UNLIKELY THAT A STUDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WOULD RECEIVE A CHARACTER AND
THE PRIMARY BERRIER -- IS THAT
IN ORDER TO BE ENTITLED TO AN
AWARD THE STUDENT MUST ROLAND
COLLEGE NO LATER THAN ONE YEAR
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
IF A STUDENT DOES NOT GET AN
ENTITLEMENT THEY ARE COMPETING
FOR ONE OF TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
AWARDS.
IN A RECENT ANALYSIS SHOWED THAT
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS OUR COMPETING FOR THESE
AWARDS.
SO IT'S LESS THAN A WATT
INTENTIONS.
AND THEN -- BECAUSE THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM IS LARGELY LINKED
TO TUITION VERY FEW COMMUNITY
CALL A VERY FEW OF THE DOLLARS.
I GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE TEN ARE WE SHOW ON THE LEFT
HAND SIDE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO WERE RECEIVING AWARDS.
SO NEARLY A MILLION STUDENTS
RECEIVE THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
PROMISE GRANT.
AROUND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS RECEIVE CALTRANS.
ALSO WE'VE DECIDED THAT THE
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE CALLS FROM
SCREENER FINANCIALLY NEEDY --
BUT ARE LESS THAN 10% OF THEM
ARE RECEIVING CAL GRANTS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE RIGHT SIDE.
OF THE VERY FEW OF THE CALIBER
OF DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS SO
WITH WE IN TERMS OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN CALGARY A REFORM.
IT IT IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE.
MORE THAN JUST INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE AWARDS
CORRECT WE BELIEVE AS I RECALL
IF WE TOOK THE SECOND YEAR OF
THE PROMISE MONEY WE COULD
PROBABLY DOUBLE THE COMPETITIVE
AWARDS MAYBE. TO FIFTY THOUSAND
FROM TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT POTENTIALLY
I WOULD SAY ONE OF THE CONCERNS
WE HAVE IN THIS CONVERSATION --
AND SENATOR LABOR THIS BILL --
NOTES THIS IN ITS INTENT NOT
ONLY DO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS RECEIVED VERY LITTLE
AND FINANCIAL AID BUT OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE FUNDED AND VERY
LOW LOW LEVELS OF PER STUDENT
FUNDING COMBAT SPECIALLY
COMPARED TO UC AND CSU.
EVEN LOWER COMPARED TO K. TWELVE
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WOULD -- HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT A
PROPOSAL LIKE THAT -- IS THAT WE
WOULD BE TAKING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS POTENTIALLY
IN USING IT FOR OTHER PURPOSES
WHAT OUR INSTITUTIONS NEED THAT
ONEY.
TO AND SO I THINK WHAT SENATOR
LABORS BILL WE ARE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT -- THEY APPROACH CENTER
LATEST TAKEN IN HER BILL -- OF
ALLOCATING FUNDING OUTSIDE OF
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED TO
SUPPORT THE THE ISSUES OF
AFFORDABILITY AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT I MEAN I MY POINT
WAS THE MAGNITUDE OF THE DOLLARS
IT IS LISTED AS INCREASING THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM WE
HAVE TO CHANGE WHAT THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM DOES.
VIS A VIS OMMUNITY COLLEGES
BECAUSE IT'S BECAUSE IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE FEE.
IT'S THE LIVING EXPENSES EVEN
FOR STUDENTS WHO GOT WHO --
RECEITA WHO WINDOW THE THE PRICE
TO GET THAT COMPETITIVE CAL
GRANT THEY GET A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS THE LIVING STIPEND
THAT THAT.
THAT THOSE STUDENTS WOULD
RECEIVE DEMEANOR UP AND DOWN AND
OUT.
SOMEONE PAGE -- ELEVEN WE'VE
JUST COMPARE THEIR ENROLLMENT
ACROSS THE THREE PUBLIC SEGMENTS
WHERE YOU SEE THAT ENROLLMENT
EARLY AND ENROLLMENT IF HOW
GREAT RECIPIENTS IS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TO THE CAL
GRANT FUNDS THAT ARE ALLOCATED
ACROSS THOSE -- THREE INSTITUTE
A THREE SEGMENTS WHERE THE WERE
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVES
BY FAR -- OF LOS MEDI CAL GRANT
FUND AGAIN FOR THOSE TWO
PURPOSES AND AND I WOULD SAY WE
MAKE THIS COMPARISON NOT TO SAY
THAT.
OTHERS SHOULD RECEIVE LESS BUT
TO SAY THAT WE KNOW HOW TO
PROVIDE AID TO STUDENTS IN OTHER
PLACES WERE JUST NOT PROVIDING
IT TO THIS SEGMENT.
THAT IS SERVING A CONSIDERABLY A
VERY DIVERSE POPULATION IN A
POPULATION OF OLDER STUDENTS WHO
HAVE FACED THE HIGHEST BIDDERS
TO ACCESS.
AND SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE IMPACT
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE -- ELEVEN
YOU'LL SEE THAT ACROSS TE THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS DID AN ANALYSIS AND
SHOWS THAT IN.
ALL NINE REGIONS WHERE THERE'S
AN UNDERGRADUATE UC CAMPUS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
DON'T HAVE THE LOWEST IN THAT
PRICE FOR THE LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS AND IN SEVEN OF THOSE
REGIONS THEY'RE THE MOST EXPECT
A EXPENSIVE OPTION FOR STUDENTS.
ON PAGE TWELVE WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THIS MORE THE NEXT AGENDA ITEM
BUT THERE'S AN IMPACT NOT ONLY
ON STUDENT SUCCESS.
BUT ON THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
STUDENTS WHILE THEY'RE ATTENDING
COLLEGE ARE THE HOPE CENTER --
FOR COLLEGE COMMUNITY AND
JUSTICE DID A A STUDY OF BASIC
NEEDS SECURITY IN OUR COLLEGES.
AND FOUND THAT HALF OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
FITTED SECURE IN THE PAST THIRTY
DAYS 60% WERE HOUSING IN
SECURITY AND SECURE AND NEARLY
ONE IN FIVE FOR HOMELESS IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
SO THAT ALL LEADS US.
TO OUR BIG CALL FOR REFORM WE'VE
GOT SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID BASED ON FINANCIAL
NEED NOTHING ELSE.
THAT THEY SHOULD BE THAT
FINANCIAL AID SHOULD BE LINKED
TO THE TOTAL COST NOT JUST
TUITION AND FEES.
AND THAT IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
EQUITABLY ACROSS EDUCATIONAL
GOALS NOT NECESSARILY FOCUSED
ONLY ON STUDENTS SEEKING DEGREES
ARE -- TO TRANSFER TO A FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTION BUT ALSO THOSE
WHO COME TO OUR COLLEGES WITH
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION GOALS.
AND SO ON PAGE THIRTEEN JUST TO
CLOSE -- WE THINK -- SP TWO
NINETY ONE US AUTHORED BY
SENATOR LLEVA IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO WE ARE VERY PROUD TO
FOLLOW IN HER LEADERSHIP.
ON THESE ISSUES ESSENTIALLY THE
BILL CREATES A NEW GRANT PROGRAM
THAT WE CONSIDER THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE.
SUBTRACT OUT WHAT WE EXPECT
STUDENTS ND FAMILIES TO PAY AS
WELL AS WHAT THE WHAT OTHER
RECEIVING AND CURRENT GRANTED.
AND THEN THAT DIFFERENCE THAT
UNMET NEED.
WOULD BE PROVIDED IN THE FORM OF
A NEW GRANT THAT WOULD PHASE IN
OVER SIX YEARS.
AND SO THE ASK OF THIS COMMITTEE
OBVIOUSLY -- MR SURE WE WOULD
LOVE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
BUT ALSO TO INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION.
IN THE BUDGET FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY TO SUPPORT THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT PER
DOES IT ELIMINATE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN ENTITLEMENT
GRANTS AND COMPETITIVE GRANTS
FOR PURPOSES OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OF FUNCTIONAL YES IT
DOESN'T ELIMINATE THE STATUTES
BUT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
STUDENT THE STUDENT WOULD NO.
LONGER IF THE STUDENT RECEIVED A
CAL GRANT THAT WOULD OFFSET THE
TOTAL COST IF IT DOESN'T WE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE BUT STILL
YOU'D HAVE YOUR LIMITED TO
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND COMPETITIVE
GRANTS SO IF YOU'RE NOT.
IF YOU'RE NOT.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
WITHIN A YEAR OF GRADUATING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND A LARGE PORTION
OF YOUR FOLKS OR NOT YEAH -- SO
THEY GET MORE UNDER THIS PROGRAM
THAT IS SO YES THEY RECEIVE A
COMPETITIVE RIO REGARDLESS SO
THIS PROGRAM IS TO SAY --
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY --
IT'S DIFFICULT TO UNWIND ALL OF
THESE DECISIONS WE'VE MADE
PREVIOUSLY.
BUT FOR THE FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE STUDENT FINANCIAL AID --
SHOULD BE AWARDED EQUITABLY IT
SHOULD BE THOSE DECISIONS SHOULD
BE BLIND TO THE STUDENT THEY
SHOULD SUBMIT A A FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATION WE CALCULATE THEIR
NEED WE LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING ALREADY AND THEN WE GIVE
THEM A AN AMOUNT TO GO -- TO
CLOSE THAT GAP [inaudible]
PERFECT.
LET ME ASK YOU.
SIR.
I'M GOOD.
IF I COULD HAVE SAID IT BETTER
THANK YOU.
I WILL USE THIS NET PRICE FLOOD
THAT PRICE FOR LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS IS THAT BECAUSE THE
COST OF LIVING IN PARTICULAR
AREAS.
AND THE AND THE LACK OF FOR
EXAMPLE DORMITORIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NO IT REALLY
IS AT THE POINT THERE IS THAT
THE TOTAL COST IS ACTUALLY
RELATIVELY SIMILAR ONCE YOU TAKE
AWAY THE TUITION -- THE
DIFFERENCES INTUITION ACROSS
SEGMENTS OF THE OTHER COSTS OF
ATTENDANCE -- FOOD HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION ARE RELATIVELY
SIMILAR CROSS SEGMENTS AND SO
STUDENTS FACE SIMILAR TOTAL COST
BUT THEY FACE THEY HAVE
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT AMOUNTS
OF FINANCIAL AID AVAILABLE TO
THEM.
WITH STUDENTS AT THE UC WRIST --
HAVING AVAILABLE THE MOST
FINANCIALLY.
AND SO WHEN YOU SUBTRACT OUT
THAT AID -- YOU FIND THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN MANY
PLACES IN MOST PLACES ARE THE
MOST EXPECT EXPENSIVE I SHOULD
BE VERY INTERESTING STATISTIC --
INTERESTING.
OKAY I DON'T THINK I HAVE -- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ON THIS.
ONE BUT LET ME CHECK.
NOPE I READ THEM ALL.
EXCELLENT PRESENTATIONS ARE
LIVING VIDEO.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S MOVE.
TO ISSUE NUMBER. FIVE BASIC
NEEDS AND MENTAL HEALTH THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM.
IT IS GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT OUR EFFORTS
AROUND FOOD PANTRIES AND
CALIBRATION ROMAN AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
MY NAME IS COLLEEN GALLEON I'M A
PROGRAM SPECIALIST WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I WORK ON
ALL THINGS BASIC NEEDS INCLUDING.
HOUSING AND FOOD -- MENTAL
HEALTH AND HEALTH SERVICES TO
STUDENTS I ALSO WORK ON FOSTER
CARE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO
HOMELESS STUDENTS -- AS YOU KNOW
WITH THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET PROVIDED TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO ESTABLISH THEMSELVES AS
HUNGER FOR CAMPUSES.
THE FUNDS WERE DISTRIBUTED
THROUGH STANDARD APPORTIONMENT
PROCESSES TO ALL HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN COLLEGES AND THAT WAS
BASED ON ENROLLMENT PER EACH OF
THE COLLEGES.
OF THE FUNDS WERE DESIGNATED TO
IDENTIFY STAFF PEOPLE ON CAMPUS
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS GETTING CROW
ENROLLED IN CAL FIRST BENEFITS
AND TO ESTABLISH OR EXPAND UPON.
A FOOD PANTRY SERVICES AT EACH
OF THE CAMPUSES.
OF THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ALSO PROVIDED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS HUNGER AND
BASIC NEEDS THESE FUNDS WERE
DISTRIBUTED ALSO THROUGH
APPORTIONMENT.
TODAY WE ARE PROVIDING A
PRELIMINARY REPORT OUR HUNGER
FOR CAMPUS REPORT YOU EACH HAVE
A COPY NOW -- WE CURRENTLY HAVE
A SURVEY OUT ACROSS OUR SYSTEM
TO A HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL DETAILS
ABOUT HOW MANY STIRRED STUDENTS
THEY'RE SERVING WITH FOOD PANTRY.
SERVICES AND WITH CAL FOR
GENERAL MEANT.
THOUGH TODAY WE CAN REPORT ON
SOME PRELIMINARY DATA THAT WE
HAVE A HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN OUT
OF OUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN COLLEGES.
THAT ARE OFFERING FOOD PANTRY
SERVICES AND OR REGULAR FOOD
DISTRIBUTION ON CAMPUS. SIXTY OF
THE COLLEGES HAVE PARTNERED WITH
THEIR CAL FRESH STAFF FROM THE
COUNTY TO HELP STUDENTS GET
ENROLLED IN COVERAGE. SEVENTY
THREE SEVENTY THREE OF THE
COLLEGES ARE ACTIVELY PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO STUDENTS ABOUT
HOW FRESH.
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
THIS IS PRELIMINARY DATA OVER
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN ASSISTED WITH HOW FRESH
APPLICATIONS AND WE HAVE. SIX
HUNDRED IDENTIFIED FACULTY AND
STAFF THAT ARE SUPPORTING
STUDENTS TO GET ENROLLED IN CAL
FRESH AND OTHER PUBLIC BENEFIT
PROGRAMS INCLUDING MEDICARE.
THIRTY OF THE COLLEGE'S REPORT
OPERATING BASIC NEEDS CENTERS ON
THE CAMPUSES.
WE ANTICIPATE THESE NUMBERS TO
INCREASE AS ADDITIONAL COLLEGES
RESPOND TO THE SURVEY AND HOPE
TO PROVIDE MORE DETAIL LATER
THIS YEAR.
OUR OFFICE RECENTLY PARTNERED AS
CHRISTIAN MENTIONED OUR OFFICE
PARTNERED WITH THE HOPE CENTER
TO CONDUCT THIS STUDENT SURVEY
AROUND BASIC NEEDS.
A 50% OF THE STUDENTS REPORTING
OF HUNGER IN THE PREVIOUS THIRTY
DAYS 60% REPORTING HOUSING IN
SECURITY AND 19% REPORTING.
HAVING EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
IN THE PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS.
THE REASONS THERE IS AN INCREASE
IN HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS AMONG
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
AGAIN CHRISTIAN IT'S ALREADY
ALLUDED TO THIS IS THAT.
THEY DON'T RECEIVE ENOUGH
FINANCIALLY TO COVER THE TRUE
COST OF ATTENDANCE -- AND THIS
IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WITH ZERO
EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION --
ACCESS TO PUBLIC BENEFITS IS
OFTEN COMPLICATED AND IT'S HARD
FOR STUDENTS TO NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM'S TO APPLY FOR AND
RECEIVE THE BENEFITS FOR WHICH
THEY'RE LIKELY ELIGIBLE.
AND THEN THE COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA IN A SPECIFICALLY
AROUND HOUSING HAS INCREASED
PRETTY DRAMATICALLY OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
LET ME ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THE
SURVEY I'M LOOKING AT OUR
ANALYSIS AND I'M NOT A NUMBERS
PERSON WHICH IS WHAT I ONCE WAS
A LAWYER BUT SO THE SURVEY. 50%
FOOD IN SECURE 60% HOUSING AND
SECURE. 19% HOMELESS AND THEN --
ANALYSIS INDICATES THE SURVEY
FOUND THAT 22% OF FOOD IN SECURE
STUDENTS RECEIVED [inaudible]
SNAP BENEFITS HELP FRESH SCENT
AND 8% WHO RECEIVED WHO
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
RECEIVED HOUSING -- ASSISTANCE
SO. 22% VERSUS 50% WHO REPORT
FOOD AND SECURITY AND 8% VERSUS
19% WHO [inaudible]
OF HOUSING AND SECURITY.
THERE IS A DELTA.
IF I'M READING IT RIGHT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO CLOSE WHAT
WHAT IT WHAT IT COUNTS FOR THE
DELTA AND WHY AREN'T MORE OF THE?
STUDENTS WHO.
REPORT FOOD AND SECURITY --
RECEIVING SAT BENEFITS IS THERE
A REASON WELL I THINK THAT THE
HOUSING ISSUE THE THIS SNAP ON
CASE OKAY HOW FRESH IS A
COMPLICATED BENEFIT TO ACCESS
AND IT'S BASED ON A NUMBER OF
VARIABLES.
HISTORICALLY STUDENTS TAKING SIX
OR MORE UNITS WERE.
ESSENTIALLY DEEMED IN ELIGIBLE
UNLESS THEY COULD VERIFY THAT
THEY WORKED TWENTY HOURS PER
WEEK ON AVERAGE EIGHTY HOURS PER
MONTH.
AND FOR MANY OF THE STUDENTS
THAT WAS CHALLENGING -- TO
PROVIDE THAT CUT THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION TO THE COUNTIES AM
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN A
BILL PASSED WHICH WAS.
NINETEEN THIRTY THAT ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
CREATE A LIST OF PROGRAMS.
THAT WOULD -- NEARER EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND GIVE
STUDENTS AN EXEMPTION. FOR THE
TWENTY HOUR WORK WORK ROLE --
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS CAME UP WITH A
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND PROGRAMS
AT FOUR YEAR SCHOOLS.
THAT WOULD EXEMPT STUDENTS FROM
HAVING TO WORK THIS TWENTY HOURS
OR EIGHTY HOURS PER MONTH --
IT'S OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE NEW PROVISIONS HAS BEEN
SLOW.
WHEN WAS IT?
IT WELL THE BILL TO CREATE A
WORK GROUP TO BEGIN WORKING ON
THE ISSUE -- PAST I BELIEVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN NOW THE
WORKGROUP DID THE WORK AND A AND
A VERY ROBUST WORK TO COME UP
WITH A VERY COMPREHENSIVE LIST
BUT IT WAS JUST WITHIN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF.
THAT THAT INFORMATION HAS BEEN
FORMALIZED AND DOCUMENTED AND
ROLLED OUT TO THE COUNTY SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS STUDENTS COME.
THEY FILL OUT THEIR APPLICATION
THEY GO TO THE COUNTY OR THE YOU
KNOW GET ON THE PHONE WITH THE
COUNTY FOR AN INTERVIEW.
AND IF ALL -- AND AND OBVIOUSLY
ELIGIBILITY IS COMPLICATED IT'S
IT'S MULTI VARIANT THERE'S MANY
MANY FACTORS THAT GO INTO
DETERMINING YOUR ELIGIBILITY FOR
CAL FRESH IT'S NOT JUST SIMPLY
WHETHER YOUR STUDENT AND YOU
MEET THE INCOME GUIDELINES RIGHT.
IT'S A FULL.
PROCESS THAT STUDENTS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH -- I THINK IT TAKES TIME
FOR CHANGES.
OF THIS MAGNITUDE TO REALLY --
COME FULL CIRCLE WITHTHE FRONT
LINE WE CAN WORK ON THAT.
THE YEAR AND A HALF LONG ENOUGH --
I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW WE MOVE
THIS THING ALONG I MEAN IT'S CAL
FRESHEN SNAPPER NOT WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE RIGHT I KNOW WHOSE
COMMITTEE THEY ARE.
I WOULD SAY JUST IN FAIRNESS TO
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
THEY'VE BEEN VERY VERY PROACTIVE
ABOUT WORKING WITH THE DIFFERENT
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA -- THEY'VE REALLY
ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TOWARDS
DEVELOPING STUDENT FRIENDLY
POLICIES THAT STAY WITHIN THE
GUIDELINES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE SNAP IS A
FEDERALLY GOVERNED PROGRAM.
IN TERMS OF ELIGIBILITY.
CURTIS AND AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT
EMPHASIZE THE DISTINCTION THERE
PROBABLY TWO BUCKETS OF ISSUES
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH ONE THAT
IS UP DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS USED TO
GET BENEFITS AND ARE IN NEED.
COLLEEN AND COLLEAGUES ARE
WORKING VERY HARD ON THAT THERE
ARE ALSO POLICY PRESUMPTIONS
THAT MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
STUDENTS. TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
BENEFITS AND AND THE WORK THAT
COLLINS MENTIONED WE HAVE MADE
PROGRESS THERE BUT THERE IS.
I THINK A A NEED TO THINK ABOUT
POLICIES IN THIS AEA TWO ABOUT
WHETHER WE HAVE HAD A THERE'S
BEEN A LONG STANDING ASSUMPTION
THAT IT WOULD BE -- STUDENTS IN
GENERAL IF YOU'RE TAKING MORE
THAN SIXTY UNITS WOULD NOT BE
ELIGIBLE AND LESS YOU MET OTHER
CRITERIA.
WELL I GUESS WHAT I'M ASKING IS
I MEAN I'D LIKE A LIST OF THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE FIXED I MEAN.
2028%.
MY MATH IS CORRECT CORRECT IS A
LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE OR NOT SO
YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHO ARE HUNGRY?
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST
INTOLERABLE. TO ME AND IF WE
NEED TO MAKE POLICY CHANGES --
WE NEED TO MAKE THOSE POLICY
CHANGES THAT WE CAN MAKE.
IF WE NEED.
TO INCREASE THE FUNDING TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM.
MOVING DOWN TO THE DISTRICTS.
TO FUN NAVIGATORS TO HELP US
STUDENTS NAVIGATE THIS PROCESS --
THEN I'D LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I THINK OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE DEAL WITH UP HERE --
INCLUDING ALL THOSE WHO WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT TODAY --
HUNGER IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA IS JUST NOT SOMETHING
THAT I'M WILLING TO TOLERATE SO.
AND I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
N. AS A BY THE WAY WITH THE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE WE HAVEN'T.
TALKED ABOUT THAT BUT I SUSPECT
THERE'S A SIMILAR SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT.
THAT CREATE THIS GAP BETWEEN
819% AND WE NEED TO FIX THAT.
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE
LINK BETWEEN THIS AND THE
PREVIOUS ITEM THAT BOTH FOOD AND
HOUSING OR ITEMS IN THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE THAT IS ADDRESSED BY
FAN FINANCIAL AID.
AS BETWEEN NINETY ONE WOULD
CLOSE THAT GAP AND SO WE VERY
FIRMLY BELIEVE THERE'S A LINK
BETWEEN THESE ISSUES AND THAT
STUDENTS.
ARE WE CAN.
HELP TO ADDRESS FOOD AND HOUSING
AND SECURITY BY EXPANDING
FINANCIAL AID FOR STUDENTS RIGHT.
AND I'M FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
USE OF THE GENERAL FUND FOR THAT
PURPOSE BUT THERE'S OTHER MONEY --
THAT I DO NOT INTEND TO LEAVE ON
THE TABLE JUST BECAUSE THE
BUREAUCRACY CAN'T MOVE FAST
ENOUGH -- MAYBE. TO GET IT TO
THE STUDENTS WHO NEEDED OR OR WE
NEED TO MAKE POLICY CHANGES TO
MAKE THOSE.
STUDENTS WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
FOOD AND HOUSING AND SECURITY.
OF QUALIFIED TO RECEIVE THOSE
BENEFITS.
THANK YOU I THINK THE NAVIGATION
PIECE ON PUBLIC BENEFIT AXIS IS
IS.
DEFINITELY WORTH RECOGNIZE OR
WILL WE WILL VISIT REVISIT THAT --
WHEN WE GET DOWN?
TO BREAST TAX AROUND HERE I
DIDN'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT YOU
MELLOW THAT'S FINE [inaudible]
NO APOLOGIES -- SO WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF FINANCIALLY REFORM
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF STUDENT
FRIENDLY POLICIES THANK YOU -- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ON THAT PARTICULAR
ITEM IN REGARD TO THE HOUSING
IT'S A SIMILAR SCENARIO WHERE
THE RULES THAT GOVERN HOUSING
AND HOMELESS RESOURCES -- THEY
ARE TRADITIONALLY FOCUSED ON
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONCISE ARE MORE --
OUR HOMELESS CHRONIC HOMELESS
PEOPLE STUDENTS AREN'T
NECESSARILY.
IDENTIFIED AS HOMELESS THE THE
THE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE COUCH
SURFING OR LISTENING OR SLEEPING
IN THEIR CAR OR SLEEPING IN
THEIR CAR.
SO WHAT WE KNOW WITHIN THE I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS HERE.
FIRST FLOOR OF PURE.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU DO AND WHAT
YOU.
WHICH CAN DO WHAT YOU DO DO AND
WHAT YOU CAN'T DO.
BUT IS SOMEBODY GOING TO SUGGEST
SOME CHANGES TO THIS PROCESS SO
WE CAN ADDRESS THESE ISSUES UP
HERE OR ARE YOU ALL GOING TO
RELY ON PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO MAY
NOT KNOW ENOUGH.
TO DESIGN A CHANGE WE DO HAVE
AND WE DO HAVE A WORK GROUP THAT
IS CALLED THE STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY WORKGROUP AND IT
CONSISTS OF A NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS PEOPLE FROM THE
FOOD BANK PEOPLE FROM ALL
SECTORS OF EDUCATION PEOPLE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
AND OUR SOLE CHARGE IS TO LOOK
AT POLICIES AND PRACTICES AROUND
HOW TO STUDENTS GET ON THE COW
FRESH AND POSSIBLY OTHER PUBLIC
BENEFITS -- AND SO I THINK THAT
GROUP WOULD BE THE BEST GROUP TO
TRY TO FORWARD SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS IF.
I LOOK FORWARD TO RECEIVING THEM.
WHETHER THEIR BUDGET RELATED OR
NOT IF THEY'RE NOT I'LL PASS
THEMON TO THE PEOPLE WHO DEAL
WITH THOSE ISSUES AND IF THEIR
BUDGET RELATED -- I KNOW WERE TO
TAKE THOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I HAVE ANOTHER ITEM ON NOT
TRIVIALIZE YOU TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT -- SO FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND INFORMATION
CURRENTLY ACROSS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM WE HAVE.
SEVENTY A BRICK AND MORTAR
HEALTH CENTERS -- MANY OF WHOM
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO STUDENTS -- SOME OF THE
COLLEGES HAVE STANDALONE
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES AND BASED
ON RESEARCH THAT WE CONDUCTED IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN PRIOR TO
THE DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS
BECAUSE WE DID RECEIVE.
TEN WE RECEIVED FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION IN THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET AND TEN MILLION
IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO STUDENTS --
BUT JUST AS A LITTLE BACKGROUND --
SOME OF THE COLLEGES HAVE
STANDALONE PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES ON CAMPUS -- BASED ON
RESEARCH THAT WE DID WE
IDENTIFIED NINETY OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT WERE
OFFERING SOME LEVEL OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO THEIR
STUDENTS -- IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
NINE I JUST MENTIONED WE GOT
FOUR AND A HALF MILLION -- THE
DELIVERABLES FOR THOSE FUNDS
INCLUDED PROVIDING DIRECT
SERVICES TO STUDENTS PROVIDING
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS WITH
TRAINING ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH.
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES FOR
STUDENTS AND TO ESTABLISH FORMAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY BASED.
A DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDERS --
FOR STUDENTS WHOSE -- MEANT
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS OF WENT
BEYOND WHAT THE COLLEGE WAS ABLE
TO PROVIDE IN TERMS OF
ASSISTANCE -- WE DID FOR THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN DOLLARS WE
DID A COMPETITIVE RFA PROCESS --
THESE FUNDS WERE MADE AWARE OF
THE AWARDS WERE MADE TO FIFTEEN
DISTRICTS ENCOMPASSING TWENTY
SEVEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THIS IS FOR THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN FUNDS -- THE GRANTS
RANGED FROM 200-500-0023 HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND THE
COLLEGES WERE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
MATCH -- TO RECEIVE THESE GRANTS.
A WE DID HAVE A FEW
ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS IN GETTING
THE CONTRACTS IN PLACE THOUGH
CURRENTLY ALL TWENTY SEVEN OF
THOSE PARTICIPATING COLLEGES.
ARE WELL INTO OPERATIONAL ICING
THEIR FUNDS.
AND FOR THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FUNDS WE DISTRIBUTED THOSE TWO
ALL HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THROUGH OUR
PORTION IT PROCESS AND THOSE
FUNDS WERE ALSO -- FOR THE SAME
PURPOSES TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES TO STUDENTS. TO PROVIDE
TRAINING TO FACULTY STAFF AND
STUDENTS AND TO CREATE FORMAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SO -- I WOULD
SAY ALL THE COLLEGES HAVE
PROTOCOL -- REGARDING CRISIS
INTERVENTION FOR STUDENTS
PRESENTING WITH IMMEDIATE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
OF THE MAJORITY OF THE COLLEGES
HAVE ESTABLISHED TEAMS ON CAMPUS
TO ADDRESS STUDENTS IN NEED --
THEY'RE CALLED BEHAVIORAL
INTERVENTION TEAMS ARE CRISIS
INTERVENTION TEAMS -- THEN I'M
NOT SURE A WAIT AND SEE IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS I HAVE ANSWERS TO
WHAT I THINK MIGHT BE QUESTIONS
BUT I REALIZE THAT EACH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS A
STANDALONE AND DISTURBED AS A
STANDALONE ENTITY S. HERE.
THE THE THE COLLEGES MAKE HEALTH
INSURANCE AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO SOME OF THEM
ALL OF THEM NONE OF THEM.
IT COVERS MENTAL HEALTH BUT HAS
NO HEALTH COMPONENT TO IT THE
COLLEGES DO NOT OFFER INSURANCE
THE THE THERE'S A THEY DO WORK
WITH VENDORS WHO CAN PROVIDE
INSURANCE AND BUT THAT'S
PRIMARILY TARGETING
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE.
AS PART OF THEIR ENROLLMENT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
I THINK THE SCHOOLS -- DO WORK
WITH THE STUDENTS TO HELP THEM
GET ENROLLED IN A CGA AND MEDIC
COW.
BUT WE DON'T MAN DATE THAT --
THAT THEY HAVE INSURANCE I MEAN
THE GOVERNMENT MANDATES THAT
THEY HAVE INSURANCE BUT THE
SCHOOLS DON'T.
AND I REALIZE IT'S DIFFICULT
BECAUSE OF THE ARCHITECTURE OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS
INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS AND THIS AND
THAT BUT IS THERE ANY
CENTRALIZED COLLECTION OF DATA
THAT THE ENABLES THE SYSTEM
OFFICE FOR EXAMPLE TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THE PROVISION.
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES -- THE
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS ON CAMPUS
THE WAIT TIMES -- AND ALL THE
REST OF THAT THAT WE TAKE A LOOK
AT AND YOU SEE IN THE C. ISSUES
SEE ISSUE SYSTEM.
THE THE THE THE THE DATA
INDICATES THAT THERE IS A THERE
ARE PROGRAMS IN PLACE THAT ARE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF YOUR
STUDENTS HOW HOW DO WE DO THAT --
FOR QUESTION -- IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION I WOULD SAY WE ARE NOT
DOING IT SYSTEMATICALLY TODAY WE
HAVE FOLKS -- YOU KNOW WHO IT
AND WE HAVE A REGULAR
EXPENDITURE REPORTING SO IN MANY
WAYS WE WOULD KNOW THE TYPES OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING PUT ON
DIFFERENT PARTS OF CAMPUSES.
WE KNOW THE TYPES OF EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE SPREAD ACROSS CAMPUSES.
WE HAPPENED HISTORICALLY DONE
THE ANALYSIS.
TO OB. TO LINK THAT TO STUDENT.
TO STUDENT OUTCOMES THAT ARE OF
INTEREST TO US OR AT LEAST
STUDENT.
EXPERIENCES THAT ARE INTEREST OF
INTEREST TO US AND WE PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE THE DATA ON A
SYSTEMATIC BASIS.
OVER A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AT A
AT A LEVEL THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO DO THAT IN WAYS THAT WOULD BE
INFORMATIVE TO POLICY MAKERS --
HERE THINK IT IS.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH VARIOUS
FUNDING SOURCES WE'VE ASKED FOR
DATA -- BUT I THINK THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO A CAN OF
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
ABOUT ABOUT HOW WE DO IT HOW
WHAT WHAT DATA SHOULD WE BE
COLLECTING.
MORE SYSTEMATICALLY TO GIVE US
THE TYPES OF INSECTS THAT WOULD
INFORM YOUR YOUR WORK MEANS SO
IF IF FOR EXAMPLE IF THE IF WE
WERE TO ASK DO YOU THINK THAT
GIVEN THE THE INVESTMENT THAT
THE STATE MAKES IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THAT.
WE'RE DOING ENOUGH TO ADDRESS
THE MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS AND
ISSUES OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS.
AS A QUESTION AND THE ANSWER
WOULD BE I THINK WE HAVE LOTS OF
EVIDENCE THAT -- OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE FACING
ISSUES RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH
I DON'T THINK WE BUT I I I DEALT
TO THE QUESTION OF ARE WE DOING
ENOUGH I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE --
A GOOD SENSE -- OVER LONG
PERIODS OF TIME -- OUTSIDE OF
THE DATA THAT COLLEEN COLLECTS
AND AND I WE'VE SHARED -- ABOUT --
WHAT TRENDS LOOK LIKE WHAT
SPECIFICALLY?
VARIES ACROSS COLLEGES I'M SO I
THINK IT TODAY.
WE ARE TRYING TO YOU KNOW WE TRY
TO MAKE DO WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE BUT CERTAINLY -- I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE
SYSTEMATIC ANSWERS FOR THOSE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE EXTREME AND DO WE KNOW
SUICIDE RATES.
WE DO NOT.
SO ONE OF MY CONCERNS IS MEAN
THAT THERE'S A HIGH DEGREE OF
STRESS IN EDUCATION AT ALL
LEVELS FROM.
I GUESS ALMOST PRE.
TO THE END OF THE LINE ON IT AT
HIGHER EDUCATION -- WE'RE IN IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SETTING IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE AND I'M INCLUDING
THE LEGISLATURE IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
WE ARE SORT OF ALLOWING OR
FORCING -- STUDENTS AND STUDENT
GROUPS. TO INTERACT WITH LOCALLY
ELECTED BOARDS TO TRY TO GET
LOCALLY ELECTED BOARDS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
COLLECT DATA RESPONDED DATA.
INPUT PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND
SERVE A PIECEMEAL BASIS AROUND
THE STATE AND AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THE ARCHITECTURE OF
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH BUT PERHAPS WE OUGHT TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION UP HERE.
ABOUT A MORE REGULARIZED
APPROACH.
TO MENTAL HEALTH AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND OBVIOUSLY
THAT.
AS WITH EVERYTHING ELSE INCLUDES
MONEY BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES
HAVING SOME SORT OF DATA SYSTEMS
SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHO'S DOING
WHAT WHERE.
WE'RE DEFICIENCIES OCCUR ARE ARE
OCCURRING AND HOW WE DIRECT
MONEY -- TO THOSE AREAS TO THOSE
DISTRICTS TO THOSE REGIONS THAT
HAVE.
NEEDS THAT ARE BEING MET AND
IT'S SORT OF HARD TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FOR OR
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEMS
ARE AND THAT'S NOT YOUR FAULT WE
PROBABLY HAVEN'T FUNDED YOU. TO
TO DO THAT I'D LIKE TO TALK TO
THE SYSTEM AND THE CHANCELLOR
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN
ORDER TO GET A BETTER HANDLE.
ON A MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR OWNER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
AND WHAT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IF
ANY WE NEED TO DIRECT DOWN THERE.
TO ADDRESS THOSE WERE DOING IT
WAS THE ISSUE WERE DOING THE UC
MEDICALLY DIFFERENT SYSTEMS.
DIFFERENT ARCHITECTURE EASIER TO
GET DATA.
BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS AND I THINK WORKING
WITH -- WITH THOSE DISTRICTS UP
FOR US WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ALSO TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT CONVERSATION IS
LOCALLY WHAT THE PRESSURES --
DISTRICTS ARE FACING AND AND HOW
DO WE MAKE THIS A PRIORITY FOR
DISTRICTS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
ADDRESS -- AT THE LOCAL LEVELS
RIGHT.
THERE'S A FEW ITEMS THAT I JUST
WANT TO SHARE AND I DON'T HAVE
THAT IN FRONT OF ME BUT WE DO
HAVE SOME STATISTICS FROM RAND --
WHO DID A STUDY OF OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT HEALTH PROGRAM WHICH WAS
FUNDED THROUGH THE MEDICAL
SERVICE ACT PROP SIXTY THREE
DOLLARS?
SO WE CAN PROVIDE SOME DATA IT'S
NOT SYSTEM MY DATA.
BUT IT DOES REFLECT I'M PRETTY
HIGH RATES OF ANXIETY AND
DEPRESSION THAT ARE IMPEDING THE
STUDENTS ACADEMICALLY SO THAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL -- I WOULD SAY
ALSO COULD PROVIDE THAT DECIDE
WHERE WOULD I GO TO REVIEWING --
AND SOMETHING ELSE I THINK IT'S
WORTH NOTING THAT THERE IS AN
ASSEMBLY BILL RIGHT NOW 1-689-
WHICH WOULD ALLOW FOR THE USE OF
PROPS SIXTY THREE FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY FOR ALL -- THREE
SEGMENTS OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND
SO PREVIOUSLY YOU KNOW BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN WE DID HAVE
GRANT MAKING PROCESS USING PROPS
SIXTY THREE DOLLARS SPECIFICALLY
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS --
I JUST THINK IT'S IT'S THE
IMPORTANT.
THING TO LOOK AT THAT ARE AN HSA
FUNDS ARE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT FUNDS -- DOING THEIR SHARE --
TO SUPPORT CAN BE COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN GENERAL AND SO WE
HAVEN'T HAD THAT FUNDING FOR
MANY MANY YEARS AND SO IT'S
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTY
NINE WELL OF COURSE BUT BUT THE
I THINK.
MONEY IS A GOOD THING RIGHT AND
THAT'S GOOD BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE THE PROCESS IN THE
ARCHITECTURE IN PLACE.
TO ASSESS WHERE THE MONEY'S
GOING MAKE SURE IT'S GOING TO
THE RIGHT PLACE.
GATHER SOME DATA ON HOW IT'S
BEING UTILIZED AND THEN MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS. TO ENSURE THAT THE
THE MONEY'S BEING DIRECTED TO
THE PROBLEM AREAS THAT'S ONE OF
THE ISSUES WE HAVE WITH PROP
SIXTY THREE RIGHT NOW.
IN ALLOCATION TO COUNTIES.
SOME SPEND IT SOME DON'T SOME
HAVE NINE HUNDRED MILLION IN
RESERVE SOME OF A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX MILLION IN RESERVE.
SO THAT'S THE SITUATION THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO REPLICATE.
IN IN HIGHER EDUCATION WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE MONEY GOES
DOWN AND FIXES PROBLEMS AND YEAH
AND AND THIS IS NOT COMING FROM
A PERSPECTIVE OF OF DATA AND
RESEARCH IT IS COMING FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF HAVING WORKED
WITH THE HEALTH OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ACROSS.
THE FIELD THERE IS A NEED WELL
FIRST PLACES TO GET THE MONEY
THE THE AUTHORITY TO USE THE
MONEY.
BUT THEN WE NEED TO WORK WITH
YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S A
PROCESS IN PLACE.
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE IT NEEDS TO
GO WHAT IT NEEDS TO DO AND THEN
ASSESS THE RESULTS -- ONCE WE
SET THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
EXCELLENT.
WE'VE GOT SOME REPORTS DO THAT I
THINK YOU'RE NOT.
DO NOT IN YET SO YES WE HAVE --
WE HAVE A SERVICE OUT TO THE
COLLEGES FOR BOTH THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
MENTAL HEALTH FUNING.
AND WE'RE PROPOSING TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO YOU IN JULY JULY FIRST.
LOOK FORWARD -- TO TO REVIEWING
IT THANK YOU.
ANYTHING FURTHER.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX IS THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
. ONE
NEW FACE.
SERVE YOUR DATA FOR YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD PLEASE SOLELY HI
SENATOR ROUGH THAT MATTHEW
ROBERTS SIGNED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE WORKING ON STRONG
WORK FORCE IN K. TWELVE STRONG
WORK FORCE THANK YOU THE JUDGE
OR THE JOIN YOU DOWN IN
RIVERSIDE EARLIER THIS YEAR FOR
YOUR HEARING.
SO YOU HEARD ALL MY QUESTIONS
ARE ANY.
OKAY IT WAS THE START.
BE THINKING WITH LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT
THE SECTIONS ARE JUST
DISTRIBUTED.
I THINK I RECALL THIS FROM WORK
FIRST PROGRAM GREW OUT OF A TASK
FORCE THAT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS
COMMISSIONED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THIS TASK FORCE
MADE A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
ABOUT STRENGTHENING CT ACROSS
THE STATE INCLUDING
RECOMMENDATION TO INCREASE LINE
AND WITH REGIONAL WORK FOR SMITH.
THE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
CREATED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WITH THE GOAL OF
EXPANDING THE AVAILABILITY AND
QUALITY OF C. T. PROGRAMS AND
IMPROVING THAT REGIONAL LINES.
CURRENTLY THE STATE PROVIDES TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
ON GOING FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PORTION OF THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
NOTABLY THIS FUNDING IS MEANT TO
SUPPLEMENT THE APPORTIONMENT
FUNDING THAT THE STATE ALSO
PROVIDES IS GENERAL PURPOSE
FUNDS FOR CITY AND OTHER
INSTRUCTION.
THE INTENT HERE IS TO PROVIDE
SOME SUPPLEMENTAL RESOURCES FOR
HIGHER INSTRUCTIONAL COSTS THAT
SOMETIMES COME WITH CTE COURSES.
AND ALSO TO SUPPORT THE REGIONAL
PLANNING AND COORDINATION
REQUIRED UNDER THIS PROGRAM.
ON THE SECOND PAGE OF OUR HAND
OUT WE OUTLINED IN BRIEF WITHOUT
REGIONAL PLANNING COORDINATION
CONSISTS OF ACROSS THE STATE
THERE ARE EIGHT REGIONAL
CONSORTIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THESE COLLEGES IN THEIR
CONSORTIA REQUIRED TO COOPERATE
WITH VARIOUS REGIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES AND
INDUSTRY LEADERS. TO IDENTIFY
REGIONAL NEEDS AND DEVELOP FOR
YOUR PLANS.
THE CONSORTIUM ALSO REQUIRED HIS
LABOR MARKET DATA TIED ON A FIVE
PRIORITY INDUSTRY SECTORS WITHIN
THE REGION.
ON WHICH TO CONCENTRATE THEIR
SPENDING.
STATE FUNDING FOR THE RECENT
RESULTS FOR SURE.
IS ALLOCATED ACCORDING TO A
FORMULA THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
ENROLLMENT WITHIN THE REGIONS AS
WELL AS THE ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
WITHIN THE REGIONS.
AND THAT'S A TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THERE'S ALSO
PERFORMANCE COMPONENT OF THAT
FUNDING FORMULA.
FINALLY THE BOTTOM FOR HAND OUT
WE BRIEFLY EXPLAIN WHAT HAPPENS
THE FUNDS ONCE THEY REACH THE
CONSORTIA. 60% OF THE FUNDS ARE
DIRECTLY ALLOCATED TO THE
DISTRICTS.
WHERE IS THE OTHER 40% ARE GIVEN
TO THE CONSORTIUM WHICH HAVE
DISCRETION TO SPEND THEM ON
INDUSTRY PRIORITIES?
THANK YOU I'D BE HAPPY TO
QUESTION [inaudible]
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NOW.
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FIND. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM FOR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH
IS THE SAME LEVEL OF FUNDING AS
FOR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
MADE A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO
SWAP SOME OF THE ALLOCATION FOR
RE APPROPRIATED AND SETTLE UP
FUNDS TO REFLECT AVAILABLE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL.
FUND.
AT THE TIME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
WE WILL BE MONITORING REVENUES
IN THE LEVEL OF MINIMUM CARE AND
AND THE LEVEL OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AS WE APPROACH THE MAY
REVISION.
BUT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INTENDS TO CONTINUE TO FUND THE
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM AT ITS
CURRENT LEVEL.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS.
MORNING AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON
SORRY -- MATTHEW ROBERTS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO OPERATE FROM
PAGE THIRTY TWO BEGINNING ON
PAGE THIRTY TWO OF YOUR HAND.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
ALREADY IT'S BEEN PRESENTED
TODAY THE STRUCTURE OF THE
STRONG WORK PROGRAM -- AS IT
ROLLED OUT IN NINETEEN SIXTEEN
PART SORRY. EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
IT WAS WHEN I WAS BORED.
SORRY NINETEEN SIXTEEN YELLING
THE EXACTLY EXACTLY EXACTLY
200-016-2000 SEVENTEEN SO WE'RE
IN OUR THIRD YEAR OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM --
AS WAS EXPLAINED 60% OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION --
GOES OUT -- TO THE DISTRICTS
DIRECTLY TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS TO CREATE MORE AND
BETTER SEE TV PROGRAMS.
A 40% OF THOSE DOLLARS OF THE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT MILLION
TRICKLE DIRECTLY INTO OUR REGION.
TO TAKE CARE OF REGIONAL NEEDS
AND REGIONAL PRIORITIES THAT ARE
DRIVEN BY THE ECONOMICS OF THAT
PARTICULAR AREA -- AND SO WE'RE
HAPPY WITH.
ROLLING INTO THE THIRD YEAR.
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE GAINS THAT WE'VE HAD.
IN TERMS OF OUTCOME SO I WANT TO
GO OVER THOSE IN JUST A COUPLE
OF MINUTES.
I THINK THE WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THOUGH IS IS REALLY
DESIGNED TO REDUCE A LOT OF THE
DUPLICATION THAT'S CURRENTLY
EXISTING WITHIN OUR SYSTEMS. TO
CROSS OVER TO ENSURE THE DOLLARS
ARE ARE BEING USED IN BRAIDED
LEVERAGE IN SUCH A WAY THAT
REALLY MOVES STUDENTS FOR THE
BEST IN THE BEST WAY TO THAT
CAREER -- A GOAL -- AND
CERTAINLY WHAT'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT TODAY IN TERMS OF THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS RIGHT IN TERMS
OF ATTAINING A LIVING WAGE.
IN TERMS OF INSURING THAT
STUDENTS ARE ARE MOVING THROUGH
SO WE'VE IDENTIFIED CERTAIN
TYPES OF STUDENTS THAT THAT --
ARE THE RECIPIENTS OF THESE
DOLLARS AND IT'S IMPORTANT I
THINK TO NOTE THAT IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. 78% OF
CALIFORNIA'S ASSOCIATES DEGREE --
HALF OF WHICH WERE IN PROGRAMS
THAT WERE DESIGNED FOR C. T. E.
OR SOME SORT OF A C. T..
AND THE NUMBERS -- IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF COURSES THAT ARE
OFFERED THE NUMBER OF FACULTY
THAT ARE ENGAGED IN CTE COURSES
IS HIGH AS WELL -- AND SO WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT STUDENTS THAT
ARE COMPLETING IN OTHER WORDS
LOOKING AT OUR STUDENTS
ATTAINING THAT LIVABLE WAGE.
ARE THEY TO ACHIEVING A
CERTIFICATE OF SOME SORT THAT'S
OF VALUE -- TO INDUSTRY IN
BUSINESS OR ARE THEY STARTED
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT LEVEL OF
THEIR CAREER.
WE KNOW FULL WELL THAT STUDENTS
ARE NOT GONNA HAVE THE SAME
CAREER THEIR ENTIRE LIFE AND SO.
IT'S THE IMPORTANCE OF US
CREATING PROGRAMS THAT SORT OF
STACK.
THAT'S SORT OF A CREATE THAT
PIPELINE -- TO MOVE THINGS
FORWARD AND SO -- A LOT OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING WE'RE LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW OR THE SHORT TERM A C.
T. E. CERTIFICATES AND HOW DO WE
MOVE OUR OUR STUDENTS THAT MAYBE
COME BACK.
IN FOR ONE OR TWO COURSES -- TO
SORT OF UP SKILL OR TO GET A
RAISE OR TO TO MOVE FORWARD --
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE
STUDENTS AS WELL.
THEY ALSO LOOK AT THE THE LEVEL
OF ONBOARDING OFF BOARDING THAT
OTHER PROGRAMS PROVIDE SUCH AS
THROUGH GUIDED PATHWAYS.
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAMS THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS WE PRESENT SOME
DATA TO YOU IN TERMS OF OUTCOMES
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THIS IS.
THIS IS REALLY WHAT THE PROGRAM
IS PREDICATED ON RIGHT IS CAN WE
ACHIEVE THE TYPES OF STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND PROGRAM OUTCOMES TO
REALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE -- SERVER.
PRESENT SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN MOVING
FORWARD ONCE THAT FOR THE FUNDS
WERE IMPLEMENTED.
THE NUMBER OF F. T. S. OR
STUDENTS A FULL TIME STUDENT
EQUIVALENT IN THE SYSTEM
INCREASED. FOR C. T..
BY ABOUT FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN JUST ONE YEAR AND SO
WE ARE SEEING SORT OF AN UP TICK.
IN THIS IS JUXTAPOZ WE THINK
WITH A LARGER DECLINE SYSTEM
WIDE -- BOTH ON THE K. TWELVE
AND THE THE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SIDE -- SO WE'RE HAPPY
TO SEE SORT OF THAT UP TAKE
MAKING STUDENTS.
MAKE SURE STEVE'S CONNECT TO
THEIR PROGRAMS.
ANOTHER ONE THAT -- PRESENT TO
YOU IS EARNING CERTIFICATES OVER
TIME THAT'S ANOTHER METRIC THAT
HIS INCREASED.
WE WENT IN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FROM.
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES
TO ABOUT SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES IN ONE YEAR SO
WE'RE DEFINITELY SAYING THE THE
UPTICK IN TERMS OF THE WHAT ARE
THEIR THEIR CREDENTIALS ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT A STUDENT WILL
NEED TO START AGAIN THAT
EMPLOYMENT AND MOVE.
FORWARD LET ME GO FORWARD HERE --
LOOKING AT MEDIAN ANNUAL
EARNINGS OF SHORT TERM CAREER
EDUCATION STUDENTS AGAIN
415-162-1617 WHEN IT WAS
IMPLEMENTED.
THE THE MEDIAN ANNUAL INCOME
WENT UP FROM THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND TO FORTY TWO THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED SO THAT WAS A
DEFINITE SIGNIFICANT INCREASE.
WE'RE LOOKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT HAPPENS -- THE THE NOTION
OF MAKING THIS PROGRAM
TRANSPARENT ENOUGH TO WHERE WE
ARE GATHERING THE INPUT FROM
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE JOBS ARE SORT OF
ADDED.
ESPECIALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO MOVE STUDENTS INTO INTO
WHERE WE WANT THEM TO BE --
ANOTHER ONE FOR MEDIA AND CHANGE
AND SHORT TERM CAREER EDUCATION
EARNINGS.
IT WENT UP FROM. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
TO SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN FROM 51%
253% SO AGAIN ALL POSITIVE.
SORT OF ATTRIBUTES COMING
FORWARD IN THE PROGRAM.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT WHEN WE WHEN
WE PULL THE REGION.
AND WE PULL THE COLLEGES AND HOW
THINGS ARE GOING -- THE BIGGEST
IMPACT IS THE AMOUNT OF
ATTENTION THAT C. T. E. AND WORK
FORCES SORT OF RECEIVING AND AND
AND BY THAT.
IT'S IT'S SORT OF MOVING THE
NEEDLE IT'S HELPING US TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE -- TO SORT OF ON
BOARD WITH OUR OTHER PROGRAMS
SUCH AS GUIDED PATHWAYS -- SEE
WHAT ELSE CAN I SAY ASK A
QUESTION YEAH SURE GO FOR
BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
THE EDUCATION PIECE OBVIOUSLY IS
WORKING I MEAN YOU'RE.
CALCULATING THE NUMBER OF
DEGREES AND CERTIFICATES AT YOU
KNOW YOU PRODUCE SURE SOMEHOW
ABLE TO ME AT LEAST ON SOME
GENERAL LEVEL.
CONNECT -- THOSE WITH WHAT --
INCOME IS DOING IN TERMS FOR THE
IN TERMS OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOVING THROUGH BUT RIGHT.
YOU FOR MY QUESTIONS BEFORE AND
YOU PROBABLY HEARD THEM IN
RIVERSIDE.
WHAT I DON'T [inaudible]
QUITE UNDERSTAND.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT THIS PEACE
WORKS AS WELL IS THE DEMAND SIDE
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS IT SAYS THE IN INLAND
EMPIRE DESERT OF REGIONS OF THE
STATE THE PROPERTY IN EMERGING
SECTORS ARE.
ADVANCED TRANSPORTATION AND
LOGISTICS OKAY I GET THAT.
AND SOMEWHERE ELSE I'LL PROBABLY
FIND THAT THERE.
TWENTY THOUSAND PROJECTED TO BE
TWENTY THOUSAND JOBS IN THAT IN
THAT SECTOR OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
AND SO I SAY WELL WHAT DOES THAT
REALLY MEAN WHAT HOW WOULD YOU
DESIGN A TRAINING PROGRAM. TO
NEXT NECESSARILY TRAINED JOE FOR
A JOB IN ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION
AND LOGISTICS IF YOU DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT THE JOB IS YOU
KNOW REALLY KNOW WHAT THE SKILL
SET IS.
WAY FOR TALKING ABOUT C. T.
RIGHT AND SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THERE NEEDS TO BE A MUCH MORE
ORGANIZED APPROACH TO THIS
WHETHER WE RELY ON THE ONLINE.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOLKS TO SET
UP THE ARCHITECTURE AND THEN
LETTING IT LATER AND ON ALL THE
REST OF US.
AROUND THE STATE OR DO IT SOME
OTHER WAY BUT SOMEBODY SOME
ENTITY NEEDS TO BE THE POINT OF
CONTACT WITH EMPLOYERS.
IN IN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE OR THE CENTRAL VALLEY SO
IF I'M -- UTC OR WHATEVER
THEY'RE CALLED THE DAILY -- ROAR
INDUSTRIES AND I'M MAKING ENGINE
THIS SELLS FOR BOEING SEVEN
TRIPLE SEVENS AND SEVEN THIRTY
SEVENS AND I NEED A CERTAIN.
HONEY COMB -- AUTOCLAVE OPERATOR
THAT NEEDS THESE SORT OF SKILLS
I CAN PICK UP THE PHONE AND I
KNOW TO CALL.
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
IN RIVERSIDE SAN BENITO COUNTY
AND SAY I NEED TEN OF THESE
PEOPLE.
AND THEY THEN THE BOARD THEN
TURNS TO THE CONSORTIUM DOWN
THERE AND SAYS I NEED WE NEED
TEN OF THESE.
PEOPLE TODAY AND WE'RE PROBABLY-GOING TO NEED A HUNDRED OF THEM
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
AND THESE ARE THE SKILL SETS.
FIGURE THIS OUT AND TELL ME WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO HELP BUT AN
INDUSTRY TO INDUSTRY.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE IT MAKES
PERFECT SENSE AND IT'S YOU'RE
DESCRIBING A MODEL FOR WHICH WE
DO UTILIZE AN IMPLEMENT UNDER EW
DE IT.
THE WD PROGRAM AND THAT'S THE
SECTOR EXPERTS THAT WE DO PUT
OUT INTO THE FIELD.
THEIR JOB IS TO IS TO RESPOND
QUICKLY TO THE NEEDS OF INDUSTRY
THE SAY A PARTNER COMES TO THEM
AND OR TO A COLLEGE AND SAYS.
WE NEED X. NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO
DO THIS FOR WE NEED THIS DONE.
THAT POSITION IS DESIGNED TO
SORT OF MAKE THAT CONNECTION SO
THEY'RE THE INDUSTRY PARTNER
EXPERT.
THAT'S DESIGNED TO TO SORT OF
INTERFACE WITH THAT WHAT MUST BE
A MARKETING PROBLEM AND BECAUSE
YOU KNOW YOU MAY RECALL WHEN I
WAS IN WHEN WE WERE ALL IN
RIVERSIDE AND I ASKED THE I WILL.
CALL F THE ENTITY BUT I ASK AN
ENTITY THAT WAS ON THE IN THE
HOT SEAT.
ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS IF I'M AN
EMPLOYER AND I NEED TO GO TO
TALK TO SOMEBODY TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT I HAVE A PARTICULAR NEED
FOR A HUNDRED ACTS WHATEVER AXES
RIGHT.
WHO WOULD I GO TO AND THESE
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD KNOW IS THAT I
DON'T KNOW?
THAT NOW THAT YEAH.
IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM AND THAT'S
NOT A PROBLEM THAT THE EDUCATION
PIECE HAS.
THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
OVER HERE AND WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE OVER HERE BECAUSE IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU PRETTY MUCH HAVE
YOUR STUFF TOGETHER.
BRIDGING THE DIVIDE YEAH IT'S
ABOUT HOW DO YOU SORT OF MAKE
THAT CONNECTION YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT AND HOW TO UTILIZE DATA
OTHER THAN THE LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION ON SUPPLY AND DEMAND
BECAUSE IT'S GENERAL IT'S JUST
IT'S BACKWARDS FACING YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT -- YOU DO YOU NEED
THE EMPLOYER ENGAGED AND THAT'S
THAT'S THE WITH SOME OF THE
ADVISORIES I THINK SO BUT BUT
BUT THE EMPLOYER BUT THE ITSELF
BY SAY MARKETING PERHAPS THAT'S
NOT THE RIGHT TERM [inaudible]
INFORMATION DISSEMINATION BUT
THE EMPLOYER COMPLETE COMMUNITY
UP AND DOWN THE STATE NEEDS TO
KNOW.
AND THAT'S WHY IT ALMOST HAS TO
BE THE SAME ENTITY -- ON A
REGIONAL BASIS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
NEEDS TO KNOW THAT IF I HAVE A
NEED.
I'M GONNA GO HERE RIGHT AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE
INVENTORY REPOSITORY REPOSITORY
OF JOBS AND JOB SKILL
INFORMATION.
THAT THEN THE CONSORTIA CAN TURN
TO TO DESIGN TRAINING PROGRAMS
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS.
SO I I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN IF I'M RIGHT.
I'M NOT IN MY HEAD SO YES.
GOOD CHRISTIAN GREY COMPLETELY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I KNOW THANK YOU.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE.
IF THAT WAS THE QUESTION I DON'T
KNOW THAT I HAVE ANY ANY MORE OF
THEM AND IF IT WAS A STATEMENT I
DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY MORE OF
THEM THOSE EITHER SO YOU KNOW
WHERE TO REACH US IF YOU HAVE
OTHER QUESTIONS.
I GUESS I SHOULD ASK WHAT WHAT
DO YOU THINK THE FOR THE GRIP IS
THIS ON PAGE THIRTY SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS.
IN THIS TO SOME EXTENT THE
THIRTY SEVEN C. D. E. F. T. E.'S.
JUST TAKE IN THE NAME PER DESERT
WHAT WHY IS THERE A DECREASE.
THAT MAKES SENSE THE QUESTION.
ITHINK I WOULD JUST MAYBE OF
MAKE IT MORE GENERAL STATEMENT
THAT -- AS WE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE FIRST PANEL ENROLLMENT
GROWTH HAS BEEN SLOW -- IN ME --
STATEWIDE IN SUMMARY -- AND
REGIONS IS DECREASING YOU SEE
DECLINES IN K. TWELVE ENROLLMENT
YOU SEE A WE SEE A TREND WHEN
LABOR MARKETS ARE ARE BETTER
STUDENTS ARE LESS LIKELY TO
ENROLL IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO I YOU KNOW I THINK WE WOULD
ARGUE IN PART IT IS.
A REFLECTIVE OF AN OVERALL TREND
AS A DEAN ROBERTS NOTED -- YOU
KNOW MMHM MOST OF OUR FTS MY
MUCH OF OUR FTS IS IN C. T.
ANYWAY AND SO I THINK THAT'S I I
THINK WE'VE -- YOU KNOW AND
LOOKING INTO IT -- ONE OF OUR
INITIAL THOUGHTS IS THAT IT'S
JUST REFLECTIVE OF THESE
DEMOGRAPHICS OKAY.
WELL AGAIN I APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION GREAT WORK KEEP IT
UP I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT OTHER LITTLE
PIECE THAT I MENTIONED WOULD
LOVE IT THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT ITEM SIXTY ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT SEVENTY
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ISSUE SEVEN IS K. TWELVE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS --
MY WATCH JUST TELL ME THAT WE'RE
ALMOST THERE SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
LET'S -- ADDENDA FIRES CELLS FOR
THE RECORD STARTING TO MY LEFT.
AMBER ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
LENA GRANT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
BRIAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
MATTHEW ROBERTS FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
OKAY [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
MICHELLE MACINTOSH HEALTH FOR
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS BACK
BECAUSE THANK YOU WHO WANTS --
TO IT WAS THE START.
I'LL START -- SO OUR OFFICE
PROCESS SAID PROVIDE JUST A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF HIGH SCHOOL CT.
I'M GONNA BE SPEAKING FROM A
HANDOUT THEYPUT THE SERGEANT
JUST.
DISTRIBUTED -- ON THE FIRST PAGE
OF THIS HANDOUT JUST A REMINDER
THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION IS
ORGANIZED -- ALL INDUSTRIES IN
THE STATE AND THE FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT SECTORS AND FOR EACH
OF THESE SECTORS THEY'VE
DEVELOPED THE SPECIFIC.
I'M SORRY YEAH THIS IS.
THAT'S THE ONE YOUR YOU KNOW I
GO TO THE PICTURES HEY IF.
YOU EMAIL ACCOUNT WHATEVER HELPS
YOU.
AND FOR EACH OF THESE INDUSTRY
SECTORS THE STATE HAS DEVELOPED
A SPECIFIC CURRICULUM AND
PATHWAY FOR STUDENTS INTERESTED
IN CAREERS IN THAT SECTOR.
SECOND PAGE JUST TALKS ABOUT THE
OBJECTIVES OF PROVIDING CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND SURE IF
YOU VISITED HIGH SCHOOL SEE TV
PROGRAMS IN YOUR DISTRICT.
LOT OF THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
DOING THEIR LOOKS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM A TRADITIONAL HIGH SCHOOL
CLASSROOM BUT FACT THE
OBJECTIVES OF THOSE PROGRAMS
HEARD QUITE COURTS TO THE
MISSION OF K. TWELVE THEY
INCLUDE.
PROMOTING STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
SOME STUDENTS HERE JUST FOR
INTEREST IN SCHOOL WHEN THEY CAN
DO SOMETHING PRACTICAL THAT THEY
CAN SEE LEADS TO A FUTURE CAREER --
AND ALSO TEACHING SOFT SKILLS
SHOWING UP ON TIME WORKING IN
TEAMS.
AND OF COURSE HELPING THE STATE
MEET ITS WORK FOR SCHOOLS.
ON PAGE THREE WE TALK ABOUT THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO SUPPORTING
CREATE TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
THIS WORK WITH THE STATE HAS
SUPPORTED -- CT THROW A
COMBINATION OF CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS AT PRIOR TO TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WHICH
IS TO SAY PRIOR TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
THE LARGEST OF THESE PROGRAMS
WAS A REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL
CENTERS AND PROGRAMS ARE OVER
ROC PEAS -- AT THEIR HEIGHT THEY
RECEIVED ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR --
THIS PROGRAM ALONG WITH MANY
OTHERS WAS ROLLED INTO ELSE EFF.
AND FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS FROM
200-013-1422 THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN HIGH SCHOOL CTU WAS.
SUPPORTED BY A COMBINATION OF
THE FUNDS PROVIDED UNDER L. C.
F. F. L. C. F. F. INCLUDED --
BUMPED TO THE HIGH SCHOOL BASE
RATE WHICH WAS INTENDED IN PART.
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE HIGHER COST
OF PROVIDING C. T. PROGRAMS AND
ALSO SOME LIMITED TERM A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS.
UGH THE MOST SIGNIFICANT OF
WHICH WAS THE CT INCENTIVE GRANT
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDED.
YOU'RE OVER YEAR DECREASING
STATE FUNDING AND AN INCREASING
LOCAL MATCH TO GO ALONG.
NOW IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHEN
THE C. T. INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM WAS -- SET TO EXPIRE
THERE IS INTEREST IN AMONG BOTH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT HIGH SCHOOL CT THROWED.
CATEGORICAL APPROACH THERE IS
SOME DISAGREEMENT ABOUT EXACTLY
HOW THAT CATEGORICAL APPROACH
SHOULD BE ADMINISTERED WHAT WE
ENDED UP WITH WORD TWO LARGE ON
GOING PROGRAMS.
OF ONE ADMINISTERED BY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE OTHER
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THE ONE ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WAS A
CONTINUATION OF THE CITY
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAM.
RECEIVES A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND SUPPORTED
ON COMPETITIVE BASIS --
APPLICANTS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE TO LOCAL DOLLARS FOR
EVERY ONE DOLLAR AND DEDICATED
STATE FUNDING THAT THEY RECEIVE.
THE OTHER PROGRAM WHICH IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WAS.
A K. TWELVE COMPONENT.
ON THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM
THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT SO THE
FINDING HERE IS DISTRIBUTED --
FIRST AS A FORMULA TO THE
VARIOUS -- CONSORTIA THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ON GOING THOSE
CONSORTIA THAN AWARD THE FUNDING
I GET A COMPETITIVE BASIS SAID
OF THE ACE IN THEIR AREA --
AGAIN FOR MOST APPLICANTS
THERE'S A TWO TO ONE LOCAL MATCH
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
FOUND ON PAGE FOUR WE DISCUSS --
IN ADDITION TO THE CATEGORICAL
FUNDING THE STATE SIR.
SIGNALS ITS SUPPORT FOR C. T. E.
BY INCLUDING AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED UNDER L. CFF.
ODD SO L. FF A WAS INTRODUCED
READ REQUIRED ALL DISTRICTS.
TO DEVELOP THE STRATEGIC PLANS
THE PLACE SPECIFIC MARKERS FOR
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND THEN
DETAILED HOW THEY WOULD MEET
THOSE MARKERS -- TO SEE THAT
THESE PLANS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED AND ARE SUCCESSFUL
WE ALSO INTRODUCED RECENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
WHICH TRACES A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT INDICATORS AMONG WHICH
IS THE COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS INDICATOR.
THAT INDICATOR IS SPELLED OUT ON
THE FINAL PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
PAGE FIVE BUT THE IMPORTATION
WAY HERE.
IS THAT WHILE THE CITY IS NOT A
NECESSARY COMPONENT OF THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER READINESS
INDICATOR.
IT IS ONE POTENTIAL COMPONENT
STUDENTS CAN BE MARKED AS
PREPARED.
IF THEY BOTH RECEIVE A HIGH
SCHOOL DEGREE AND COMPLETE ONE
OF THE CAREER PATHWAYS THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER.
NOW THE LATEST DASHBOARD DATA
INDICATE THAT THE STATE STILL.
HAS SOME WAY TO GO IN MEETING
THIS -- GOAL -- SPECIFICALLY IT
SHOWS THAT ABOUT 40% OF STUDENTS
ARE MARKED AS PREPARED BY 20%
ARE MARKED IS NEARING PREPARED
THAT LEAVES 40% THEY'RE MARKED
AS NOT PREPARED.
THAT'S THE END OF MY
INTRODUCTORYREMARK MARKS ALL
HEADED OVER TO THE OTHERS WELL.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT IF I LOOK AT
THE DASHBOARD AND I SEE THAT.
40% OF THE STUDENTS IN A
PARTICULAR DISTRICT ARE PREPARED.
DOES THAT MEAN NECESSARILY THAT
THEY WHEN THEY GET THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA THAT THEY HAVE A
JOB.
I KNOW IT DOES NOT A IT'S
SUPPOSED TO INDICATE THAT THEY
ARE PREPARED FOR EITHER COLLEGE
OR CAREER BUT IT.
IS DOES NOT NECESSARILY INDICATE
THAT THEY'VE BEEN ACCEPTED IN
EITHER FIELD SORT OF A DEFECT IN
OUR DASH WORDS WELL I I I'LL LET
THE PRESIDENT. TO THAT BUT IF.
WE JUST SAY.
THAT WAS A POOR CHOICE OF WORDS --
PREPSTAR DASH BOARD SYSTEM NEEDS
TO BE ENHANCED IN ORDER TO
MEASURE THE THE C. T..
PIECE OF CASE.
TO TWELVE I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS OKAY
OF AND WERE LOOKING YES MA'AM
NEXT AT LEANA GRAHAM OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES
AN ADDITIONAL TWO BILLION FOR
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
BRINGING TOOK TOTAL ELSE EFF
FUNDING TO SIXTY THREE BILLION
IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY IN ADDITION AN
AMOUNT EQUAL TO TWO POINT 6% OF
THE L. CFF BASE GRANT IS
PROVIDED.
THROUGH THE NINTH THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADE SPAN ADJUSTMENT
TERM ACCOUNT FOR THE HIGHER COST
OF PROVIDING CT PROGRAMS AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
THE SPACE GRANT ADJUSTMENT
AMOUNTS TO APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION AN
ONGOING FUNDING THAT HAS BEEN
FILLED IN ON TOP OF THE LCF BASE.
THEY CAN BE USED TO SUPPORT
ROBUST CT PROGRAMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE A LOCAL
PRIORITY.
FUNDING ALLOCATED THROUGH THE LC
FF SHOULD PAY FOR A FULL RANGE
OF EDUCATIONAL COSTS INCLUDING
C. T. E..
BUT IN RECOGNITION OF THE FACT
THAT HIGH QUALITY C. T. PROGRAMS
PLAY ABOUT A VALUABLE ROLE IN
PREPARING STUDENTS TO MEET THE
STATE'S LABOR TO PARK IT DEMANDS.
THE BUDGET MAINTAINS THE ONGOING
INVESTMENTS THAT WERE AND
NEGOTIATED AS PART OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET FOR BOTH THE
CITY INCENTIVE.
INCENTIVE GRANT PROGRAMS YOU
TAKE AND THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
COMPONENT OF THE STRONG WORK
FORCE PROGRAM.
A DIFFICULT ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION -- AN ONGOING PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IS PROVIDED
FOR LOCAL GRANTS TO K. THROUGH
TWELVE ENTITIES UNDER EACH
PROGRAM.
AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE MILLION AN
ONGOING PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO SUPPORT A
REGIONAL LEADERSHIP STRUCTURED
TO ASSIST TEACHERS AND INDUSTRY
PARTNERS.
IN IMPLEMENTING HIGH QUALITY C.
T. PROGRAMS AS WELL AS TWO
MILLION FUN PROVIDED TO SUPPORT
REGIONALS REGIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED.
WITH ADMINISTERING THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE COMPONENT OF THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM.
THESE PROGRAMS ALONG WITH THE
FUNDING PROVIDED THROUGH THE LC
FF HELP ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO TO
PARTICIPATE IN EFFECTIVE HIGH
QUALITY C. T. PROGRAMS.%
THAT ARE A LOT A LINE NOT ONLY
WITH COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS STANDARDS.
BUT ALSO WITH THE NEEDS OF
EMPLOYERS INDUSTRY AND LABOR.
FINALLY A NOTED IN THE AGENDA
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT MAKES SEVERAL TECHNICAL
CHANGES.
THE LANGUAGE GOVERNING BOTH
PROGRAMS -- THESE CHANGES ARE
PROPOSED IN RESPONSE TO
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE MADE
BY THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
PATHWAYS JOINT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
AND FEEDBACK RECEIVED FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS -- I HAVE WITH ME
AND AMBER ALEXANDER FROM FINANCE
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON BUDGETARY
ROCKED AND MEMBERS I MICHELLE
MACINTOSH.
pLEADERSHIP OFFICE TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMAN.
AND I CAN'T SAY THAT C. T. E. IS
INCLUDED IN THE DASHBOARD IS
PART OF THE CAREER COMPONENT IF
STUDENTS COMPLETE A SEQUENCE --
OF COURSES OF THREE HUNDRED
HOURS OR MORE -- THAT IS WHAT
MEASURES THAT'S ONE OF THE
CURRENT MEASURES FOR AND THE
DASHBOARD AT THIS TIME.
I'M SO WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THE
GOVERNOR SUPPORT AS THE TAKE AND
PROVIDING FUNDING INTO POSITIONS
TO IMPLEMENT THE CAREER
TECHNICAL.
EDUCATION INCENTIVE GRANT UNDER
THE SEA TAKE SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE AND EXPAND
PROGRAM CITY PROGRAMS DRIVEN.
BY STUDENT INTEREST CURRENT
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE LABOR
MARKET DATA INDUSTRY ADVOCACY
AND INVOLVEMENT.
AM I MET WITH PROGRAMS OFFERED
AT THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS.
K. TWELVE CITIES UNIQUE FROM C.
T. PROGRAMS OFFERED IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THAT THEY EMPHASIZE
THE INTEGRATION OF GENERAL
ACADEMICS.
ANNA WITH CTP AND COURSES ARE
BASED ON THE CT MODEL CURRICULUM
STANDARDS.
CORRECT TECHNICAL STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS INSTANT
LEADERSHIP'S OURS THE LEADERSHIP
ARE INTEGRAL TO CT COURSE
OBJECTIVES AND STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH THE CURRICULUM OF
WORK BASED LEARNING EXPERIENCES.
THROUGH OUT THER CT COURSE
SEQUENCE.
SO HERE'S A QUICK UPDATE ON
EIGHT EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL
YEAR SEE TAKE APPLICATION
PROCESS -- THE APPLICATIONS OPEN
TO THE ELLIE ETS ON DECEMBER
NINETEENTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THEY WERE THEN DO BACK TO THE CD
E. ON JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT WAS A TIGHT
TIME LINE BUT WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO TO GET THE ALLOCATIONS OUT TO
SCHOOLS.
PRIOR TO THE MARCH FIFTEENTH
NOTICING -- OF TEACHERS.
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED I WE HAD A
TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
NINE APPLICATIONS RECEIVED -- OF
OF THOSE APPLICATIONS THREE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS WERE ACTUALLY READ
AND SCORED -- THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
GRANTEES SERVING FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO ELEAZAR.
OTHER PRELIMINARY ALLOCATION YES
IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE TOTAL ASK FROM
THOSE THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE APPLICATIONS WAS. THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS -- GRANT AWARD
NOTIFICATIONS WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE PROCESS OF GETTING THOSE
OUT TO THE FIELD -- AND WORKING
THROUGH OUR PROCESSES AT THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO THAT.
SERVER FUNDING RESULTS AS I
MENTIONED I AM A TOTAL OF THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
APPLICATIONS WILL BE FUNDED.
SERVING A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO LOCAL EDUCATION AND
AGENCIES -- THIS LIST WAS
PROVIDED AT THE MARCH BOARD
MEETING STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
MEETING -- AGAIN 200-98
INDIVIDUALS A INDIVIDUAL LEDS.
THIRTY AND THIRTY NINE
CONSORTIUM MADE UP OF TWO OR
MORE FOR THIS THIRTY NINE
CONSORTIA ACTUALLY MAKE UP A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
AND THEN FIFTY THREE OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES ARE
REPRESENTED AND LIKE YOU AS
SENATOR ROUGH I DO LIKE PICTURES
TOO SO THAT WOULD BE HE HE ADDS.
I HAVE PROVIDED YOU WITH.
THE MAP OF THE STATE AND WHAT
THIS ACTUALLY SHOWS IS THE
SPREAD OF FUNDING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE BUBBLE WILL FOR EACH
COUNTY THIS IS DONE BY COUNTY IT
THE BUBBLE FOR EACH COUNTY.
I TELLS YOU HOW MANY GRANTS WERE
AWARDED IN THAT COUNTY AND
REMEMBER THAT COULD BE AN
INDIVIDUAL ELLIE A OR COULD BE
CONSORTIA.
AND THEN THE TOTAL DOLLARS
AWARDED FOR THOSE COUNTIES.
SAYS THE POSITIVE THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO AND FOR
AT IMPLEMENTATION WITH THE TAG
COMING UP BIRTH -- FIRST OF ALL
AT THE SUPERINTENDENT OF ABC
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT -- WILL
WRITE A LETTER FOR EACH OF THE
STUDENT THAT COMPLETES THEIR
CAREER PATHWAY EDUCATION PROGRAM
GUARANTEEING THEM AN INTERVIEW
FOR A TEACHING POSITION ONCE
THEY FINISH THEIR POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION -- ANOTHER -- POINT IS
THAT RED BLUFF HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE NORTH OFFERS SIXTY NINE
SECTIONS OF CTE COURSES.
SERVING FIFTH ELEVEN OF OUR
FIFTEEN SECTORS AND THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES ACTUALLY VOTED TO
EXPAND THEIR SCHOOL PERIOD FROM
SIXTY PERIOD TO A SEVEN DAY
PERIOD -- AND ALL STUDENTS AT
ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLETE A TWO
YEAR SEQUENCE OF COURSES IN A C.
T. E. PATHWAY AS A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT.
AND THIS YEAR FOR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE CLASS OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE THE
FIRST CLASS TO HAVE ALL
GRADUATES.
AND COMPLETING A SEQUENCE OF
COURSES IN CT.
A COUNTRY COSTA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION REPORTED NEARLY 86%
OTHER TEACHERS REPORT THAT THEIR
STUDENTS PARTICIPATE IN WORK
BASED LEARNING EXPERIENCES --
WILL CAN THEY'LL CONTINUE TO BE
ACTIVE PARTNERS AND THEY EARN
AND LEARN EAST BAY INITIATIVE
WITH THEGOAL OF EXPANDING.
THEIR INDUSTRY PARTNERSHIPS AND
WORK BASED LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
AND THEN IN SAN BERNADINO COUNTY
CONSORTIUM MEMBERS WILL ASSESS
THEIR PRACTICES FOR COLLECTING
DATA PERTAINING TO WORK BASED
LEARNING.
AND LOOK AT HOW BEST TO CAPTURE
THIS DATA ELEMENT FOR C. T. E..
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR PEAS
COMMUNITY CLASSROOM METHODOLOGY --
COMMUNITY CLASSROOM IS -- AN
UNPAID -- UNPAID.
FIVE INTERNSHIP AND THEY WILL BE-OFFERING THAT TO COMMUNE
CONSORTIUM MEMBERS AND THE
CONSORTIUM WILL ALSO LEVERAGE
THE WORK OF THE INLAND DESERT.
REGIONAL STRONG WORK FORCE
CONSORTIUM TO LEARN ABOUT THE
LAUNCH APPRENTICESHIP NETWORK
PROJECT WHICH HAS A YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP COMPONENT.
IS PART OF FOCUSING ON THE
EXPANDING ROLE OF RECOGNIZED
APPRENTICESHIPS -- AND WITH THAT --
WE ALSO AS OUR FUNDING FOR SEVEN
TECHNICAL REGIONAL CENTER SEVEN
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS -- COMES TO AN END OF
THIS JUNE AT TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PUBLICLY THANK
THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE IN THE
HARD WORK THAT THEY'VE PROVIDED.
AND DURING THE PAST THREE YEARS
OF SERVING OUR AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES WITH THE SEA
TO GRANT
NO MAYBE MIKE I'M NOT SURE MY
QUESTION REALLY MAKES SENSE OR
EVEN AS RELEVANT BUT SO IF I'M
LOOKING AT A K. THROUGH TWELVE
DISTRICT IN THERE A HUNDRED
GRADUATES OF YOU KNOW AT THE END
OF THE THE THE TERM.
I AM ABLE TO TELL THAT SIXTY OF
THE HUNDRED ONE TWO OF TWO OR
FOUR YEAR.
COLLEGE.
OF THE TWENTY OF THEM.
AS A RESULT OF K. TO TWELVE C.
T. PROGRAMS WENT INTO OTHER
MANUFACTURING JOBS OR
MANUFACTURING APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM THE TEN WENT.
TO BECAUSE OF A ICE CAGE YOU --
TWELVE CT PROGRAM WENT INTO AN
EITHER IN AEROSPACE.
F. MAINTENANCE POSITION OR
AIRCRAFT MAINTENANCE -- TRAINING
OR APPRENTICESHIP JOB AND AT THE
LAST TEN WENT TO AG BECAUSE OF
WAS A CASE OF TWELVE DISTRICT
THAT HAD AN AG SEAT YOU PROGRAM.
YES SO THAT'S PART OF THE FOLLOW
UP DATA FOLLOWUP STAYS AT WE DO
WE'VE TYPICALLY DONE ON THIS
FOLLOW UP STUDIES WITH OUR
PERKINS FUNDS FROM THE FEDERAL
AND THAT WE RECEIVE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- AND WE
HAVE STARTED DOING FOLLOW UP
STUDIES WITH OUR SEE TEAGUE
GRANT -- AND SAID THAT THE OTHER
CHART THAT I PROVIDED WITH YOU
FOLKS -- AND SO THEN THAT IS IN
FOLLOW UP AND THAT WAS PART OF
THE LEGISLATION IS TO FIND OUT
HOW MANY OF THOSE STUDENTS
ACTUALLY CONTINUED ON EITHER
WENT TO THE MILITARY AND SO
FORTH OR WENT ON TO EMPLOYMENT
OR EDUCATION IN THE SAME.
IN THE AME PATTERN MAYBE THIS
IS GONNA BE PART OF THIS
LONGITUDINAL.
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM THE
BEST THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
FIRST FOR TALKING ABOUT.
IN A CRADLE TO CAREER -- BUT I
WAS GONNA ASK IT AND MAYBE I
SHOULD LET EVERYBODY ELSE FINISH
BUT AS PART OF THE STRONG WORK
FOCE AND THE C. T. INCENTIVE
GRANT AND WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR A FEW YEARS.
WHAT SORT OF DATA DEFICIENCIES?
HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED.
IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THE DATA
SYSTEM OUGHT TO BE STATEWIDE AND
YOU KNOW LOCAL OPTION RIGHT.
WHAT SORT OF DATA DEFICIENCIES
HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED AND AND WHAT
ACTION ARE WE TAKING TO REMEDY
THE DEFICIENCIES IN ORDER TO
GIVE A?
GIVE US A ROBUST -- BODY OF DATA
FROM WHICH TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS IN THE FUTURE THE
FIRST QUESTION I THINK THAT'S A
FAIR QUESTION.
AND SO AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS
IS THAT -- WHEN SEATED FIRST
ROLLED OUT A THINK THERE WAS AN
EXPECTATION THAT OUR CALL PADS
ARE CALIFORNIA LONGITUDINAL
PEOPLE DATA SYSTEM?
WAS GOING TO BE ABLE TO COLLECT
A LOT OF THE DATA AND THERE'S
BEEN -- A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT AS
PRESSURE ON CAL PADS ITSELF TO
COLLECT.
NOT JUST OUR C. T. E. DATA BUT
DATA FOR ALL OF THE STUDENTS
RIGHT ACROSS THE STATE -- AND SO.
AND SOME THINGS THAT I HELP HAS.
CANDY CURRENTLY IS IT CAN
COLLECT THE NUMBER C. T. E.
STUDENTS THEY CAN COLLECT
PATHWAY INFORMATION.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY
AT THIS POINT T. DISAGGREGATED
DATA BY FUNDING SOURCE IF YOU'RE
ASKING SPECIFICALLY.
HOW DO WE KNOW WHICH STUDENTS
BENEFITED FROM SEATED WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO TELL YOU
THAT EXCEPT WE DID WE JUST
STARTED TO IMPLEMENT A SURVEY
SYSTEM -- WITH OUR WITH OUR
GRANTEES AND THAT'S WHERE THIS
DATA CAME FROM -- WE DID A FOR
FIRST WE DID A ADAM.
A SURVEY TO DO ENROLLMENT DATA
TO SEE WHAT TYPES OF OUTCOMES
THAT WE DID GET WHAT WE COULD
GET -- AND SO THIS IS JUST THE
ENROLLMENT DATA AND THEN WE'LL
BE ROLLING OUT ANOTHER SURVEY TO
OUR FOLKS SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
TAG -- TO GET TO GET THAT DATA
AS WELL WE ALMOST NEED A SYSTEM
THAT WORKS WITHOUT THE NEED FOR
SURVEYS RIGHT EXACTLY SO I MEAN
THE THE EXISTING SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE DOES IT IT.
IT CAN TELL YOU HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED K. THROUGH
TWELVE I GUESS HER AND ROLLED IN
C. T..
CAN IT TELL YOU HOW MANY OF
THOSE STUDENTS SECURE JOBS IN
THE FIELD IN THE C. T. THAT DOES
NOT IT DOES NOT GIVE US THE
FOLLOW UP.
ON THE WEATHER OF SOMEBODY WHO'S
IN A MANUFACTURING RELATED C. T.
PROGRAM WINDS UP AS A PRIEST AT
STARBUCKS OR WHETHER THEY'RE
ACTUALLY INTO.
WE DO FIRMS ARE PERFECT FOR
PERKINS WE DO -- BECAUSE THAT'S
TRADITIONAL DATA WE'VE ALWAYS
COLLECTED FOR PERKINS -- BUT NOT
FOR STATEWIDE CT.
YES SIR I DID ME I MEAN TO CUT
YOU WANNA THAT'S THAT'S
PERFECTLY FINE NO -- IT'S I
THINK I THINK THE THE TWO
LEGISLATIVE PIECES THAT ARE HERE
THAT WERE REPORTING ON A REALLY
DESIGNED TO SORT OF HELP US TO
BEGIN TO CREATE THAT THAT.
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHERE DO WE
CONNECT THE SYSTEMS IN TERMS OF
THE DATA POINTS IN OTHER WORDS
WHAT ARE THE RELEVANT PIECES.
BY TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER INDICATORS
THAT ARE COMING OUT OF THE CAGE
WILL SYSTEM.
AND THEN HOW TO THOSE SORT OF
RELATE BECAUSE WE KNOW FULL WELL
THAT PART OF THE COLLEGE --
INDICATOR IS -- LIKE DUAL
ENROLLMENT -- WHICH IS.
A GOOD WAY TO SORT OF MEASURE
WHETHER STUDENTS ARE MAKING
PROGRESS IN COLLEGE ATTAINMENT
SO.
WHAT WE'VE DONE NOW THAT'S THE
GOAL YEAH IF THAT'S THE GOAL SO
I MEAN THE SORT OF METRICS THAT
WE HAVE IN STRONG WORK FOR US
WE'RE TRYING TO INSURE THAT
THEY'RE CONNECTING?
AND PART OF THAT WORK IS IT'S
THE LONGITUDINAL THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S INSURING THAT THE DATA MO
USER IN PLACE TO TO TO SAY THAT
CAL PADS CAN TALK TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN MY S.
SYSTEM.
SO THAT WE CAN CREATE SORT OF A
OF A PIPELINE BECAUSE THIS IS A
PIPELINE CREATION RIGHT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT THESE TWO
PIECES OF LEGISLATION ARE
DESIGNED TO DO.
IS TRY TO CONNECT THE SYSTEMS
WHEN WE GO TO OTHER STATES AND
PRESENT ON THIS.
IS NOT A LOT OF OTHER STATES
THAT ARE CONNECTING THAT THE
SECONDARY TO POST SECONDARY
SYSTEM RIGHT SO WE ALSO NEED THE
END RIGHT AND WE NEED TO HAVE
THE DATA.
THE OUTCOME DATA IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP TO EVALUATE THE
EFFICIENCY AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE
FINDING AND BE AGILE ENOUGH. TWO
SHIFTS TO PIVOT FROM PROGRAM
BETA PROGRAM BE IF A IS NOT
WORKING.
OR WERE PRODUCING PEOPLE WERE
TURNING OUT A PRODUCT THAT THAT
INDUSTRY DOESN'T NEED
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
YEAH THERE'S CERTAIN PROGRAMS
THAT A K. THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM
WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER BETTER
THAN A COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN AND
VICE VERSA SO.
WHERE IS THE DEVELOPMENTAL NEED
OF THE STUDENT IN TERMS OF THEIR
TRAJECTORY AND I THINK THAT'S
THE QUESTION TO GET OUT THERE
AND IF I CAN JUST JUMP IN HERE
TO REMEMBER ALEXANDER WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- YOU
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- TO PROVIDE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE CREATION
OF THIS.
AT CRADLE TO CAREER -- MINOR
TIDAL DATA SYSTEM AND HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL ACCOMPLISH MANY OF THE
GOALS THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING --
TO GET THAT NO FOR THIS YEAR
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING
DISCUSSIONS ON YOU KNOW FOR THE
PAST YEAH I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
YEARS -- BUT JUST REALLY BEING
ABLE TO TRACK -- AS STUDENTS
PROGRESS AS THEY GO FROM K.
TWELVE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
INTO THE WORK FORCE AND REALLY
FINDING OUT YOU KNOW WHERE THEY
END UP ALONG THAT EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAY -- WITH REGARDS TO THESE
TWO PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY -- IN
RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE DATA
DEFICIENCIES THAT THAT HAD BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN PREVIOUS YEARS
THERE WERE SOME IMPORTANT
CHANGES THAT WERE MADE LAST YEAR --
IT FOR BOTH PROGRAMS AND ONE OF
THE KEY CHANGES WAS REALLY THE
INCORPORATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE AND JOINT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
AND FOR BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
THAT COMMITTEE IS ASKED TO GO IN
AND REVIEW THE DATA METRICS THAT
ARE REQUIRED TO BE REPORTED ON
BY A GRANT APPLICANTS.
AND TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO IF THEY'RE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE METRICS ENSURING
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
COLLECTIBLE.
AND THEN ALSO LOOKING AT WHETHER
NEW METRICS NEEDED TO BE ADDED
AND SO AS OUR DATA SYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP.
THE HOPE IS THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO INCORPORATE MORE CAREER
MEASURES INTO -- INDICATORS LIKE
THE COLLEGE AND CAREER AND
REALLY HAVE THAT DATA THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISIONS AT THE STATE LEVEL.
IT'S REALLY A CONNECTIVITY ISSUE
ISN'T IT BECAUSE WE HAVE THESE.
THESE ENTITIES THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THESE SYSTEMS
WORKING IN THE SAME.
YOU KNOW ENVIRONMENT BUT YOU'RE
WORKING AND SO THE QUESTION IS
HOW YOU CONNECT.
AND OPERATE IN THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO INSURE THAT
YOUR SERVICING YOUR CUSTOMER
CLIENT WHICH IN YOUR CASE IS.
OF THE STUDENTS SERVICE AND MAKE
SURE THAT YOU DELIVER TO THEM
THE PRODUCT THAT THEY THINK
THEY'RE GONNA GET WHICH IS AN
EDUCATION THAT GETS THEM.
A GOOD PAYING JOB IN A FIELD
THEY WANT TO WORK IN.
WHETHER THEY'RE A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE OR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GRADUATE OR SOMETHING BEYOND OR
SOMETHING IN BETWEEN.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE ISSUE IT
REQUIRES DAY THAT REQUIRES
EVERYBODY TO TALK TOGETHER IN
THE DATA.
TO BE ACCESSIBLE BY EVERYONE AND
THEN.
SOME OF I WEIGH TION OF PROGRAMS
AND THE MONEY THAT WE SPEND AND
THE RE DIRECTION OF THAT MONEY
IF THEY'RE BETTER WAYS.
TO USE THAT MONEY BUT ANYWAY
GREAT JOB I DID I DO YOU.
ANYBODY HAVE ANYTHING ELSE.
GREAT PRESENTATION LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT IS ADULT
EDUCATION.
OUR FINAL ISSUE FOR THE DAY
.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON HOAX SO WE
HAVE NEW FACES HERE LET'S START
TO MY LEFT HER FEW DATA FOR
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD.
PASTI NELSON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN SIR.
KEITH IS ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
CAROLINE SACRI DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
OF YOUR AMERILA CALIFORNICUM
ECOLOGIST CHAPTERS OFFICE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHAT'S THE STORY -- GO AHEAD AND
START AGAIN HE'S THE KING THAT
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE FINANCE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM AND SO THE SECOND SET OF
DISTRIBUTED ONE MORE HAND OUT
FROM OUR OFFICE FOR TODAY.
IF YOU TURN TO THE FIRST PAGE OF
THIS HANDOUT WE'LL SEE THAT
LITTLE EDUCATION AS MULTIPLE
PURPOSES BUT IS PRIMARILY
INTENDED TO PROVIDE PRECLUDED
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND ABILITIES.
KIDADA AND ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS OFFER COURSEWORK IN
BASIC ENGLISH NOT SOMETIMES
CULMINATING IN HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA.
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE AND
ALSO IN SHORT TERM CT.
IN CALIFORNIA THE MAIN PROVIDERS
OF ADULT EDUCATION OUR ADULT
SCHOOLS FROM WITHIN THAT KIT ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS WELL AS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SYSTEM.
HISTORICALLY THESE TWO SYSTEMS
IT'LL SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
DIFFERENT RULES AND POLICIES AND
SO IN TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
THE STATE.
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS THAT
DIFFERENCE BY RESTRUCTURING
ADULT EDUCATION INTO A SYSTEM OF
REGIONAL CONSORTIA THAT BRING
TOGETHER ADULT SCHOOLS INCLUDING
COLLEGES.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE
OF THESE REGIONAL CONSORTIA
ACROSS THE STATE SUED THESE ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THE STRONG WORK
FORCE CONSORTIA THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING IN THE EARLIER PANEL.
THE STATE DID ALSO BEGAN IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO
PROVIDE.
ONGOING FUNDING FOR ADULT
EDUCATION THROUGH WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY CALLED THE ADULT
EDUCATION BLOCK GRANT.
AND WAS RECENTLY RENAMED THE
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM THE
ORIGINAL AMOUNT THERE WAS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ON GOING.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDER SOMETIMES
RECEIVE FUNDING FROM OTHER
SOURCES. FOR EXAMPLE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DO RECEIVE
APPORTIONMENT FOR THE NON CREDIT
ADULT EDUCATION COURSES.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ADULT
SCHOOLS MAY RECEIVE FEDERAL.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
STATE DID PROVIDE AN
AUGMENTATION FOR THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM THE BOOK OF
THIS AUTHENTICATION TWENTY TWO
MILLION WAS.
FOR COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
THERE IS ALSO A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION ON GOING FOR
IT DID IMPROVEMENTS PRIMARILY
RELATED TO IMPROVING OUR ABILITY
TO TRACK STUDENT OUTCOMES AS
THEY MOVE ACROSS PROVIDERS AND
EVENTUALLY INTO THE WORK FORCE.
YOU'LL HEAR SHORTLY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT THE
GOVERNOR DOES ALSO PROPOSING
ADDITIONAL COST OF AN ADJUSTMENT
FOR THIS YEAR WHICH WOULD BRING
TOTAL FUNDING FOR THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM TO FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
ON GOING.
THE COMPUTER OVERVIEW WE JUST
WANTED TO BRIEFLY NOTE SOME
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS REGARDING
ALIGNMENT IN THE STATE THAT'LL
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
AS I NOTED THE ADULT EDUCATION
SYSTEM AS IT'S DESIGNED AS BRING
TOGETHER TO PREVIOUSLY DESPERATE
SYSTEMS.
AND WHAT THE STATE HAS MADE MANY
EFFORTS TO INCREASE ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN MIDDLE SCHOOLS IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES THAT REMAIN
UNRESOLVED. ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
HAS TO DO WITH HOW THE STATE
FUNDS ADULT EDUCATION.
BECAUSE THERE IS A SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO THE ADULT
SCHOOLS VERSUS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
PER STUDENT FUNDING LEVELS
LIKELY VERY QUITE A BIT ACROSS
PROVIDERS WHICH COULD RESULT IN
DIFFERENCES IN ACCESSING QUALITY
FOR STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF
POLICIES THAT CONTINUE TO DIFFER
AT THE ADULT SCHOOLS.
COMPARED TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES INCLUDING POLICIES
RELATED COURSE FEES AND MINIMUM
INSTRUCTOR QUALIFICATIONS.
AND FINALLY THERE'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION AROUND DATA
IMPROVEMENTS AS REFERENCED IN
THAT BUDGET PROPOSALS FROM LAST
YEAR.
ON TO DEFEAT THE STATE DOES NOT
HAVE COMPLAINTS ABOUT CONSIDER
FOR ADULT STUDENTS THOUGH THAT
ARMS OF INDICATED THAT
IMPROVEMENTS ARE UNDERWAY AND
HE'LL LIKELY HERE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT LATER ON THE PANEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM
[inaudible]
THAT.
SO KEEP HIS -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
ON THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES OVER SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
FUNDING FOR THREE PRIMARY ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS -- LARGEST OF
WHICH IS THE MAIN ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM THE WHICH HAS
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR POINT
SIX MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND -- ALLOCATED
TO IT WHICH IS A JOINT
ADMINISTERED BY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCES OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
THERE'S ALSO FIFTEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DALTON
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES PROGRAM
WHICH IS RUN BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION -- AND LASTLY
THERE'S OVER A HUNDRED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS --
FOR THE TITLE TO WORK FORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITIES ACT AND
CAL WORKS PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
ADULT EDUCATION -- PROVIDE ADULT
EDUCATION SERVICES --
ADDITIONALLY -- THERE'S ALSO
SOME SOME PORTION OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES APPORTIONMENT
AND THE K. TWELVE ABORTIONS --
ARE USED TO PROVIDES SERVICES TO
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF STUDENTS
THAT -- AND THE TYPE OF PROGRAMS
AT THE MAIN ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM -- PROVIDES -- AS
MENTIONED THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE MAIN ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM OF EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND FOR UNDER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE
DALTON CORRECTION FACILITIES.
PROGRAM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- AS I SAID I'M
CAROLINE'S ACREE AND I AM
SPEAKING HERE ON BEHALF OF
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMAN.
THIS WEEK I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
ADULT EDUCATION WEEK IN SERVICES
NOW OPPORTUNE TIME TO TALK ABOUT
THIS TOPIC.
FROM THE ADULT EDUCATION OFFICE
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DELIVERS ASSISTANCE
AND GUIDANCE. TO PROVIDERS IN
THE FIELD ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF ADULT SERVICES ADULT
EDUCATION SERVICES.
IN CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA IS THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTRY.
WITH FULL FUNDING FROM AS KEITH
SAID WE OWE A TITLE TO ADULT
EDUCATION FAMILY LITERACY ACT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND THEN IT IN -- JOINT JOINTLY
WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THE
CALIFORNIA DELTA G. CATION
PROGRAM.
RECENTLY WE SENT OVER A DRAFT OF
OUR REPORT FOR YOU TO REVIEW
THAT ADDRESSES THE KEY --
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
STATE LEVEL DATA ON STUDENT
ENROLLMENT OUTCOMES SKILL GAINS
STUDENT DEMOGRAPHICS AND OTHER
DATA.
I'M USING THE NEW ADULT
EDUCATION DATA AND
ACCOUNTABILITY METRICS AS WELL
AS OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD -- HI YOUR
MAIL FROM THE CALIFORNIA COMING
UP CALLED DISCOUNTERS OFFICE.
ON THE PARTNERSHIP WITH WITH
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSED ON THE LAST TWO THREE
YEARS HAVE BEEN THE STRUCTURAL
ISSUES DESCRIBE THAT MEANS WE
ADULT EDUCATION WAS RE IMAGINE
AND REGIONAL COMES.
AS RITA CONSORTIA AND WAS TO BE
BASED ON METRICS SO WE VIEW
THOSE AS STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
SO WE'VE INVESTED AND CAPACITY
BUILDING WITHIN OUR REGIONAL
CONSORTIA SO THEY COULD DO THE
KIND OF PLANNING.
WITH THEIR STAKEHOLDERS MONKS
THE PROVIDERS THOSE ARE SEVEN
ONE CONSORTIUMS OVERSEE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY PROVIDERS -- BEEN
ALSO A BIG KEY TO THIS ACTUALLY
BECOMING UP A SYSTEM OF A
PROGRAM MADE UP OF TWO SYSTEMS.
ARE THE METRICS AND THE DATA
THAT WE WE ACTUALLY REQUIRE OUR
PROVIDERS TO REPORT.
AND GLAD TO SAY THAT BUT DURING
THE LAST THREE YEARS WE'VE
CREATED A UNIFORM DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEM.
WHICH WAS A PROVIDER FOR THAT WE
TITLE TO THAT SEE THE LOCAL CITY
FOR MANY YEARS.
SO THEY ACTUALLY BECAME A
UNIFORM DATA COLLECTION PROVIDER
FOR THE KP TWELVE FOR THE STATE
PROGRAM AS WELL -- LAST YEAR --
WE ACTUALLY REQUIRED OUR
COLLEGES TO PARTICIPATE WITH THE
ACTUALLY YOUR PRIOR THE LAST
YEAR WE HAVE.
ACTUALLY JUST RELY ON THERE ARE
EXISTING REPORTING SYSTEM TO
MEET OUR REPORTING NEEDS FOR
ADULT EDUCATION SO ARE WE NOW
HAVE OUR M. I. S..
R. OUR OUR WEEK OUR PROVIDER
CROSSES AND ALL THAT DATA --
GETS REPORTED UP TO TO A FILE ON
THAT'S PRESENTED UTILIZING A
PLATFORM THAT WE REFER TO IN A
LARGE BOARD AS ADULT EDUCATION
PIPELINE.
AND THAT DATA IS UTILIZES.
ALARM ARCADY TRIAL DATA AT THE
VALIDATE SARAH TRANSITION DATA
WHAT AM I A SYSTEM -- AND THEN
ACTUALLY -- VALIDATES WITH EDT
TAXING NOW THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY PORT WAGE GAINS -- IT
AND PUT THAT THERE WERE ACTUALLY
WORKING THAT OUT TWO QUARTERS
AFTER EXIT.
THINGS THAT WE CANNOT TELL YOU
IN THE PAST REGARDING ADULT
EDUCATION -- SO AND THAT THE
PLATFORM IS WHAT WE UTILIZE TO
NOW MOVING FORWARD TO REPORT Q..
ON THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR -- BUT ALSO IT PROVIDES
A PLATFORM THAT'S USABLE FOR
CONSORTIUMS OUR PROVIDERS.
SO THEY ACTUALLY HAVE ACTIONABLE
DATA IN WHICH THEY COULD UTILIZE
FOR THEIR THREE YEAR PLANNING
WHICH THEY HAVE UNDER WAY IN
WHICH THAT'S PART OF OUR
STRUCTURAL WORK THAT WE DID IS
THAT WE ACTUALLY CREATED BY
THREE YEAR PLANNING PROCESS.
THAT HAS FOUR COMPONENTS TO IT
ONE IS THEY ACTUALLY -- DO AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE RESOURCES
REGIONALLY AMONGST THEIR
PROVIDERS AMONGST APPROACH THEIR
THEIR PARTNERS SUCH AS THE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD SYSTEMS.
AND THEN ALSO THEN THEY ACTUALLY
CAN DO CONCERTS LOOK AT THE
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE REGION.
THE LABOR MARKET INFORMATION
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF VESTMENTS
AND MADE A LOT OF DATA AVAILABLE
WE ARE ON LABOR MARKET
INFORMATION JUST TO GET THE
CONVERSATION GOING.
WE WANT THEM TO WORK WITH THE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM.
THEN AFTER THAT ACTUALLY COME UP
WITH SOME STRATEGIES.
AND THEN AFTER THAT PILOT SOME
NEW IDEAS -- SO THAT'S KIND OF
THE STRUCTURAL THINGS WE'VE DONE
TO ACTUALLY MOVE -- ACHIEVE I
THINK SOME ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS A
10% INCREASE IN SERVICES AND SO
ON WE EXPECT THAT TO CONTINUE.
LET.
ME JUST ASK THIS QUESTION I MEAN
BEYOND DATA COLLECTION
COMPILATION THINGS LIKE THAT --
V. L. A. -- MENTION SOME.
EXISTING ISSUES -- IN TERMS OF
MAKING THE TWO IN ESSENCE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN CASE
OF TWELVE WORK SMOOTHLY TOWARD
ACCOMPLISHING A COMMON GOAL HERE
IN ADULT EDUCATION ONE WAS.
EARLY A FUNDING ISSUE THE OTHER
IS THERE.
MUST BE A CREDENTIALING
QUALIFICATION ISSUE -- ALLOWING
INSTRUCTORS TO SERVE CROSS TEACH
SO TO SPEAK IN DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTS.
MAYBE YOU COULD DISCUSS SOME OF
THE IMPEDIMENTS THAT THAT IF IF
THAT'S THE RIGHT WORD -- THEY WE
HAVE STRUCTURALLY HERE IN THE
STATE.
THAT CREATES SOME ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO HAVING -- SMOOTHLY
RUNNING ADULT EDUCATION.
SYSTEM INVOLVING PARTICIPANTS
FROM DIFFERENT COMING FROM TO
THE PROCESS FROM DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS THE FIST QUESTION --
CERTAINLY AND I'D LIKE TO CALL
IT A CHALLENGE.
VERSES AN IMPEDIMENT BECAUSE IT
IT IS A CHALLENGE AND I'D LIKE
TO TALK OF IT -- CREDENTIALING
THE TEACHER QUALIFICATION PIECE
FIRST.
CURRENTLY -- INDIVIDUALS THAT
TEACH IN A K. ADULT.
SYSTEM ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE A
CURRENT CREDENTIAL ISSUED BY CTC.
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
THEY HAVE TO MEET MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS. ONE OF THOSE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS CAN BE
THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL.
IF THEY ARE -- AND IT'S UP TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHOOSE
WHICH QUALIFICATION THEY'RE
GOING. TO TO RECEDE THE OTHER
CHALLENGE IS THERE'S A PAY
DIFFERENTIAL.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES RE ABLE
TO PAY THOSE TEACHERS AT A
HIGHER RATE.
THAN MANY OF OUR KD ADULT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
TEACHERS.
AND THAT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE
FOR THAT PAID PIECE AND THEN TO
BRING INSTRUCTORS FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE INTO OUR K.
TWELVE CABLE SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE TO THEN GO AND GET A
CREDENTIAL BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
TEACH AND BE ON THE PAYROLL THEY
HAVE TO HAVE THAT CREDENTIAL AND
WE ARE LOOKING AT SOME WAYS
THROUGH OUR ADULT EDUCATION
ASSOCIATIONS TO COME UP.
WITH WAYS TO EASE THAT BURDEN
BECAUSE THERE IS A COST TO TO GO
AND GET YOUR CREDENTIAL.
UP. TO THREE FOUR FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. TO GET THAT CREDENTIAL
AND SO IT IS A COST TO THOSE
TEACHERS WHO ARE THEN GOING TO
BE MAKING.
NOT A NOT A LOT OF MONEY TO
RECOUP THAT IN THE FUTURE SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS
[inaudible]
TO STREAMLINE THAT.
I REALIZE THE SENSITIVITY OF
THIS QUESTION OF BUT IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT MAYBE THIS IS A
CONVERSATION THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE AT LEAST IN TERMS OF I MEAN
I GUESS IT DEPENDS ON WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TEACH AND WHO WERE
TRYING TO TEACH.
AND IS IT US THIS IS A
SPECIALIZED.
AREA OR TO OUR SUBJECT AREA
WHERE.
IT WOULD IT WOULD.
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO NECESSARILY
HAVE SOMEBODY CREDENTIALED IN
THE CONTEXT OF K. THROUGH TWELVE
AT A PARTICULAR DISTRICT BECAUSE
MAYBE DON'T TEACH THAT OFTEN.
MAYBE THERE THAT THAT MANY
STUDENTS INTO TEACHING IT AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE MIGHT HAVE
SOMEONE AVAILABLE IN A
SPECIALIZED AREA TO TEACH A
PARTICULAR COURSE.
AND IT WOULD SEEM SORT OF AND
DIFFICULT TO REQUIRE. EIGHT TO
TWELVE TEACHING CREDENTIAL UNDER
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES ON THE OTHER
HAND IF YOU'RE TEACHING ENGLISH --
IN YOUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INSTRUCTOR AND THEY WANT TO PUT
YOU OUT OF SIGHT SHE WON A CASE
OF TWELVE CAMPUS TO KEEP TEACH
ENGLISH WELL THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT. EIGHT TO TWELVE RB
TEACHING.
THEN I WOULD THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE A DIFFERENT SCENARIO OR
MY COMMENTS MAKING SENSE SUIT SO
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TEACHING SO THEY ARE --
IN THE CREDENTIALING SYSTEM A
TEACHER TEACHING INDICATED OLD
SCHOOL CAN HAVE.
HE A MULTIPLE SUBJECT OR A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO TEACH ADULTS
AND IT'S VERY SPECIFIC ON THEIR
CREDENTIAL.
THEN THERE IS WHAT'S CALLED A
DESIGNATED SUBJECTS CREDENTIAL
IN THE THAT IS FOR SOMEONE WHO.
HAS A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
WISHES TO PERHAPS WORK WITH
ADULTS WHO ARE LEARNING ENGLISH
AND THEY WANT TO COME BACK AND
TEACH.
WRAPS THE RETIRED NOW AND AND
THEY WANT TO DO SOMETHING ELSE.
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND SO
THEN THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH
COURSE WORK TO EARN THAT
DESIGNATED SUBJECTS CREDENTIAL.
THE COURSE WORK REALLY FOCUSES
ON AND GO G. IN THE TEACHING O
ADULTS.
AND ADULT LEARNERS VERSUS
TEACHING CHILDREN WELL MAYBE
MAYBE I NEED TO ASK A DIFFERENT
QUESTION.
WHAT IS IT EXACTLY WERE TEACHING
IN THESE ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS?
ARE WE TEACHING BUT WE USED TO
CALL THE G. E. D..
PROGRAM ARE WE TEACHING --
CAREER TECH EDUCATION TYPE
COURSES WERE ACTUALLY TEACHING
BOTH OF THOSE OKAY AND ALL OF
THOSE FOR TEACHING ADULT BASIC
EDUCATION.
WHICH IS FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE LOW LEVEL LOW LEVELS OF
LITERACY. FOR TEACHING ADULTS
SECONDARY EDUCATION SO
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO RECEIVE
THEIR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA IS
THAT FOR SOME REASON WERE
DERAILED.
DURING THEIR NORMAL HIGH SCHOOL
CAREER OR HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY SUCH AS THE GED HIGH
SET OR TASK THOSE OF THE THREE
THAT WE ACCEPTED.
ME DOING CALIFORNIA.
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE --
ILL CIVICS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE MOVING INTO CITIZENSHIP
AND WANTING TO ASSIST THEIR
FAMILIES LEARNING HOW TO
ASSIMILATE INTO GRANT --
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS SHORT
TERM C. T. PROGRAMS.
THEY ALSO HAVE PROGRAMS FOR WORK
FORCE RE ENTRY.
INTO THE RESERVE A HOUR THE
WORK FOR SOMEONE TO COME BACK
INTO THE WORK FORCE.
AND PARENTS HELPING THEIR
CHILDREN IN -- IN SCHOOL AND
ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES SO --
OUR STATE FUNDING COVERS ALL OF
THOSE.
AREAS SO PERHAPS IN THE C. T.
AREAS SO SPECIAL ICT COURSES CAN
YOU GIVE ME SOME EXAMPLES.
I MEAN THE ONE LEGACY IN A LIKE
A CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT
OKAY WOULD BE A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
A SHORT TERM THEY HAVE TO BE
LESS THAN A YEAR PROGRAM.
AND THAT WOULD REQUIRE SOMEONE
THAT HAS AT EITHER INSTITUTION
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO HAVE A
STATE LICENSE JR TO BE ABLE TO
TEACH -- JORDAN FOR CNA SO WOULD
YOU NEED TO HAVE A CASE YOU
TWELVE TEACHING CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS SEE IN A COURSE ON A
CASE TO TWELVE CAMPUS YOU NEED
TO HAVE A C. D. E. CREDENTIAL.
THERE IS A CITY IN CREDENTIALS
FOR THAT FOR THAT.
REALLY.
IN HEALTH.
IN THAT AREA IN THAT AREA YES.
IF I MAY ACTUALLY.
SO.
THAT I CUT YOU OUT NO FOR JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY SOMETHING SO.
FOR ADULT SCHOOLS RUN IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
GENERALLY SPEAKING.
THE INSTRUCTORS NEED TO HAVE A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL ISSUED BY
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING IN ORDER TO
INSTRUCT.
STUDENTS IN ADULT EDUCATION
THERE IS ONE EXCEPTION THE
LEGISLATURE MADE TO THAT AND
THAT JUST HAPPENED ACTUALLY.
RECENTLY AND THAT'S FOR
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS
THERE'S BEEN A A CHANGE IN.
REQUIREMENTS OF RATIOS IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
SO YOU HAVE A LOT OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY SAYING THEY
NEED.
A WORKFORCE TO MEET THAT.
THAT HIGHER RATIO THAT THAT NEW
RATIO AS A RESULT THE
LEGISLATURE MADE AN EXCEPTION
AND SAID FOR CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANTS STRUCTURES.
INSTRUCTOR DOES NOT NEED TO HAVE.
A TEACHING CREDENTIAL IN ORDER
TO TEACH BUT FOR EVERYTHING ELSE
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN.
AUTOMOTIVE FOR SOME SORT OF
INTRODUCTORY AUTOMOTIVE TECH
WHATEVER THE PROGRAM IS A
ENGLISH SECOND LANGUAGE.
THE INSTRUCTOR IN AN ADULT
SCHOOL NEEDS TO HAVE A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL NOT SO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE JUST
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATE WHICH IS
GENERALLY SPEAKING NEED TO HAVE
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
ONLY TO MEET MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS TO TEACH AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
OUR ADULT EDUCATION COURSE WHICH
IS DIFFICULT IT'S DIFFICULT FOR
ADULTS SCHOOLS TO HIRE IF THEY
SEE AN INSTRUCTOR FROM COMMITTEE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO HIRE.
THAT THAT MAKES THINGS DIFFICULT.
IT'S ALSO RAISES AN ISSUE ABOUT
IS THE TEACHER CREDENTIAL REALLY.
OFFERING HIGHER QUALITY YOU KNOW
FOR THE STUDENTS YOU KNOW WE'VE
ACTUALIZED AREAS THE ANSWER TO
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN FOR EXAMPLE.
OR LET'S SAY YOU ONLY OFFER A
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN COURSE
BECAUSE HOPEFULLY WE'VE GOT THE
DEMAND SIDE OF THIS THING
FIGURED OUT.
AND YOU ONLY NEED ONE EVERY
THREE YEARS. TO MEET THE DEMAND
HOW HOW WOULD YOU.
HIRE AND RETAIN THE TEACHER IN A
CASE TO TWELVE SYSTEM. TO TEACH
SAYS SORT OF COURSE [inaudible]
WHEN?
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MAY BE ABLE TO
BRING SOMEBODY ON TO BRING A MAN
TO TEACH I MEAN I'M I'M JUST
THINKING.
THE SYSTEM PROBABLY WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SYSTEM
CONSISTENT WITH THE POLITICS
OUTSIDE OF THIS BUILDING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES ON
INSIDE OF K. THROUGH TWELVE
DISTRICTS. TO FIGURE OUT IF
THERE'S A WAY TO MAKE THIS A
LITTLE MORE AGILE WITHOUT
STEPPING ON ANYBODY'S TOES AND
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
PROPERLY CREDENTIALED AND AND
AND MY MAKING SENSE I MEAN FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOUR C. D. E. PROGRAM
YOU HAVE YOUR TEACHING.
SOMEONE YOU YOU NEED TO TRAIN
SOME PEOPLE IN THE ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
AS OPPOSED TO WHATEVER WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
IN IN COMPUTERIZED LOGISTICS
WAREHOUSE MANAGEMENT.
WHAT I NEED?
TO TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND I'M
GOING TO DO IT IN THE CASE YOU
TO ON THE CASE TO TWELVE CAMPUS
DO I NEED A TEACHING CREDENTIAL
FOR THAT YES YOU DO.
AND WHAT SORT OF BURDEN DOES
THAT IMPOSE ON A CASE TO TWELVE
DISTRICT IF THEY NEED TO HIRE A
CASE TO TWELVE INSTRUCTOR WITH
THE TEACHING CREDENTIAL TO TEACH
A COMPUTERIZED.
LOGISTICS MANAGEMENT COURSE.
ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS.
IF THEY WOULD CREATE A LARGE
BURDEN ON THAT ON THAT DISTRICT
HOWEVER. TO TEACH A C. T. E.
PROGRAM ON THE K. TWELVE
DISTRICT YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE.
A STANDARD KATE.
TWELVE CREDENTIAL YOU WOULD HAVE
A DESIGNATED SUBJECTS CREDENTIAL
WHICH MEANS THAT YOU'RE AN
EXPERT IN.
THAT AREA THAT YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
FIELD EXPERIENCE AND WORK
EXPERIENCE.
IN THAT AREA OF LOGISTICS SO
THAT YOU ARE AN EXPERT IN YOUR
BRINGING THAT INFORMATION TO THE
STUDENTS HOW EASY IS IT TO GET
THAT SORT OF CREDENTIAL IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING AND I KNOW THAT
MICHELLE MACINTOSH COULD HAVE
SHARED THAT.
CD INCENTIVE GRANT WILL AS WELL
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I'M
SUGGESTING CHALLENGING TOO
BECAUSE WE WE CAN'T IT'S HARD TO
BE COMPETITIVE SALARY WISE.
WE CAN'T WE'RE NOT GONNA SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM TODAY BUT I I DO
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT.
AND HAVE BRING ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE
INCLUDING THE ONES THAT ARE
PROTECTIVE OF CREDENTIALING AS
THEY SHOULD BE.
ABOUT TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
APPROPRIATE CASES WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY.
TO TEMPT IN THE SPECIALIZED
AREAS NOT ESL NOT.
SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY.
IN THE CASE YOU TWELVE
ENVIRONMENT.
BRING SPECIALIZED PLAYERS TO THE
TABLE SO WE'VE WE'VE THE NEEDS
OF ADULT STUDENTS AND THE NEED
OF FOLKS IN THE MARKETPLACE.
JUST ADD.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED.
DIFFERENCE IN FEES IN COURSE
FEES.
THESE ARE TWO SYSTEMS ADULT
EDUCATION COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT BIT AND CO EXISTED IN KIND
OF PARALLEL TRACKS.
FOR DECADES AND NOW LET YOUR
LEGISLATURE RECENTLY MADE THE
DECISION. TO TO HAVE THEM WORK
TOGETHER CONSORTIA AND TO TO
LEVERAGE EACH OTHERS COMPARATIVE
ADVANTAGES AND STRENGTH TO WORK
TOGETHER.
IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT AND IT'S
AND THERE STILL ARE INEQUITIES
AROUND THE STATE FOR STUDENTS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T FULLY AID AS
A STATE WE HAVEN'T FULLY
INTEGRATED.
THESE PROVIDERS YOU TO BE ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER AN EXAMPLE IS
WITH THE COURSE FEES STICKING
WITH THE EXAMPLE OF THE
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT.
PROGRAM [inaudible] FOUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THEIR NON
CREDIT ADULT INSTRUCTION THEY
ARE PROHIBITED BY LAW FROM
CHARGING COURSE FEES.
WERE AS FOR FOR ANY OF THOSE
ADULT EDUCATION COURSES BUT FOR
FOR THE K. TWELVE ADULT SCHOOLS
THEY ARE PERMITTED TO CHARGE
COURSE FEES FOR CORRECT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
SO FOR A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT YOU ARE SOMETHING WE
LOOK AT IS YOU GO -- TO SAY LONG
BEACH AND A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT PROGRAM AT LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE -- NEARBY
COMMUNICORP WHICH WOULD BE FREE
TO THAT STUDENT BUT IF THEY GO
THROUGH THE ADULT SCHOOL COULD
COST.
A THOUSAND MORE DOLLARS IN FEES
TO GO THROUGH THAT PROGRAM.
IN IN THE SAME AREA ANY ADULT
SCHOOLS WILL TELL YOU NOT THEY
DON'T CHARGE BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO THE CHARGE BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT GET AS MUCH MONEY STATE
MONEY. FOR INSTRUCTION AS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
TO AS MY COLLEAGUE.
MISS KING MENTIONED.
YOU DO NOT HAVE WE DO NOT HAVE A
SET AMOUNT.
PER STUDENT A STANDARD AMOUNT
PER STUDENT CURRENTLY IN THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES VERSUS ADULTS%
SCHOOLS YOU HAVE WERE ALL OVER
THE MAP ON ON THE ADULT SCHOOLS
AND WHAT THEY GET FUNDED NOT
IT'S NOT.
EIGHTY EIGHT RIGHT CORRECT THEY
GET THEY GET A AN AMOUNT TO THE
CONSORTIUM THE CONSORTIUM
DECIDES.
HOW MUCH THE PROVIDERS GET THE
PROVIDERS?
A SERVICE STUDENTS THEY CAN
SERVE AS MANY AS THEY CAN.
IN ANY WITH THE ADULT SCHOOLS
AND SO YOU REALLY DO HAVE
DIFFERENCES DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES DIFFERENT FEES
CHARGED DIFFERENT FUNDING
AMOUNTS PROVIDED TO THE TO THE
ADULT EDUCATION.
ENTITIES JUST DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THEY'RE AN ADULT SCHOOL
COMMUNICATION WHERE THEY ARE SO
JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF SOME OF
THE INEQUITIES THAT EVENTUALLY
LEGISLATURES GONNA NEED TO
GRAPPLE WITH I THINK.
TO WE THINK IN ORDER TO TO
REALLY HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S
COHESIVE COHERENT WORKING
TOGETHER IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY
SO IS THE SOLUTION TO
STANDARDIZE THE APPROACH OR TO
GIVE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
THE SAME DISCRETION THAT THE
CASE YOU TWELVE OPERATION AND WE
THINK THEY DID.
THE BEST WAY FORWARD WOULD BE TO
STANDARDIZE THE FEET TO THE TO
ASSURE THE ADULT SCHOOLS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF FINDING.
OF GENERAL FUND AMOUNT AND
HAVING MORE MORE THE
STANDARDIZATION LIKE WE HAVE
CURRENTLY WITH CANELO SHE'S
UNITY COLLEGES TO RECOVER
[inaudible]
COST.
WELL CURRENTLY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES GET ENOUGH FUNDING.
FROM THE STATE AND AND AND AND
JUST OVERALL FUNDING THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE INSTRUCTION SERVICES
STUDENTS WITHOUT CHARGING THAT
FEE WHERE IS THE ADULT SCHOOLS.
NOT NECESSARILY THE CASE THEY
HAVE TO CHARGE FEES. TO TO MAKE
UP FOR THAT THE LACK OF FUNDING
ARE CURRENTLY GETTING IN MANY
CASES.
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO THE FIRST
FLOOR.
ANYTHING ELSE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND TAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
LIKE A REAL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
EVERYBODY CUED UP SO THIS IS A
PUBLIC COMMENT I NORMALLY DON'T --
SET TIME LIMITS BUT I WOULD ASK
YOU TO LOOK BEHIND YOU AND SEE
THE LENGTH OF THE LINE SO.
BRIEF IS BETTER IF YOU CAN YES
MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AGREE YOU AND
MEMORY OF SENATOR ALFORD ALQUIST
WHO AUTHORED SENATE BILL ONE
SIXTY FOUR ESTABLISHING YOUR PS
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
SENATOR ALQUIST UNDERSTOOD THAT
ARE MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED STUDENTS OFTEN GET LOST
IN THE VERY THE COMPETING
INTERESTS THAT THE SYSTEM IN
LOCAL CAMPUSES.
ARE AS THE PRESIDENT ELECT OF
THE UPS ASSOCIATION MY NAME IN
THE LIST PRICE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR MAINTAINING YOUR PS
CARING NEXT TOP AS A
CATEGORICAL PROGRAM FOR
PROTECTING SERVICES FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
RECENTLY EMANCIPATED FOSTER
YOUTH ARE KERR STUDENTS WORKING
TOWARDS SELF SUFFICIENT FREE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
VETERANS AND THOSE WHO NEED
INTENTIONAL AND INTRUSIVE
ACADEMIC AND PERSONAL SUPPORT.
TO SUCCEED IN COLLEGE -- WE
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE WRAP
AROUND SERVICES TO THOSE
STUDENTS CURRENTLY. 309-800-0600
ELEVEN AND A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
COLLEGES WERE ASKING TODAY FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
AUGMENTATION THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO CLEAR A WAITING LIST OF ABOUT.
FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS -- WE
POLLED CAMPUSES RECENTLY ABOUT
SIXTY EIGHT RESPONDED THERE
ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
THEY CANNOT SERVE -- AND SO
WE'RE ASKING -- THAT YOU MAKE
THAT INVESTMENT IN THE O. P. S.
IT'S THE FIFTY YEAR PROGRAM WITH
THE TRUE APPROVED IN A TRACK
RECORD IN IT IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED. TO HELP CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
I AND TO PROVIDE A SKILLED
WORKFORCE FOR CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AND
THE FIRST THING -- THANK YOU FOR
COMING.
I'M TEACHING THEM THE OPS
STUDENT AND I'M HERE TO SAY THAT
IT HAS BEEN A BIT OF ME.
A LOT WELL SERVICES THAT THEY
PROVIDE IN.
YES IF YOU COULD GO KEEP
CHARGING AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE I'M FROM
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE AND
I'M ANOTHER ETHIOPIA'S STUDENT.
AND MY BACKGROUND IS IN BUSINESS
AND EDUCATION.
AND THIS PROGRAM HAS HELPED ME
OUT A LOT I'M THE FIRST --
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND COLLEGE IS A
GREAT THING SINCE I WAS A CHILD
I ALWAYS KNEW I WANTED TO ATTEND
COLLEGE SO THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM IT PROVIDES TEXTBOOKS
AND SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND I REALLY THINK HIS IS A
GREAT PROGRAM AND THE FURTHER
FUNDING WOULD HELP.
OTHER STUDENTS.
WE'LL DO THE BEST WE CAN KEEP
PLUGGING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
YES MA'AM HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PAULA JASSEM UPS
DIRECTOR OF INTER COLLEGE I'M
HERE SPEAK UP ON BEHALF UPS ALSO --
SENATOR ALQUIST AUTHOR ANNE
GENIUS LEGISLATION THAT RESULTED
IN UPS REGULATIONS.
THAT NOT ONLY RULING IDEAL PS
PROTECTED UPS HAS BEEN
ACCOUNTABLE AND CONTINUES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SERVING STUDENTS.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCES
OFFICES A PROPONENT OF
FLEXIBILITY IN ITS OVERSIGHT OF
THE SYSTEM.
THIS FLEXIBILITY SMACKS TO SOME
OF US AS NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
IS THIS FLEXIBILITY WHAT HAS LED
US TO MILLIONS OF SHORTFALL IN
OUR SYSTEM.
WE HAVE YET TO SEE REAL RESULTS
MY CHANCES OFFICE INITIATIVE
THERE HAS BEEN LITTLE SCRUTINY
ACCOUNTABILITY AS TO WHERE THE
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE
LANDING OR WHERE THE OR WHAT
THEY ARE CHEATING.
WE ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF UPS IT WORKS IT HAS
BEEN ACCOUNTABLE WE ASK THE
COUNCIL'S OFFICE IS ALSO HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ASK THAT YOU -- PSP KEPT
WHOLE NOT SUBJECT TO TITLE FIVE
REGULATORY CHANGES CONSOLIDATION
BLOCK GRANT FUNDING.
OR ANY OTHER DESTABILISATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM THANKS
FOR JOINING US YES MA'AM.
A LITTLE TALLER -- GOOD
AFTERNOON -- MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MY NAME IS DOLLY KING I AM
REPRESENTING THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALSO NOTICE
BACK -- I JUST WANNA SAY THAT WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED COLA AND SIGNIFICANT
CASTERS CONTRIBUTIONS -- WE'RE
ALSO APPRECIATIVE AS WILLIAM
WILLINGNESS TO PAUSE AND TO
REVISE THE STUDENT CENTERED
FUNDING FORMULA -- BACK ALSO
APPRECIATES THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE FOR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR FULL TIME FACULTY IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
I WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
OF FULL AND PART TIME FACULTY --
THE INCREASE INVESTMENT WILL
ALLOW US TO MAKE MORE PROGRESS
ON RECRUITING HIGH QUALITY AND
DIVERSE FACULTY INTO OUR
COLLEGES WHICH NEEDS TO BE A TOP
PRIORITY -- NOW SO DURING LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET CONVERSATIONS BACK
HAD SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
THE FUNDING FORMULA.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
PERFORMANCE BASED METRICS.
THAT WOULD DELIVER UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THE GREATEST SYSTEM
OF WINNERS AND LOSERS.
THESE CONCERNS ARE NOW.
AS THE FORMULA HAS ALREADY
PROVEN TO BE FINANCIALLY
UNSUSTAINABLE AND UNPREDICTABLE --
WE UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE IN THIS
PROCESS HOWEVER WE CANNOT DELAY
MAKING THE NECESSARY CHANGES TO
THE FORMULA I MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT PERFORMANCE BASED FUNDING
WILL NEVER BE THE BEST APPROACH
FOR STUDENTS -- FINALLY WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FULLY ONLINE
COLLEGE.
AND DO NOT BELIEVE THAT IS THE
BEST INVESTMENT FOR STUDENTS.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY FACULTY
WHO'VE BEEN DEVELOPING BEST
PRACTICES CONTENT EXPERIENCE IN
PROVIDING ONLINE OPTIONS FOR
THEIR STUDENTS OVER THE LAST TWO
DECADES.
HOWEVER NONE OF THEM WERE
INCLUDED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
AN ONLINE COLLEGE.
SO NOW THAT NOW WE HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE FACULTY ON THE
OUTSIDE WATCHING AS NO GOOD
CONTRACTS ARE ANNOUNCED AND
ACCEPTED WITH OUT SO MUCH AS A
HEADS UP.
DESPITE ALL THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THESE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANKS
FOR JOINING US YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN I STARTED
THIS MIKE REILLY CAN KATE WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATE.
AND WE ARE SO EXCITED TO HEAR
THE CONVERSATION TODAY AROUND
ADDRESSING BASIC NEEDS AND
MENTALHEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AS THE HOPE CENTER SURVEY
REVEALED 5260% OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS RESPECTIVELY
ARE REPORTING FOOD AND HOUSING
IN SECURITY.
WE NEED TO STOP GAP MEASURES
REAL FINANCIAL AID REFORM AND A
STATEWIDE COMMITMENT TO DOING
SURVEYS.
LIKE THE ONES IN THE HOPE.
OF REPORT TO REGULARLY LIFT UP
BARRIERS FACED BY OUR FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOME --
STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THIS
COMMITTEE ON THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR FRED JONES ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR BUILDING WITH
DUAL ENROLLMENT HALF OF MY
TEACHERS ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE OTHER HALF FOR K..
TWELVE WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL FOR
THIS BODY PUTTING SET ASIDE
DOLLARS FOR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND SEE TAKEN STRONG
WORK FORCE.
WE THINK THOUGH TO HOLD THESE
DOLLARS ACCOUNTABLE THERE NEEDS
TO BE CLEAR STATE STAFF STATE
OVERSIGHT REGIONALLY LOCATED
WHICH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION USED TO DO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
THEY NO LONGER HAVE THAT
CAPACITY.
SO THAT IS ONE THING WE ARE
PUSHING FOR ONE SIDE OF THE COIN
IS THE DOLLARS THE OTHER SIDE IS
THE STAFF TO HOLD THOSE DOLLARS
ACCOUNTABLE SO WE'LL DO ALL WE
CAN TO WORK WITH YOU IN THAT.
GOT IT.
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON LEILANI I CANNOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY EACH APA
COALITION OR COALITION HAS BEEN
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE C. T.
INCENTIVE CURRENT PROGRAM OVER
THE YEARS.
AND WE SUPPORT CURRENT EFFORTS
TO TRY TO PROVIDE ALL OF THE K.
TWELVE C. T. FUNDS EXCLUSIVELY
THROUGH SEE TECH.
WE BELIEVE THAT C. TAKE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN PROVIDING ONGOING
FUNDING TO K. TWELVE PROGRAMS
WITH ANNUAL ACCOUNTABILITY THAT
ENABLES US TO MAINTAIN.
AND IMPROVE CT PROGRAM
SYSTEMATICALLY IN A WAY THAT THE
INCENTIVE GRANT WAS.
ON DESIGNS AND WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE C. TAKE METRICS ARE
CLEAR IN FOCUS ON THE ELEMENTS
THAT MAKE UP HIGH QUALITY CTP
WHICH INCLUDES RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES. FOR
ARTICULATION DUAL ENROLLMENT
ETCETERA.
THE STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM IN
THE MEANTIME WE BELIEVE HAS ONLY
ADDED ANOTHER LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY THAT DOESN'T DO.
AND THAT DOES NOT ADD VALUE TO
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE SEE TV PROGRAMS.
AND WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS
ABOUT THE GROUND METRICS WHICH
ARE THE SAME AS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM
METRICS WHAT THAT MEANS FOR K.
TWELVE PROGRAMS.
IS THAT THE EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR
PROGRAMS WILL BE DEMONSTRATED
FOR MANY YEARS SOMETIMES AS MANY
AS FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS BECAUSE
THE METRICS OCCUR ONLY AFTER
STUDENT COMPLETES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
AND FINALLY HAT -- THE CATO
STRONG WORK FIRST PROGRAM
METRICS ALSO.
DO NOT AND CONSIDER STUDENTS TO
ENROLL IN UNIVERSITY
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE
OTHER PATHWAYS OUTSIDE OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AFTER THEY'VE
COMPLETED HIGH SCHOOL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
I AM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
MEMBER -- I TEACH MATH -- AT
YOUR BOW COLLEGE IN HAYWARD MY
NAME IS DAVE OKAY I'M ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE SHIP -- LAST
PROCEED AS FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
FUNDING FORMULA AND SPECIFICALLY
THE SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION
APART THAT'S BASED ON FINANCIAL
AID.
AND I APPRECIATE THE DESIRE TO
DEVOTE 20% OF FUNDING TO
RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
BUT 20% IS A VERY LARGE SLICE
GIVEN THAT IT WAS SET UP IN
ESSENTIALLY TO ROB PETER TO PAY
PAUL.
AND I ASK YOU TO WRAP YOUR BRAIN
AROUND THE IDEA THAT UNDER.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION SOME
DISTRICTS WILL LOSE AS MUCH AS
10% OF THEIR TOTAL FUNDING.
WHILE OTHERS WILL GAIN AS MUCH
AS A 10% WHEN FULL THAT IS
ALMOST A 20% SWING IN THE
NUMBERS THAT I PASSED OUT OR TO
TO SUPPORT THAT CLAIM.
THE LOSER DISTRICTS TEND TO BE
IN HIGH CST REGIONS -- WHERE IT
IS HARDER FOR STUDENTS TO
QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL AID -- AND
THAT IS IT IS THE CASE EVENWHEN
STUDENTS.
WE STILL HAVE STUDENTS WHO DON'T
QUALIFY FOR FINANCIAL AID EVEN
THOUGH THEY FACE FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURITY SO THERE'S
A BIG DISCONNECT THERE THAT WERE
THERE.
IS STILL EXIST AND IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE IT'S GONNA GET CLOSE
BY THE FUNDING FORMULA.
BUT IN HIGH COST REGIONS THOSE
DISTRICTS ALSO HAVE HIGHER
STAFFING COSTS AND WHILE MOST OF
THESE DISTRICTS ARE ON HOLD
HARMLESS FOR THE MOMENT -- THE
CLIFF IS LOOMING IF THIS FLAW IS
NOT FIXED MANY OF THESE
DISTRICTS WILL BE FORCED INTO
DRACONIAN CUTS AND ALL OF THEIR
STUDENTS WILL SUFFER INCLUDING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS.
WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL ALLOCATION
WAS INTENDED TO SUPPORT NOW I'VE
DONE SOME WORK ON AS A MATH GUY
DO AT WORK ANALYZING BUDGETS FOR
DISTRICT AND SO ON I'VE ACTUALLY
TRIED MODELING SOME SUPPOSE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FIXES TO THIS PROBLEM
AND IT'S ACTUALLY NOT THAT HARD
TO DO.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A PRICE
TAG ASSOCIATED WITH IT BUT I I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT THE THE
COST FOR FIXING THIS IS LESLIE
VAN EXTENDING THE CURRENT HOLD
HARMLESS IN PERPETUITY.
SO THEY CAN BE DONE FOR LESS
COST THAN THAT -- BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TO FIX THIS OTHERWISE A LOT
OF STUDENTS WILL SUFFER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO COME DOWN
AND TALK TO US.
YES MA'AM.
I AFTERNOON TERASA AND THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMITTEE FOR AN
EXCELLENT -- AND THOROUGH
ANALYSIS MY NAME IS LIZ THAT
NEVER IT AND WITH THE MYTHOLOGY
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA IN COLLEGE DISTRICTS --
WE FIRST ONE IN A MENTION THAT
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
STRONG COAL THAT IS PROVIDED AND
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
APPROACH -- TO PERSON STIRS
SPECIFICALLY THAT PERSON THE
SISTERS CONTRIBUTION -- AND WE
SUPPORT THOSE MEASURES WE DO
WANT -- TO MENTIONED THAT IN THE
LETTER THAT WILL BE WE'VE
PROVIDED THE OUTLINE A FEW
SENSIBLE MODIFICATIONS TO THE US
STUDENT CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA.
ONE OF THE KEY ONES THAT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT IS THAT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE TOTAL
COMPUTATIONAL REVENUE.
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
PLUS THE COLA BE ADOPTED AS A
NEW BASE FOR DISTRICTS AS A WAY
OF A STABILIZING DISTRICTS --
FROWNED AT FUTURE LOSSES -- AND
WE OUTLINE IF IF YOU OTHER
MODIFICATIONS WERE ALSO VERY
CONCERNED WITH A PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE -- ESTIMATES THAT WERE
HIGHER THAN WAS ACTUALLY
ALLOCATED TO DISTRICTS AND WE
HOPE THAT THE MAY REVISE THAT
CAN BE CORRECTED -- SO THAT CUTS
TO SERVICES ARE NOT MADE -- AND
THAT WE DON'T HURT STUDENTS THAT
WERE ACTUALLY TRYING.
TO HELP.
AND THEN LASTLY I'LL MENTION
THAT -- SIMILARLY TO YOU WE ARE
VERY PERPLEXED WITH THE APPROACH
THAT HAS BEEN TAKEN TO A
FACILITY SPENDING AND THE SLOW
RELEASE OF PROP FIFTY ONE
RESOURCES.
COLLEGES ARE EXPERIENCING FOR
MONTHS WHICH MEANS THAT AT THE
END OF THE DAY TAXPAYERS ARE
GETTING LESS.
FROM ON WHAT THEY INVESTED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE COLLEGES AND
WHAT WILL ACTUALLY BE THE RESULT
SO WE URGE THAT YOU.
FIND ALL THE PROJECTS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
PLAN ADOPTED BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
MR JOURDAN'S KHAKI ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR ADULT
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA DOLE
ASSOCIATION.
BOTH K. TWELVE ADULT EDUCATION
PROVIDERS IN THE STATE -- COUPLE
THINGS WITH REGARD TO THE
CREDENTIALING ISSUE AND YOUR
QUESTIONS I'VE REACHED OUT
YOURSELF TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT WE
DO HAVE A A SIMPLY BE A VEHICLE
OF SOME LEGAL SIXTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER WOULD
AGREE -- SO WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT ISSUE I WITH REGARD TO
FUNDING I WOULD THERE HAS BEEN
SOME OPPORTUNITIES ARE PROVIDED --
PROVIDERS ARE GIVEN THE
FLEXIBILITY -- BUT THERE ARE
STILL SOME ONGOING DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THAT.
WITH REGARD TO FEES I'M IN THE
CONTEXT OF A BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
HAVE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON AND
THE ASSEMBLY I WOULD REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT INCLUDES PERFORMANCE BASED
FUNDING TO SERVE HARD TO SURVIVE
AND HIGH NEED POPULATIONS
ADDITIONALLY ANOTHER THIRTY
MILLION IT AS PART OF THAT.
HUNDRED TEN TO ADDRESS THOSE C.
T. E. FEED RELATED ISSUE AND
PROVIDE SOME OPPORTUNITIES TO
LOWER FEES FOR OUR STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE FINAL COMPONENT
OF THAT HUNDRED TEN MILLION IS
FIFTY MILLION TO HELP COVER
INCREASING COSTS ASSOCIATE WITH
PURRS STIRRERS WHAT HAVE YOU AS
WELL AS TO GROW CAPACITY IN THE
ADULT EDUCATION SYSTEM ALTHOUGH
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
ADMINISTRATIONS INCLUSION OF A
COLA AS PART.
OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
ADULT EDUCATION TACKLE IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOT -- ADDRESSING
THE COST INCREASES WHICH RANGE
BETWEEN FIVE AND 10% EACH YEAR
FOR ADULT SCHOOLS ABSENT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ARE THEY ARE
IN THE POSITION WHERE THEY'RE
MAKING CURRENT BUDGET YOUR CUTS
TO PROGRAMS.
OR AT MINIMUM HAVE TO LOOK AT
THAT FOR THE FOLLOWING YEAR
WHICH MEANS SOME OF THE MOST
MARGINALIZED ON IMMIGRANT
STUDENTS WHO NEED CITIZENSHIP
YES CELL PATHWAYS.
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
SOME WITH MY SHORT TERM CAREER
TRAINING IN BASIC SKILLS AND I
COULD GO ON THAT SO APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THAT
REQUEST WE ARE FOLLOWING UP WITH
STUFF GOOD THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT PATTON FROM
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
MONEY.
BOTH K..
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE AND THE
C. TWO DOLLARS THAT ARE IN THE
BUDGET.
I WOULD ECHO THE SENTIMENT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY ACCOUNTABILITY AS
IS AS IMPORTANT AS THE MONEY IS
MAKING SURE THAT THEE ARE
REGIONAL EXPERTS.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO HELP
SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE USING THEIR
DOLLARS EFFECTIVELY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS FOR
JOINING US [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDMANAT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
EDUCATION REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE SUPPORT FOR THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION SIDE OF
THINGS -- BUT WE ARE PRETTY
CONCERNED ABOUT STRONG WORK
FORCE.
AND THE FACT THAT SOME OF THAT
MONEY IN THIS PROPOSED BUDGET IS
COMING FROM ONE TEN SETTLE UP
FUNDS.
MOST NOTABLY WERE CONCERNED THAT
THERE MAY BE AN ISSUE.
A CHILLING EFFECT FROM THOSE
COMING FROM ONE TIME FUNDS --
AND WE WONDER WHERE THOSE FUNDS
WOULD COME FROM IT NEXT YEAR
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MEET OUT AT
SOME POINT WITH YOUR OFFICE IN
THE OTHER OFFICES THAT SIT ON
THIS COMMITTEE TO DISCUSS SOME
OF THE DATA ISSUES [inaudible]
AT THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND THE QUESTIONS
YOU ASKED ABOUT TRUMP.
LOOK FORWARD TO MEETING WITH YOU
[inaudible]
YES SIR.
NICOLAS JARVIS ON BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THEN MONICA COLLEGE LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
AND THE MORE OF THE LA AS
RECOMMENDATION. TO INCREASE THE
DISPERSION OF PROPOSITION --
FIFTY ONE BOND FUNDING. FOR THAT
CAN'T CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
APPROVED CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDING FOR SP.
TWO NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE OFF MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WES YOU TOUCH ON
A FEW THINGS FIRST.
WE S. LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH A
SECOND AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD WE BELIEVE
WE CAN DO MORE TO COVER THE
BASIC NEEDS OF OUR CLINICAL
STUDENTS -- SPECIALLY WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THE DATA COMING FROM
THE HELP CENTER'S REAL COLLEGE
SURVEY SO REALLY HOPING TO TAKE
LEE ON THAT.
PART. THIRTY TWO W. SUPPORTS THE
STUDENTS CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA AND IT'S EQUITABLE AND
TEND TO FOCUS ON STUDENT SUCCESS
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR --
WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
DETAILS ON HOW THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AN OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
WILL ADDRESS DATA QUALITY ISSUES --
AND THE LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY
OF THIS WE STAND READY TO HELP
OUT IN ANYWAY POSSIBLE.
FOURTH WE APPRECIATE THE ALLEY
AS VERY HONEST ANALYSIS OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM WE VIEW THIS PROGRAM AS
A STRATEGY AIMED AT COLLEGE
AWARENESS AND ACCESS.
UNFORTUNATELY COLLEGES WERE NOT
USING THE FLEXIBILITY PROVISION
WITHIN THAT LAW -- ARE
PRIORITIZING THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS WHO WHO DO NOT HAVE AS
HIGH A NEED -- SO WE ASK
LEGISLATURE TO DEMAND MORE AND
BETTER DATE ON HOW THESE FUNDS
ARE BEING USED AND LASTLY WE
SUPPORT -- CENTER LABORS AS
SPEAK TO ANYONE THINKING.
THANKS FOR JOINING YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION TO SPEAK TO
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY ITEM.
WE URGE YOU TO FIND ALL THIRTY
NINE OF THE NEW PROJECTS THAT
WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN THEIR
SPENDING PLAN WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE TO PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS OFF OF THAT
PLAN.
BUT WE ALSO ECHO THE CONCERN
THAT DISTRICTS ARE VERY CONFUSED
BY THE TWO COMPETING STANDARDS
ON PRIORITIZING PROJECTS.
WHEN VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION
FIFTY ONE THEY APPROVED TWO
BILLION DOLLARS -- FOR MORE THAN
JUST HEALTH AND SAFETY PROJECTS
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BOND
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT CONSTRUCTION
RENOVATION RECONSTRUCTION OF
QUIPPING.
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS SO
THAT CERTAINLY BROADER THAN JUST
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS REALLY IN
THE BEST POSITION TO ASSESS THE
SYSTEM'S FACILITY PRIORITIES
FROM THAT STATE WIDE PERSPECTIVE.
LASTLY YOU ARE ON THE ISSUE OF
INCORPORATING VISION FOR SUCCESS
METRICS.
INTO THAT EVALUATION AND
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS WE JUST
URGE YOU TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
USING NON FACILITIES FACTORS --
WHEN YOUR FUNDING CAPITAL OUTLAY
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE SO MUCH
DATA AND INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ACTUAL CONDITION?
ALL OF OUR SITES WE USE THE
FUSION SYSTEM TO UPLOAD OF VERY
MY NEW TO DETAIL ABOUT THE
CONDITION OF ALL OF OUR
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SIR.
THANKS FOR SHARE OUR MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
MOUNTAIN TO SING -- TO YUBA SAN
BERNADINO FERTILITY ANSWER KERN
LOS ANGELES PERALTA.
SAN DIEGO AND SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AS
LONG AS THE AS WELL AS THE LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE FACULTY GUILT.
AND I WANT TO ADDRESS REAL
QUICKLY THE PROP FIFTY ONE
FACILITIES WE WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU.
THE DISTRICT'S WHEN AND AND THEY
WERE PLAYING BY THE RULES AS
THEY PROPOSED MADE THEIR
PROPOSALS.
AND THEY FEEL LIKE THE RULES OF
THE GAME HAVE BEEN CHANGED ON
THEM.
ON THE BUDGET -- ONE THE NEW
STUDENT SUCCESS FUNDING FORMULA
ONE SUGGESTION THAT WE WOULD
MAKE WOULD BE TO LOOK AT THE
EQUITY ALLOCATION.
BY COLLEGE AS OPPOSED TO
DISTRICT THERE TOUCH POINTS ON
THOSE STUDENTS AT EACH COLLEGE
THAT THEY ATTEND.
THE OTHER THING IS WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
INCREASE IN E PROMISE.
PROGRAM -- IT REALLY CREATES A
COLLEGE GOING CULTURE AT EACH OF
THOSE LOCAL AREAS -- FINALLY --
WE WOULD ASK THAT YOU LOOK AT
NON CREDIT AND CHANGING THE
ACCOUNTING MECHANISM FOR NON
CREDIT FROM CENSUS STATE -- FROM
POSITIVE ATTENDANTS TO CENSUS
DATE THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON I THINK IT IS
MISTER TURNER CALL RICE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION -- ALSO
WE ARE PROUD TO BE THE CO CHAIRS
OF THE GET REAL COALITION REAL
STANDING FOR RELEVANCE IN
EDUCATION AND LEARNING ALONG
WITH OUR PARTNERS FROM THE
CONSTRUCTION BUILDING TRADES --
JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION AND DELIBERATION
ON ALL THE ISSUES PARTICULARLY
ON THE KERR TAKE EDUCATION
INCENTIVE GRANT AND ALSO -- THE
PROGRAM'S INCORPORATION TO THE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM OF WE
ALSO AGREE WITH THE CHAIRMAN
RELATED TO THE DEMAND SIDE OF
THIS EQUATION AS INDUSTRY WE ARE
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE LINING WITH
THE REGIONAL NEEDS.
AND THAT THE PROGRAM DELIVERY AS
WELL AS THE DEVELOPMENT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THOSE JOB
NEEDS ARE IN THE REGION.
WE THINK THAT THE BEST WAY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT AS HAS BEEN
STATED IS WITH SOME STRONG STATE
LEADERSHIP THAT IS REGIONALLY
DELIVERED.
THAT WILL BRING ABOUT STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY SO AGAIN WE'RE
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS
ARE CONNECTING TO PROGRAMS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE WE UNDERSTAND THIS
IS A PHYSICAL COMMITTEE -- SO WE
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO YOU -- UP.
PRESENT TO YOU ALSO THE
DELIBERATION RELATED TO THE
AMOUNT OF REQUESTS THAT ARE
PROGRAM AND STILL THAT AMOUNT TO
A REQUEST IS ALMOST DOUBLE --
THE FUNDING THAT IS AVAILABLE SO
IF THE COMMITTEE SO INCLINED TO
CONSIDER -- INCREASED RESOURCES
TO ALLOW FOR MORE AND ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMS TO BE CREATED WE WOULD
APPRECIATE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT AGAIN.
IT NEEDS TO BE CONNECTED TO THE
POLICY DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
STRONG LEADERSHIP A AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MA'AM [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ROTH
IRA AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM A LEXUS THERE GOES THE OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS AND
I'M ALSO A STUDENT AT MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE -- I AM HERE TO
SUPPORT SB -- TWO NINETY ONE SO
ONLY 5% OF OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE
CAL GRANT EVEN THOUGH 43%
QUALIFY AS YOU ALREADY KNOW --
AND THE REASON WHY IS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ONLY GET 7% CAGR FUNDS -- I AM
PART OF THE 95% THAT DOES NOT
GET FINANCIAL AID DESPITE BEING
CONSIDERED IN POVERTY.
THE LACK OF FUNDING RESULTS IN
STUDENTS INCLUDING MYSELF BEING
FORCED TO SLEEP IN OUR CARS TO
THE HOUSING AND SECURITY.
CHOOSING TO SPEND OUR LAST FIVE
DOLLARS ON EITHER GAS OR FOOD
FREQUENTLY.
UP PARKING ACCOUNT BIG BIG
DONALD PARKING LOTS JUST TO
FINISH OUR ASSIGNMENTS AT NIGHT --
DROPPING CLASSES TO ALLOW US TO
HAVE A SECOND JOB.
AND EVEN -- THE IDEA OF TRANSFER
IN BECOMING A LOOMING FEAR
RATHER THAN SOMETHING TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT -- AND BE PROUD OF
BECAUSE OF THE OF THE LACK OF
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE.
OUR SINS ARE CAPABLE AND IF
GIVEN THE RESOURCES THEY ARE
PROVEN TO DO WELL SO I ASK FOR
YOU TO SUPPORT -- TO SP TWO
NINETY ONE AND TO INCLUDE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET TO FIGHT THESE
PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR COMING TO
JOIN A SERVER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ROTH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ALICE WALKER GRIP AND MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS HAVE YOUR
DATE HERE TODAY TO ASK YOU IN
FAVOR OF SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO NINETY ONE REASON WHY I'M
SAYING THIS IS BECAUSE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS BASED
CHALLENGES THAT OUR PARTNERS IN
THE C. S. USING THE UC SYSTEM
DON'T QUITE FRANKLY SEE.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS ARE COMING
IN WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
EXPERIENCE IN LIFE AND ABOUT NOT
DIRECTLY OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL IT'S
OPENED UP A WORLD OF CHALLENGES
THAT MANY STUDENTS IN THE C. S.
USING YOU SEE SYSTEMS OFTEN BASE.
TO THE PROBLEM THE PROBLEMS OF
PUTIN SECURITIES TRANSPORTATION
AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE SO
pEVERYDAY ACADEMICS WHICH IS WHY
I WOULD ASK YOU TO NUMBER WITH
SP TWO NINETY ONE WE CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES BY
PROVIDING MORE EQUITABLE
FINANCIAL AID RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS.
SO STUDENTS WILL HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT CAN A PAPER BOOK OR PAY
FOR GAS OR WONDER WHERE THE NEXT
MEAL IS GONNA COME FROM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
YES SIR AFTERNOON ALEXANDER
MARTINEZ M. J. C. AND ASSOCIATES
THERE'S A MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE
US SENATOR -- I PRESENT TWENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND JC.
AND BEING A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES STUDENT AND SENATOR
I'VE DEALT FIRST HAND WITH FOOD
AND SECURITY HOMELESSNESS AND
GENERAL FINANCIAL SECURITY.
AS IT PERTAINS NOT ONLY FOR MY
FRIENDS AND FAMILY BUT THE
STUDENTS THAT I REPRESENT.
FINANCIAL SECURITY IS AT THE
CORE OF THE PROBLEMS WE FACE.
THE STRESS OF WONDERING WHERE
OUR NEXT MEAL WILL COME.
OR IF WE'LL BE ABLE TO
FINANCIALLY MAINTAIN OURSELVES
IN A FULL TIME SCHEDULE HAMPERS
OUR ABILITY TO FOCUS AND BE
EFFICIENT.
THIS IS WHY I'M ASKING YOU TODAY
TO CONSIDER SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO NINE ONE AND TO INSURE THAT
THE END GOAL OF STUDENT SUCCESS
COMES FORTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BRIDGE
GOVERNMENT JUST MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA REMEMBER
HALF THE HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WE
SUPPORT CENTER AWAY THIS SP.
TWO NINETY ONE AND ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT THE
COMPLETE FINANCIALLY REFORM.
THAT SERVES CALIFORNIA'S
NEEDIEST STUDENTS FIRST -- OUR
STUDENTS ALSO NEED NOT ONLY
ACCESS TO HIGHER ED AND THE
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT HELP
THEM SUCCEED IN HIGHER EDUCATION
BUT THEY NEED THAT IF THE SAUDIS
THAT ARE NOT ONLY SAFE.
BUT OUR MODERN AND SO WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT THE
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT.
SAYING THAT I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS THEY'RE STILL HERE
FOR PARTICIPATION WAS AN
EXCELLENT CONVERSATION AND WE
HAVE FINISHED THE AGENDA SO WE
ARE.
ADJOURNED